SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DARLEY. DODD. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD. LIMON
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA. BOGUE.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO.
CIERTO. SKINNER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB
WIENER. WILK MEMBERS. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE.
WE'LL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. AND LET
US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. AND ON THIS, HARVEY
MILK DAY, WE PRAY. MERCIFUL GOD,
GRANT US THE GRACE TO FOLLOW THE
EXAMPLE OF OUR BROTHER HARVEY
MILK. THAT WE MIGHT FEARLESSLY
CONTEND AGAINST EVIL AND MAKE NO
PEACE WITH OPPRESSION. MAY WE
EMPLOY OUR FREEDOM AND OUR
PRIVILEGE IN THE MAINTENANCE OF
JUSTICE IN ALL OUR COMMUNITIES,
CITIES, AND AMONG THE NATIONS.
WE PRAY TO BE AGENTS OF CHANGE
AND PROCLAIMERS OF THE HOPE THAT
WILL NEVER BE SILENT. WE ASK
THIS IN YOUR NAME. YOU WHO HAVE
CALLED US TO WALK IN LOVE
TOGETHER. AMEN. MEMBERS, JOIN ME
IN THE PLEDGE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FOR.
I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO INTRODUCE SENATOR HURTADO'S
HUSBAND, GERBERT TI¾N BOSCH.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. OUR NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR. IT WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. NOW
IS THE TIME TO REMOVE ANY BILL
FROM THE CALENDAR TODAY. FROM
THE FILE. SEEING NO MEMBER
WISHING TO DO THAT, WE'RE MOVING
ON NOW. WE'RE ON CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE SEN. SECOND
READING SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 347. THIRD. SECOND
READING COMPLETE. NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO SENATE. THIRD READING
MEMBERS, ARE YOU PREPARED? WE
HAVE A FULL AGENDA TODAY AND
WE'LL BE STARTING WITH FILE ITEM
56 BY SENATOR CABALLERO. SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1420 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO, AN ACT RELATING TO
ENERGY. SENATOR CABALLERO, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE
FINEST EDUCATIONAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS. THE MOST AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS IN THE COUNTRY AND
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP
SOLAR IN THE COUNTRY. CALIFORNIA
HAS INVESTED BILLIONS OF
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS IN THESE
INDUSTRIES IN SUPPORT OF OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS. HOWEVER WE
STILL REQUIRE A DIVERSE SET OF
SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
CAN ACTUALLY ACHIEVE OUR CARBON
REDUCTION GOALS BY 2045. DESPITE
ROBUST INVESTMENTS, SOME HARD TO
DECARBONIZE INDUSTRIES WILL BE
UNABLE TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
AND DECARBONIZE IN TIME WITHOUT
NECESSARY POLICY CHANGES AND
SUPPORT. AND THE INSTITUTIONAL
RESEARCH THAT'S BEING DONE HAS
SUPPORTED THIS. THE SHIPPING
INDUSTRY, INCLUDING THE PORT
OPERATIONS, HEAVY TRUCKING,
AVIATION AND HEAVY INDUSTRY ALL
NEED PATHWAYS TO MEET OUR
STATE'S GOAL. ADDITIONALLY, AS
WE TRANSITION TO A ZERO CARBON
ECONOMY, WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO INCLUDE HIGH ROAD EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FOR OUR STATE'S
WORKFORCE. AND I KNOW YOU'VE
HEARD ME SAY NUMEROUS TIMES THAT
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
IS THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
EARN A LIVABLE WAGE, A GOOD
EARNING CAPACITY, AND TO BE ABLE
TO BUY A HOUSE AND PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. LET'S BE CLEAR,
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD, AFTER MUCH RESEARCH AND
ANALYSIS, DETERMINED IN THEIR
2022 SCOPING PLAN THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD NOT ATTAIN ITS
CLIMATE GOALS TO DECARBONIZE
WITHOUT UTILIZING HYDROGEN AS A
FUEL SOURCE, CARB QUITE CLEARLY
STATES THAT CALIFORNIA CANNOT
REACH REACH ITS EMISSION GOALS
WITHOUT EXPANDING HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION BY 1700 TIMES THE
PRESENT RATE OF PRODUCTION. 1700
TIMES. THAT IS, WHERE SB 1420
COMES IN A HYDROGEN BILL THAT
WOULD ESTABLISH THE HIGHEST
EMISSION STANDARDS FOR HYDROGEN
IN THE WORLD. IT EXPRESSLY
PROHIBITS RESOURCE SHUFFLING
DURING PRODUCTION AND REQUIRES
THE ANNUAL CARBON INTENSITY OF
THE PRODUCED HYDROGEN FUEL TO BE
EQUAL, OR THAT TO BE EQUAL TO OR
BELOW THAT OF OUR ENERGY GRID.
COLLECTIVELY, THE BILL ENSURES
THE CONTINUED CONTINUED
DECARBONIZATION OF HYDROGEN FUEL
WHILE MAINTAINING PROTECTION
AGAINST EMISSION IMPACTS. THE
DEFINITION OF QUALIFIED CLEAN
HYDROGEN NOW EXPLICITLY
PROHIBITS HYDROGEN PRODUCED FROM
FOSSIL FUEL FUEL FEEDSTOCKS AND
MEET SPECIFIC EMISSION REDUCTION
LIMITS, AS DETERMINED BY THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
OR CARB. ALIGNING WITH
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS.
SPECIFICALLY, SB 1420 REQUIRES
THAT ON A STATEWIDE BASIS, AT
LEAST 60% OF THE HYDROGEN USED
IN TRANSPORTATION BE RENEWABLE
BY 2030, AND BY 2040 45. IN LINE
WITH OUR CURRENT STATUTORY GOAL
OF A ZERO CARBON ECONOMY, THE
REMAINING 40% MUST BE A MIX OF
RENEWABLE AND CLEAN. THE AMENDED
DEFINITION EXPLICITLY INCLUDES
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN PRODUCED
FROM RPS ELIGIBLE RESOURCES,
EMPHASIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOURCES IN
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION. SB 1420
WOULD ALSO CONSOLIDATE,
CONSOLIDATE THE DEFINITIONS OF
HYDROGEN INTO A SINGLE
DEFINITION FOR QUALIFIED CLEAN
HYDROGEN PROJECTS, ENSURING
CLARITY AND CONSISTENCY IN THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR CEQA
AND PERMIT STREAMLINING. I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR AND EMPHASIZE
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT ALLOW ANY
PROJECT TO PROCEED OUTSIDE OF
THE CEQA PROCESS OR HAVE ANY
IMPACT ON THE PUBLIC'S ABILITY
TO PROVIDE COMMENT AND INPUT ON
EACH INDIVIDUAL PROJECT. SB 1420
WOULD ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO MEET
ITS GOALS, ALLOW A TRANSITION IN
THE AVIATION HEAVY TRUCK DUTY
TRUCKING AND MARITIME INDUSTRIES
AWAY FROM DIESEL AND JET FUEL TO
A CLEANER, LOCALLY PRODUCED
PRODUCT THAT WOULD NOT ONLY
DECARBONIZE THE FUEL BUT
ELIMINATE THE PRODUCTION OF AIR
POLLUTION. CONTAMINANTS SUCH AS
SULFUR OXIDES, SOX AND NITROUS
OXIDE, OR NOX. SB 1420 WOULD
ALSO ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO
LEVERAGE THE $1.2 BILLION
BILLION DOLLAR IN FEDERAL FUNDS
FROM THE INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT, AWARDED TO THE ARCHES
COALITION FOR A HYDROGEN HUB
GRANT BY UNLOCKING PRIVATE
SECTOR INVESTMENT, ESTIMATED TO
BRING $10 BILLION INTO OUR
STATE, CREATING JOBS, ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND NEW ENERGY
RESOURCES. AND FOLKS, IF YOU'LL
REMEMBER FROM OUR BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS, ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT THAT CALIFORNIA SAW A
DECLINE OF WAS IN INVESTMENT IN
NEW PRODUCTS IN THE STATE. THE
ABILITY FOR COMPANIES TO GO
PUBLIC AND THE ABILITY FOR THEM
TO BRING IN PRIVATE INVESTMENT
IS WHAT HAS HURT US OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS. THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW US TO RE-ENERGIZE THAT
SECTOR. IN CONCLUSION, THE BILL
IS AMENDED, FULFILL THE
COMMITMENTS I MADE IN BOTH THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND
SENATE ENERGY COMMITTEES. AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE BEEN
MEETING WITH ME OVER THE PAST
YEAR AND AS WELL AS THE
CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR INPUT AND
LANGUAGE. HYDROGEN IS A CRITICAL
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S TRANSITION
TO A ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION AND ENERGY SYSTEM
. I AGREE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
THAT BY EXPANDING HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION, WE CAN BETTER
DECARBONIZE INDUSTRIES, MAKE OUR
ENERGY GRID MORE RELIABLE,
STABILIZE COSTS FOR CONSUMERS,
AND CREATE HIGH ROAD JOBS TO
TRADITIONAL TRANSITION WORKERS
TO THE NEW GREEN ECONOMY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SENATOR NEWMAN? AYE, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. I WANT
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR HER
APPROACH, WHICH IS A VERY
PRACTICAL AND PRAGMATIC SET OF
POLICIES THAT WILL BE NECESSARY
AND WILL ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO
MEET ITS VERY AMBITIOUS SET OF
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. AND THESE
GOALS, AS SHE NOTED, ARE
EXPLICITLY IN LINE WITH CARB
SCOPING REPORT AND OTHER
FINDINGS. I WANT TO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
BILL DOES RESPECT CEQA. IT DOES
ALLOW FOR PUBLIC INPUT. IT
EMPHASIZES HIGH ROAD EMPLOYMENT
AND LEVERAGES THE $1.2 BILLION
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
RECENTLY AWARDED CALIFORNIA FOR
THE ARCHES PROGRAM, WHICH WILL
CATALYZE UP TO $50 BILLION IN
NEW MARKET ACTIVITY AROUND CLEAN
ENERGY. FOR THOSE REASONS I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY FOR THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, SENATOR BECKER? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I JUST WANT TO
SAY I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK ON THIS, AND I
THINK IT'S AN ABSOLUTELY VITAL
TOPIC AND HAVE HAD A COUPLE
BILLS ON THE TOPIC AS WELL,
WE'VE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS. I
HAVE A COUPLE SPECIFIC THINGS
I'D LIKE TO, I THINK, SEE, GOING
FORWARD, WE DO HAVE AS I THINK
OF, YOU KNOW, BY 2045, WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE NET ZERO. AND I
THINK CURRENTLY THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT FOR 60% CLEAN
HYDROGEN AND 2045. SO I THINK
THERE'S PROBABLY SOME BALANCE,
THAT AND I THINK I'VE GOT SOME
SPECIFIC SUGGESTIONS AROUND THE
CARBON INTENSITY STANDARD. I
THINK THAT COULD HELP US,
CLARIFY THAT WHEN WE GET TO 2045
THAT WE HAVE THE MAJORITY OF
CLEAN HYDROGEN, OR AT LEAST
REQUIRE THE SAME CARBON
INTENSITY STANDARDS. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
THIS. MAYBE STAYING OFF THE BILL
TODAY, BUT I THINK IT'S A
VITALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC, AND I
THINK WE CAN HOPEFULLY GET THERE
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU.
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I GUESS I WOULD ECHO
MY FRIEND FROM PALO ALTO, AND
HIS SOME OF HIS OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS, BUT I THINK IT'S
WORTH NOTING THAT THE AUTHOR
HERE, WHETHER IT'S HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, IN TOUGH FORUMS
WITHIN THE UN, AND BASICALLY
ANYWHERE SHE'S INVITED, SHE'S
BEEN OPEN AND WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN A WAY THAT WE
CAN ALL SORT OF REFER TO
RHETORICALLY AND SAY, I'M
WORKING WITH ALL PARTIES, BUT I
REALLY TRUST HER THAT SHE'S
GOING TO BE WORKING ON THIS
LEGISLATION GOING FORWARD, THAT
DEFINITION THÀNH OF CLEAN, THIS
BIG QUESTION MARK OF WHETHER
CALIFORNIA IS IN FACT GOING TO,
DOUBLE DOWN ON WHAT I CONSIDER A
MISGUIDED EFFORT FOR THIS LIGHT
DUTY FUTURE TO HAVE A NO OFFENSE
TO THE MIRAI DRIVERS OUT HERE,
BUT THIS PUSH FOR LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES TO SOMEHOW BECOME A
NEVER ENDING SUBSIDY, I THINK,
IS A MISGUIDED EFFORT. HOWEVER,
THOSE OF YOU WHO LIVE NEAR ANY
PORT OR NEAR ANY INDUSTRIAL
FACILITY IN CALIFORNIA KNOW THAT
SOMETHING'S GOT TO CHANGE. AND
WE HAVE TO KEEP MAKING THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE NOT JUST GOING
TO SHUT DOWN INDUSTRY, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO JUST SHUT DOWN OUR
REFINERIES. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
STOP DOING BUSINESS. AND SO I
TRULY VIEW ESPECIALLY IN THE
INDUSTRIAL CONTEXT AND THE
CONTEXT OF OUR HEAVY DUTY FLEET
THAT'S LITERALLY KILLING PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW, THAT WE'VE GOT TO
FIND A WAY TO YES, I KNOW THIS
BILL STILL NEEDS WORK AND IT
DOESN'T YET HAVE MY FULL
SUPPORT. TODAY BUT I THINK THIS
AUTHOR IS UP TO THE TASK OF
GETTING US TO A PLACE WHERE WE
DON'T JUST DEFAULT TO THE STATE
OF EXISTING LAW, TO A STATE OF
CONFUSION, OR EVEN JUST TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, BUT IN FACT,
TO A FRAMEWORK HERE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN PUT OUR STAMP AND
SAY, THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA WAY.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE OURSELVES TO
A GREEN HYDROGEN FUTURE, AND I
THINK THIS BILL IS A MEANINGFUL
STEP IN, IN THAT DIRECTION.
UNFORTUNATELY, I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT TODAY, BUT I DO THINK
IT EARNS, THE MERIT TO MOVE
FORWARD, AND I HOPE THAT AS IT
COMES BACK AND AS WE WORK
THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT I'LL BE
ABLE TO CAST THAT I VOTE. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM, HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SENATOR CABALLERO, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE LOOK MEMBERS,
WE CAN CONTINUE ON THE PATH THAT
WE'RE ON RIGHT NOW. 2035 WILL
GET HERE AND WE WON'T WE WON'T
HAVE MET OUR GOALS, AND AS A
MATTER OF FACT, THE SOX AND NOX
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE. AND WE
HAVE THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN
THE SOUTH COAST AIR BASIN AND
ALSO IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
PEOPLE ARE DYING, AND IF THEY'RE
NOT DYING, THEY'RE GETTING
REALLY SICK OR WHAT WE CAN DO IS
WE CAN BELIEVE IN WHAT SCIENCE
SAYS. THE ARCHES COLLABORATIVE
IS MADE UP OF OUR BEST AND
BRIGHTEST FROM OUR UNIVERSITIES,
AS WELL AS ENTREPRENEURS THAT
HAVE PUT THE MONEY WHERE THEIR
MOUTH IS AND THAT ARE IN A
POSITION TO HELP US GET RID OF
WASTE THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY, AND TO DO IT IN A WAY
THAT'S RESPONSIBLE AND THAT WILL
HELP US TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS, REDUCE AIR QUALITY AND
CREATE GOOD JOBS. IF NONE OF
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO YOU, THEN
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT. DON'T VOTE
FOR IT TODAY. BUT THE ARCHES
PROJECT BRINGS IN $1.2 BILLION
OF FEDERAL IRA MONEY, AND IN
ORDER TO BUILD, THEY NEED AT
LEAST $10 BILLION IN PRIVATE
EQUITY. AND WE HAVE FUNDS THAT
ARE COMING TO CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE SAYING WE WANT TO INVEST
BECAUSE WE KNOW CALIFORNIA
PRODUCES THE BEST. SO WE'RE AT
THIS PRECIPICE. WE EITHER MOVE
WITH Dð, DELIBERATE
INTELLIGENCE, OR WE JUST LET IT
GO AND SAY, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DO IT, WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING, AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO
EXACERBATE THE SITUATION THAT WE
SEE GLOBALLY. THE EXCITING THING
ABOUT THESE PROJECTS. WELL, AND
LET ME JUST SAY THAT PART OF THE
CHALLENGE IS WE HAVE TO USE THAT
FEDERAL GRANT BY 2030. THE
PLANT, WHATEVER THE FACILITY,
WHATEVER IT IS THAT'S BEING
BUILT, HAS TO BE BUILT AND
OPERATIONAL FOR TWO YEARS OR THE
OR THE GRANT DOES NOT PAY OUT.
SO THINK ABOUT THAT. HOW MANY OF
YOU KNOW OF A CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT THAT GOT DONE IN THREE
YEARS WHEN THEY HAVEN'T EVEN
PULLED THE PERMITS YET, AND THEY
AND THERE'S NO EXPEDITED
PROCESS. IT DOESN'T HAPPEN IN
CALIFORNIA. WE GOT TO MOVE. AND
WHAT I WILL COMMIT TO YOU AND
I'VE SPOKEN TO MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM MALIBU, IS WE GOT TO GET
THIS RIGHT, WHICH MEANS ALL
HANDS ON BOARD WORKING ON IT. I
HAVE TAKEN TONS OF AMENDMENTS
THAT DO WHAT I THINK WE WANT TO
DO, AND TWO COMMITTEES THAT WERE
TOUGH TO GET THROUGH THAT, THAT
GAVE ME A CHARGE ABOUT WHAT I
NEEDED TO AMEND IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO, TO, TO GET THEIR SIGN
OFF. AND WE'VE, WE'VE DONE THAT.
THAT'S NOT EASY TO DO IN AN
INDUSTRY THAT'S, THAT'S NEW. SO
THIS THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
TIME. THIS REALLY IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO SEIZE THE MOMENT,
I, I HAVE TRAVELED
INTERNATIONALLY AND HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT DIFFERENT
PROJECTS. AND I CAN TELL YOU THE
WHOLE WORLD IS LOOKING AT
CALIFORNIA AND THEY'RE SAYING,
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO BE
DOING TO MEET YOUR ENERGY NEEDS?
AND HOW CAN WE WORK TOGETHER IN
PARTNERSHIP? WE NEED TO BE
THERE. WE NEED TO BE IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO ACT. AND
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. OUR
DISCUSSION DEBATE HAVING CEASED
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ONE TIME
BECAUSE WE HAVE MEMBERS OFF THE
FLOOR AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
PUT THOSE ITEMS ON CALL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 56 ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE DALY. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. EGGMAN. AYE GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR MINH. AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE. OTOBO
AYE. PADILLA. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SATO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. WE WILL
GO THROUGH THE ROLL ONE MORE
TIME. WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER,
BLAKE SPEAR. AYE. DALLY. AYE.
DURAZZO GONZALEZ. LIMON
MENGIBAR. PADILLA SATO. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. WIENER.
IRA. NØ. AYE. STURDY. NOS ONE.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 44. SENATOR ARCHULETA. HE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1081 BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SENATOR ARCHULETA,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY I AM PRESENTING
SENATE BILL 1081, WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH OPTIONAL DRIVER'S
LICENSE LEGISLATION IN
CALIFORNIA. IN DOING SO,
CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN OVER 40
STATES AND TERRITORIES THAT
UTILIZE DMV TO EFFECTIVELY
INSURE THAT RESIDENTS COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL SELECTIVE SERVICE
REQUIREMENTS. CGRTS.
SPECIFICALLY, SENATE BILL 1081
WOULD ALLOW A PERSON THAT IS
REQUIRED TO BE REGISTERED UNDER
THE FEDERAL MILITARY SELECTIVE
SERVICE ACT AND WHO SUBMITS AN
APPLICATION FOR THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE, IDENTIFICATION CARD, OR
RENEWAL THROUGH THE DODD. VÆ
WILL BE DEEMED TO HAVE CONSENTED
TO REGISTRATION WITH THE UNITED
STATES SELECTIVE SERVICE SYSTEM.
HOWEVER, AN INDIVIDUAL WHO DOES
NOT WISH TO BE ENROLLED WITH THE
SELECTIVE SERVICE WILL BE GIVEN
THE CHOICE TO OPT OUT OF THE
REGISTRATION. SENATE BILL 1081
WOULD AUTOMATICALLY AND
ADDITIONALLY PROHIBIT THE DMV
FROM MAKING OR DISTRIBUTING A
LIST OF THOSE WHO DID NOT
CONSENT TO THE REGISTRATION.
RECENT AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN TO
EXEMPT UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
FROM THE BILL DELAY,
IMPLEMENTATION AND CONDITION
THAT THE BILL, UPON RECEIVING
FEDERAL FUNDS IN AN AMOUNT
SUFFICIENT TO PAY FOR ALL
INITIAL START UP AND
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS. IT IS
LEGAL. IT IS A LEGAL REQUIREMENT
THAT MOST ALL MALES REGISTER
WITH THE SELECTIVE SERVICE
BETWEEN THE AGES OF 18 AND 26,
MEN WHO FAIL TO REGISTER WITH
THE SELECTIVE SERVICE CUT
THEMSELVES OFF FROM FUTURE
BENEFITS AND OPPORTUNITIES IF
THEY DO NOT REGISTER BETWEEN 18
AND 26 YEARS OF AGE, MEN
PERMANENTLY BECOME INELIGIBLE
FOR ALL FEDERAL JOBS, AS WELL AS
FEDERAL JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING THOSE FUNDED BY THE
WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITY ACT. FAILURE TO
REGISTER MAY ADDITIONALLY CAUSE
DELAYS IN CITIZENSHIP
APPLICATIONS FOR IMMIGRANTS WHO
DO NOT HAVE AND DID NOT REGISTER
. CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS ONE
OF THE NATION'S LOWEST RATES OF
ELIGIBILITY. RESIDENTS WHO HAVE
SIGNED UP FOR THE SELECTIVE
SERVICE AS OF OCTOBER 2023, THE
SELECTIVE SERVICE SYSTEM
ESTIMATES THAT ONLY 74% OF
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
REGISTERED, IN CONTRAST TO OTHER
LARGE STATES, INCLUDING NEW
YORK, TEXAS, FLORIDA THAT HAVE
IMPLEMENTED DRIVER'S LICENSE
ENROLLMENT, THEY'VE REACHED
ENROLLMENT RATES OF OVER 90.
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF FAFSA
SIMPLIFICATION ACT, THERE IS
SUFFICIENT CONCERN THAT THE GAP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND STATES
WITH DRIVER'S LICENSE
LEGISLATION WILL WIDEN IF ACTION
IS NOT TAKEN TO INCREASE
REGISTRATION LEVELS FOR STATES
LIKE CALIFORNIA, FAFSA WAS A
SIGNIFICANT TOOL FOR MAKING
YOUNG MEN AWARE OF THEIR LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO SIGN UP FOR THE
SELECTIVE SERVICE. WITH THE TOOL
NOW GONE, IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
CALIFORNIA IMPLEMENTATION AND
IMPLEMENTS SENATE BILL 1081 AND
JOINS THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
OF STATES THAT HAVE STREAMLINED
THEIR REGISTRATION PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE ACTION TO
ENSURE THAT OUR RESIDENTS DO NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY MAKE
THEMSELVES INELIGIBLE FOR JOBS
AND BENEFITS BECAUSE OF OUR
INABILITY TO ENROLL PEOPLE
THROUGH THE DMV PROCESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SENATOR
DURAZO, I JUST WANT TO MAKE MY
CONCERN VERY, VERY SIMPLE, IT
SHOULD NOT BE THE ROLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
FACILITATE THE SELECT SELECTIVE
SERVICE REGISTRATION. THIS
SHOULD BE THE ROLE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL TO DO SO. AND OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO PROMOTE IT
AS NEEDED. SO I WILL BE NOT BE
SUPPORTING. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE, SENATOR
ARCHULETA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 44.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DALLY. NØ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. EGGMAN GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO WENT. AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. CIERTO AYE
. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. WILK AYE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ASHBY. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. DURAZZO EGGMAN.
LIMON. MCGUIRE OCHOA. BORG.
PADILLA RUBIO. SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WAHAB. WIENER.
AGE 23. NOES TO THE MEASURE.
PASSES NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NINE.
SENATOR. MEN ARE YOU PREPARED?
HE IS SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1126 BY SENATOR.
MEN, AN ACT RELATING TO CHILD
ABUSE AND NEGLECT. Ó PASS ON
FILE. HE'S GOING TO PASS ON FILE
. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO FILE ITEM 15. SENATOR
BECKER, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 935 BY SENATOR BECKER. AN
ACT RELATING TO CRIMES. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BECKER. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. RISE TO PRESENT, SB
935. THIS IS A KIND OF SIMPLE
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT
ADDRESSES A LOOPHOLE AND STATUTE
REGARDING PEACE OFFICER
TESTIMONY IN A RECENT CASE, A
DETECTIVE WITH OVER 20 YEARS OF
SERVICE RESIGNED FROM LAPD
BEFORE REACHING THE AGE OF 50,
MAKING THEM INELIGIBLE FOR
RETIREMENT STATUS. THE OFFICER
WAS CALLED BACK TO TESTIFY AT A
HEARING, BUT BECAUSE THE
DISCREPANCY CURRENTLY IN
STATUTE, THE JUDGE WAS UNSURE
WHETHER TO ADMIT THE WITNESS.
THIS WOULD ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
BY ALLOWING HONORABLY SEPARATED
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WITH
THE REQUISITE EXPERIENCE TO ALSO
PROVIDE SUCH TESTIMONY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 15.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS.
AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI. AYE DODD.
AYE. Dð. RAFEAL. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE MINH.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO AYE. OCHOA BORG. AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ARCHULETA. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE 38. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 17.
SENATOR NGUYEN. SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1478 BY SENATOR NGUYEN AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS.
SENATOR NGUYEN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MOTION SHELTER
DOESN'T HAVE A VOICE, SO WE WILL
AND WE HAVE TO BE THEIR VOICE.
SB 1478 SIMPLY PROVIDES GUIDANCE
TO VETERINARIANS WHO PRACTICE IN
ANIMAL SHELTERS BY OUTLINING
BASIC BUT ESSENTIAL ELEMENTS
NECESSARY FOR THE PROPER AND
SAFE CARE OF THESE ANIMALS THAT
ARE BEING HOUSED IN THESE ANIMAL
SHELTERS. THIS BILL PUTS ON THE
RECORD COMMON SENSE PRACTICE.
VETERINARIANS ARE TRAINED TO
UTILIZE. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR NEWMAN? ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I'M PROUD TO
BE A COAUTHOR OF THIS BILL. THIS
IS ONE OF TWO BILLS THE AUTHOR
BROUGHT IN RESPONSE TO A GRAND
JURY REPORT AND OTHER REPORTING
THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE ABYSMAL
CONDITIONS IN CALIFORNIA'S
ANIMAL SHELTERS, PASSING THIS
BILL IS NOT ONLY GOOD FOR PETS,
IT'S A VALIDATION OF OUR CONCERN
FOR THOSE PETS AND A COMMITMENT
TO THE VALUES THAT THAT WE SHOW
AS A LEGISLATURE. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE, AND I VOTE. THANK YOU, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? HEARING?
NONE. SENATOR NGUYEN, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN? SB 1478
WILL PROVIDE BASIC GUIDANCE TO
IMPROVE THE MANAGEMENT AND
OPERATION OF ANIMAL SHELTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I APPRECIATE AND
THANK MY COLLEAGUE, SENATOR FROM
FULLERTON, FOR BEING A COAUTHOR
AND FOR CHAMPIONING THE WELFARE
OF ANIMALS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
ITEM? HEARING NONE 38 AYES ZERO
NOES. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 20. SENATOR NEWMAN, HE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1372 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN IN RELATION TO AVIATION.
SENATOR NEWMAN, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1372, WHICH WOULD ENSURE EQUAL
ACCESS AND CONSISTENT FAIR
TREATMENT AT THE AIRPORT
SECURITY CHECKPOINTS FOR ALL
TRAVELERS BY LIMITING THE
EXPANSION OF SO-CALLED THIRD
PARTY EXPEDITED SCREENING
SERVICES. UNLESS THEY OPERATE IN
A DEDICATED SECURITY SCREENING
LANE, SOME OF YOU, ESPECIALLY
THE MEMBERS OF THE LA DELEGATION
, MIGHT RECALL A CONTROVERSY
EARLIER THIS YEAR WHICH INVOLVED
BROKERS BUYING UP TEE TIMES AT
AREA PUBLIC GOLF COURSES ON
BEHALF OF CLIENTS WHO WERE
WILLING TO PAY EXTRA TO PLAY
GOLF ON PUBLIC COURSES. AS A
MEMBER OF THE CITY'S PUBLIC GOLF
ADVISORY COMMITTEE PUT IT, THIS
IS A PUBLIC GOOD. IT WOULD BE
LIKE IF SOMEONE TOOK OVER A
PUBLIC SWIMMING POOL. INSTEAD,
THERE WOULD BE SURGE PRICING TO
SWIM IN IT. WHEN THIS PRACTICE
IN LA WAS EXPOSED, THE LOCAL
MEDIA ATTENTION WAS INTENSE, THE
OUTRAGE WAS IMMEDIATE, AND THE
RESPONSE WAS APPROPRIATE. THE LA
DEPARTMENT OF RECREATION AND
PARKS LAUNCHED AN INVESTIGATION
AND SUBSEQUENTLY INSTALLED
CONTROLS TO PREVENT FUTURE
SIMILAR ABUSES. AND AS THE
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE REC AND
PARKS DEPARTMENT PUT IT AT THAT
TIME, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
IT'S NOT RIGHT. IT'S NOT FAIR.
THIS BILL, WHICH HAS GOTTEN MORE
THAN ITS SHARE OF ATTENTION,
ACTUALLY REVOLVES AROUND THE
EXACT SAME PRINCIPLE. IN THE
AFTERNOON AFTERMATH OF 911, A
MASSIVE SECURITY SYSTEM WAS
DEVELOPED AND INSTALLED AT OUR
NATION'S AIRPORTS TO PREVENT
ANOTHER SIMILAR CATASTROPHE, SO
FAR SUCCESSFULLY. THE COST OF
BUILDING AND OPERATING THAT
SYSTEM WAS BORNE BY TAXPAYERS
ACROSS THE NATION. RICH
TAXPAYERS, POOR TAXPAYERS, AND
IN BETWEEN TAXPAYERS. IT STANDS
TO REASON THEN, THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD BE TREATED THE SAME BY
THAT SYSTEM. IF AND WHEN THEY
HAVE TO TRAVEL. UNFORTUNATELY,
THAT'S NOT CURRENTLY THE CASE.
AT NINE OF CALIFORNIA'S BUSIEST
AIRPORTS, TRAVELERS PAYING A FEE
TO A PRIVATE COMPANY ARE GRANTED
LINE CUTTING PRIVILEGES AT THE
EXPENSE OF THOSE WHO DON'T PAY
SUCH A FEE. THIS IS, I THINK
YOU'LL ALL AGREE, NOT FAIR. IT'S
ALSO SOMETHING THAT CAN EASILY
BE FIXED. SO CLEAR. THE COMPANY
WHICH RUNS THIS VERY PROFITABLE
CONCIERGE TRAVELER SERVICE AND
THE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S AIRPORTS, WHICH
ENJOY A SHARE OF THE PROFITS
GENERATED BY THE CLEAR SYSTEM,
CLAIM THEY LACK THE INFLUENCE TO
PERSUADE THE TRANSPORTATION
SECURITY ADMINISTRATION TO AMEND
ITS PROCESSES TO ALLOW FOR A
DEDICATED LANE FOR TRAVELERS WHO
PAY FOR THE SERVICE. THIS IS
CLEARLY NOT TRUE. DELTA AIRLINES
RECENTLY LAUNCHED JUST SUCH A
SERVICE CALLED DELTA ONE, WHICH
OFFERS PREMIUM TRAVELERS
EXPEDITED ACCESS TO AIRPORT
SCREENING WITHOUT INTERSECTING
WITH ANY OTHER LINE. ALL THAT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO IS CREATE
A SUFFICIENT LEVEL OF SHARED
MOTIVATION BETWEEN CLARE AND ITS
AIRPORT PARTNERS TO PETITION TSA
TO DO THE EXACT SAME THING WE
HAVE A LETTER TO THE SECRETARY
OF TRANSPORTATION AND THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
URGING THEM TO DO EXACTLY THIS.
AND TO BE CLEAR, NO PUN
INTENDED, THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
BANNING OR EVEN HARMING CLEAR
ITS EMPLOYEES, ITS CUSTOMERS, OR
ANY OF ITS PARTNERS. THIS IS NOT
AN ATTACK ON FREE ENTERPRISE OR
THE PROFIT MOTIVE EITHER. THIS
IS SIMPLY ABOUT FINDING A BETTER
BASIS FOR CONDUCTING THE
OPERATIONS OF EXPEDITED
SCREENING PROGRAMS LIKE CLEAR,
SO THAT THOSE WHO PARTICIPATE
CAN ENJOY THE BENEFITS OF
MEMBERSHIP. I'M LOOKING AT YOU
MEMBERS WITHOUT ADVERSELY
AFFECTING THOSE WHO DO NOT. IN
THAT SPIRIT, AS A RESULT OF
NEGOTIATIONS FACILITATED BY THE
CHAIR AND AGREED TO BY CLEAR
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN IN SENATE
TRANSPORTATION, CLEAR HAS
REMOVED ITS OPPOSITION IN THE
POST 9/11 ERA. TRAVEL HAS BECOME
A GANTLET OF CHALLENGES AND
BURDENS IN SO MANY WAYS. BY
PASSING SB 1372, THIS BODY WILL
HAVE MADE THOSE CHALLENGES JUST
A LITTLE BIT MORE BEARABLE AND A
LITTLE BIT MORE FAIR. I AM
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
HELP IN DOING JUST THAT WITH
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1372. I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY AND PERHAPS
REITERATE BECAUSE SOME OF IT WAS
COVERED IN THE AUTHOR'S REMARKS,
THAT THAT THE BILL, THIS BILL
WAS AMENDED SIGNIFICANTLY.
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN IN
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE THAT
CHANGED THE BILL DRAMATICALLY
FROM WHERE IT STARTED OFF. THE
BILL WOULD HAVE BEEN DISRUPTIVE,
I BELIEVE, AND I THINK MOST OF
YOU WOULD HAVE HAD THE SAME
READING WHEN IT WAS FIRST PUT IN
PRINT. IN TERMS OF THE CURRENT
USE OF CLEAR, THE CURRENT
CONTRACTS AND EXISTENCE OF CLEAR
AT AIRPORTS WHERE THERE ARE
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE RIGHT NOW.
INSTEAD THE BILL WAS AMENDED SO
THAT IF THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT
IN PLACE AT THE AIRPORT BEFORE
JANUARY ONE, 2025, THIS BILL HAS
NO EFFECT WHATSOEVER. SO THOSE
CUSTOMERS, YOUR CONSTITUENTS, MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
USING CLEAR AT AIRPORTS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE DISRUPTED
BY THIS BILL BECAUSE THIS BILL
REACHES OUT TO THOSE AIRPORTS
THAT ARE NOT YET UNDER CONTRACT
AND ESSENTIALLY PUTS A
MORATORIUM UNLESS THEY'RE ABLE
TO FOLLOW THE DIRECTION OF THE
BILL, WHICH IS TO SET UP THE
SEPARATE LINE. WITH THAT, I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR CIERTO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
THE BILL SIMPLY IS NOT NEEDED, I
THINK THE AUTHOR MADE IT CLEAR
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT, NO PUN
INTENDED. AGAIN AND IT'S LINE
CUTTING IS NOT FAIR TO THE
LEGISLATURE, SHOULD NOT BE USED
BECAUSE LINE CUTTING IS NOT
CLEAR. IS NOT FAIR, THIS IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN TSA PRE. BUT WHAT
THEY DO IS THEY USE BIOMETRIC
CHECKS TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
IDENTITY IS THE SAME PERSON THAT
IS ON THE TICKET, AND THAT'S IT.
AND THEN THEY WALK YOU UP, YOU
GO OVER TO THE TSA LINE AND YOU
GO IN AND GET YOUR STUFF
SCREENED. TSA IS THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE THAT'S A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
THE FEDERAL AGENCY. THEY'RE IN
CHARGE OF DECIDING WHAT LINES
ARE SHOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
PEOPLE TO WALK THROUGH, THIS IS
AN INTRUSION INTO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S SPACE. IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT DELAYING CUSTOMERS AT
ALL. IT PROVIDES 600 JOBS FOR
PEOPLE AND I HOPE THEY CAN
EXPAND AND PROVIDE 600 MORE JOBS
FOR OTHER PEOPLE. SO FOR ME,
I'VE BEEN TO OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
US FLY EVERY WEEK AND, THERE HAS
NEVER, EVER BEEN AN INSTANCE
WHERE SOMEBODY'S GETTING CLEAR
HAS DELAYED WHAT I'M DOING IN
TSA PRE AND MADE MY DAY, MY DAY
WORSE. SO, YOU KNOW, THE PREMISE
THAT SOMEHOW IT'S NOT FAIR.
WELL, IF IT'S NOT FAIR, THEN
THEY SHOULD DO AWAY WITH TSA PRE
AND PUT US ALL IN THE OTHER LINE
, BECAUSE IT DOES EXACTLY THE
SAME THING, THEY ARE JUST
RESPONDING TO A MARKET. IF THERE
WASN'T A MARKET FOR IT, IT
WOULDN'T EXIST. AND IF TSA, THE
TSA DIDN'T ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T
FEEL THAT IT WAS WARRANTED, THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE IT. THEY WOULDN'T
ALLOW IT. SO WITH THAT, I WOULD
SAY THAT THIS BILL, BECAUSE OF
THE PREMISE IN WHICH IT WAS
DRAWN UP, IS NOT ABOUT FAIRNESS
TO OTHER PEOPLE IN LINE. IT'S
ABOUT SOMEBODY CUT IN FRONT OF
US. AND THAT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD REASON TO
BRING LEGISLATION FORWARD. SO
WITH THAT, I WOULD ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS AND PUT THIS BABY
TO BED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING SEEING
NONE. SENATOR NEWMAN, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? AYE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE ROBUST
COMMENTS, LET ME MAKE, MAKE,
MAKE ONE POINT AND I'M RESISTING
THE URGE TO MAKE THE PUN, BUT
BUT TO BE CLEAR, CLEAR IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN TSA PRECHECK. TSA
PRECHECK IS A TRUSTED TRAVELER
PROGRAM. YOU PAY $78, IT GETS
YOU FIVE YEARS OF ELIGIBILITY.
WHAT THAT DOES IS IT RUNS YOU
THROUGH AND VERIFIES THAT ACROSS
A WHOLE BUNCH OF SYSTEMS THAT
YOU ARE, IN FACT, A SAFE
TRAVELER. AND THERE IN LIES THE
BASIS FOR THAT EXPEDITED LINE
FOR TSA PRECHECK. CLEAR. THERE'S
NO SUCH THING. ALL IT DOES IS
MATCH YOUR ID TO YOUR IDENTITY,
AND IT IS NOT, IN FACT,
CONNECTED TO ANY OF THE SYSTEMS
THAT ACTUALLY ENSURE THAT WE'RE
SAFE WHEN WE TRAVEL. THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY AMONG THE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL ARE THE
FLIGHT ATTENDANTS UNION, WHO
HAVE EVERY REASON TO BE FEARFUL
OF ANOTHER NINE OVER 11
SITUATION AND THE TSA EMPLOYEES
UNION, WHO, IN ADDITION TO THE
SAFETY CONCERNS, ARE JUST AS
EXPOSED AS ANYBODY TO THE
FRUSTRATION THAT THE LINE
CUTTING CAUSES. SO I SAY TO MY
COLLEAGUE, WHO'S NEVER BEEN A
PARTY OR WITNESS TO ANY OF THIS,
YOU'VE GOT TO TRAVEL MORE. AND
YOU'LL NOTICE THAT ESPECIALLY IN
SOME OF THE CROWDED AIRPORTS,
THE FRUSTRATION LEVELS. I'M
LOOKING TO MY COLLEAGUE HERE
FROM SANTA CLARITA WHO'S NODDING
HIS HEAD, ARE REALLY HIGH. AND
TO THE QUESTION, YOU KNOW, WHAT
ABOUT FAIRNESS? SHOULD WE
LEGISLATE FAIRNESS? WE DO IT
EVERY DAY HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. SO THIS BILL IS
ABOUT CREATING AN INCENTIVE
SHARED BY THE CLEAR COMPANY AND
THE AIRPORTS, SIMPLY TO GO TO
TSA AND SAY, HEY, ALLOW US TO
MAKE MONEY, RESELL ACCESS TO A
PUBLIC SERVICE, BUT DO IT IN
SUCH A WAY THAT IT'S NOT ADVERSE
TO THE AVERAGE TRAVELER WHO
EITHER CAN'T AFFORD THAT OR
CANNOT DO IT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 20. ALAN ALVARADO, GIL
NÓ ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DELI DODD
DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLASER
GONZALEZ I GROVE HURTADO I JONES
NÓ LAIRD I LEMON I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN. NILO NGUYEN. NØ. NILO
NØ. OKUBO NO PADILLA I
PORTANTINO. ROTH I RUBIO.
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I STERN. UMBERG I WAHAB
WIENER WILK I. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN TALLY.
DODD. GLASER GROVE. MCGUIRE
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. STERN.
I. WAHAB I WIENER. WATT. AYES
25. NOES SIX. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SEN. NEWMAN. WE STILL
HAVE YOU ON THE ROLE AND
SCHEDULE. YOU HAVE FILED. ITEM
4647 I SHOULD SAY. WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A PAUSE FOR THE CAUSE
REAL QUICK.
SENATOR PORTANTINO, CAN YOU
STATE YOUR VOTE ON 1372? WAS
THAT PORTANTINO NØ? 1372.
PORTANTINO. NO. OKAY.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
TO JUST STAY CALM. STAY PUT FOR
A FEW MINUTES AS WE FIX THIS
TECHNICAL GLITCH WE GOT GOING ON
.
ALL RIGHT. WE STAND CORRECTED. I
IS 25 NOES. SEVEN. THE MEASURE
PASSES IN REGARDS TO FILE ITEM
20. NOW WE'RE MOVING ONE SECOND.
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE BACK AT IT.
WE'RE NOW. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
47. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1164 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. TAX LEVY. SEN.
NEWMAN. FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. A LESS
EMOTIONAL ISSUE THIS TIME. I
RISE TO PRESENT SB 1164, WHICH
WHICH WOULD DEFER THE PROPERTY
TAX ASSESSMENT ON A NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED ADU FOR A PERIOD OF
TEN YEARS OR UNTIL THE PROPERTY
IS SOLD. IF THE HOMEOWNER
ATTESTED, THE ADU WILL BE USED
FOR HOUSING OVER THE PAST
DECADE, THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ADOPTED A SERIES OF MEASURES IN
RELATION TO ADU'S, INTENDED TO
REDUCE BARRIERS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS HINDERING THE PACE
OF ADU CREATION ACROSS THE
STATE. THOSE BARRIERS, WHICH
INCLUDE ADMINISTRATIVE ZONING
AND OTHER ISSUES, HAVE BEEN FOR
THE MOST PART ON THE MUNICIPAL
OR THE SUPPLY SIDE. WE'RE MUCH
LESS HAS BEEN DONE. AND WHERE
THIS BILL IS FOCUSED IS ON THE
DEMAND SIDE OF THE EQUATION,
INCENTIVIZING HOMEOWNERS FOR
WHOM AN ADU MAY BE A GOOD
INVESTMENT, BUT TO WHOM THE
FINANCES MAY SEEM DAUNTING. WHEN
A NEW ADDITION TO A HOME OR AN
ADU IS BUILT, THE NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED PORTION OF THE
PROPERTY IS IMMEDIATELY ASSESSED
AT 1% OF THE VALUE OF THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE JUST ADDED AN AMOUNT
THAT IS THEN APPENDED TO THE
PROPERTY OWNER'S NEXT YEARLY
PROPERTY TAX BILL. AS A TYPICAL
EXAMPLE, AN ADU ASSESSED AT A
VALUE OF $300,000 WOULD INCUR AN
IMMEDIATE PROPERTY TAX INCREASE
OF $3,000 PER YEAR. THE PROSPECT
OF SUCH AN INCREASE, ESPECIALLY
ON TOP OF THE EXPENSE AND
COMPLEXITY ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AN ADU, APPEARS
TO SERVE AS A SUBSTANTIAL
DISINCENTIVE FOR HOMEOWNERS,
PARTICULARLY WORKING CLASS
HOMEOWNERS, TO BUILD ADUS, EVEN
IF THEY MIGHT OTHERWISE REAP THE
BENEFITS OVER A LONGER TERM. BY
PAUSING THE PROPERTY TAX
INCREASE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF ADU OWNERS WILL
BE INCENTIVIZED TO INCREASE THE
OVERALL PRODUCTION OF ADUS
ACROSS THE STATE. SUCH AN
ALLOWANCE WILL BETTER ALIGN
MARKET FORCES WITH THE STATE'S
BROADER HOUSING GOALS. BY
ENHANCING AN INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNERS COST BENEFIT
CONSIDERATIONS AS THEY RELATE TO
CONSIDERING THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AN ADU. IN ADDITION TO THE WORK
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS DONE,
REMOVING ADMINISTRATIVE HURDLES
TO CONSTRUCTION VALUES, WE
SHOULD ALSO LOWER REAL AND
PERCEIVED COST BARRIERS SO AS TO
MAKE ADUS A MORE APPEALING AND
FEASIBLE OPTION FOR MIDDLE AND
WORKING CLASS HOMEOWNERS. SB
1164 WAS AMENDED IN SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS TO REDUCE THE
PROPERTY TAX WAIVER FOR NEW
IDEAS FROM 15 TO 10 YEARS, AND
THE BILL WILL SUNSET IN FIVE
YEARS. THIS BILL HAS STRONG
SUPPORT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
, WHO AGREE THIS COULD BE AN
IMPORTANT ADDITIONAL MECHANISM
FOR TO ACCELERATE HOUSING
PRODUCTION ACROSS THE STATE. I
AM RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 47.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DEL.
NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO BERGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NILO. NÓ
OCHOA. BORG. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMMER. AYE WAHAB. NØ.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
DURAZZO. GROVE NGUYEN. OCHOA
SEYARTO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
DON'T KNOW. GROW UP. I DON'T
KNOW. SHARON, I DON'T KNOW. ALL
RIGHT. FINAL COUNT IS 29 NÓ SIX.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OUR SAFER CALIFORNIA BILL
PACKAGE. I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
PART. THE FLOOR IS YOURS, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, THANK YOU
FOR THIS, COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT. AND TO KICK
OFF THE PRESENTATION OF THE
BIPARTISAN THE BIPARTISAN SAFER
CALIFORNIA PLAN, WHICH WILL BE
PRESENTED HERE THIS MORNING.
SENATORS FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE HAVE COME TOGETHER TO
ADVANCE A SERIES OF 15 BILLS.
THIS DATA DRIVEN POLICY PACKAGE
WILL HELP CURB IT CAN HELP CURB
CALIFORNIA'S FENTANYL CRISIS AND
THE RISING RATES OF RETAIL THEFT
AND COMMUNITY BASED CRIME. TEN
OF THE BILLS ARE FOCUSED ON
EXPANDING EVIDENCE BASED
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT
SOLUTIONS AIMED AT THE DEADLY
FENTANYL EPIDEMIC, IMPACTING
COUNTLESS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES. THE OTHER FIVE BILLS
THEY'RE GOING TO HELP PREVENT,
DETER AND PROSECUTE RETAIL THEFT
AND COMMUNITY BASED CRIMES THAT
HAVE IMPACTED THE SAFETY AND
QUALITY OF LIFE IN COMMUNITIES
BIG AND SMALL. ACROSS THE GOLDEN
STATE. TODAY, WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR IS ABOUT REAL SOLUTIONS
THAT ADDRESS ACUTE CHALLENGES
IMPACTING CALIFORNIA. THIS
CRITICAL POLICY PACKAGE WILL
HELP MAKE OUR SAFE SAFER. IT'S
GOING TO HELP MAKE OUR STATE
HEALTHIER, AND IT'S SUPPORTED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT, FIREFIGHTERS
AND SMART JUSTICE. AND JUST
TODAY, SEVERAL BIG CITY MAYORS.
AND AS I SAID EARLY ON, NONE OF
THE SENATE'S THEFT BILLS WOULD
MEAN REVISIONS TO PROP 47,
ENSURING WE NEVER REPEAT THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST MASS
INCARCERATION IS NOT THE ANSWER,
NOT TODAY, NOT EVER. AND THIS
PACKAGE WOULD ADVANCE STRATEGIC
ENHANCEMENTS IMPLEMENTED ON
SPECIFIC RETAIL AND COMMUNITY
BASED CRIMES. THE PASSAGE OF THE
SAFER CALIFORNIA POLICY PACKAGE
WILL MEAN MORE CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE FIGHTING ADDICTION WILL GET
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT,
SETTING THEM UP FOR A HEALTHIER
FUTURE. AND IT BUILDS UPON MORE
THAN $1 BILLION, MORE THAN $1
BILLION THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS HAS INVESTED TO EXPAND
PROGRAMS FOR ENFORCEMENT. PUBLIC
HEALTH AND COMMUNITY BASED
EDUCATION. AND THE RETAIL THEFT
PACKAGE BUILDS ON MORE THAN $100
MILLION WORTH OF INVESTMENT BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAS
MADE HAS BEEN MADE IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS TO HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT TACKLE RETAIL THEFT.
THAT INCLUDES $85 MILLION FOR
LOCAL POLICE TO CRACK DOWN ON
THEFT, ALONG WITH $6 MILLION ON
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE CHP TO
INCREASE THEIR PRESENCE IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. I'D LIKE TO WRAP IT
UP RIGHT HERE AND TURN IT OVER
TO THE AUTHORS. WITH THIS I
THANK YOU. YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
EVERY DAY WHERE IN THIS NATION
WHERE DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
CAN COME TOGETHER. AND I'M
GRATEFUL. I'M GRATEFUL TO LEADER
JONES FOR HIS PARTNERSHIP IN
THIS. AND I WANT TO SAY THANKS
TO EVERY MEMBER OF THE WORKING
GROUP WHO SPENT THE GREATER PART
OF THEIR YEAR LAST YEAR
ADVANCING THIS EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACH. WITH PERMISSION. MR.
PRESIDENT, I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THOSE WORKING
GROUP MEMBERS, INCLUDING SENATOR
SKINNER, SENATOR UMBERG, SENATOR
EGGMAN, SENATOR ROSS, SENATOR
WAHAB, AND SENATOR WIENER, AND I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
OUR BIPARTISAN GROUP OF AUTHORS
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING HERE
TODAY. SENATOR WAHAB, SENATOR
ROTH, SENATOR ASHBY, SENATOR
CORTEZ, SENATOR MINT, SENATOR
NEWMAN, SENATOR OCHOA, BOGH,
SENATOR SKINNER, SENATOR UMBERG,
AND SENATOR WIENER CALIFORNIANS.
THEY DESERVE A UNITED APPROACH
TO TACKLING THESE CHALLENGES,
AND THE SENATE IS DOING JUST
THAT. COLLEAGUES, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE SAFER
CALIFORNIA PLAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO OUR FIRST ITEM UNDER
THIS PACKAGE. IT'S FILE ITEM 30
BY SENATOR ROTH, SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1385 BY
SENATOR ROTH. AN ACT RELATING TO
MEDI-CAL. SENATOR ROTH. THANK
YOU. MR. PRESIDENT, BEFORE I GET
TO THE MATTER OF THE BILL, I'D
LIKE TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS. I WAS PRIVILEGED TO
SERVE ON THE FENTANYL WORKING
GROUP, WITH MANY OF YOU SITTING
ON THIS FLOOR. AND I DON'T HAVE
TO TELL YOU THAT FENTANYL IS THE
LATEST OPIOID CRISIS THAT'S
PLAGUING OUR COUNTRY AND THIS
GREAT STATE, AND HAS BEEN FOR
DECADES. AND IT'S DECIDEDLY THE
MOST DANGEROUS OF ALL OF THEM.
IT'S EASILY PRODUCED IN LABS AND
PROBABLY IN GARAGES AND IS MORE
POWERFUL, MORE ADDICTING, AND
MORE DANGEROUS THAN ANY OTHER
OPIOID. SADLY, OVER 150 PEOPLE
DIE EVERY DAY FROM OVERDOSES
RELATED TO SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS
LIKE FENTANYL. AS A FORMER AIR
FORCE OFFICER, MY SENSE OF DUTY
EXTENDS EVEN BEYOND THE GENERAL
PUBLIC TO OUR MEN AND WOMEN WHO
SERVE OUR GREAT COUNTRY AND THE
MILITARY, I'M SAD TO TELL YOU,
IS NOT IMMUNE TO THE RISING
FENTANYL CRISIS. PARENTS OF
SOLDIERS, AIRMEN, COAST GUARD
PERSONNEL, SAILORS, MARINES,
SPACE GUARDIANS. NOW, THEY'RE
NOT EXEMPT FROM THE FEAR THEIR
CHILD COULD DIE FROM AN OVERDOSE
. I REMEMBER READING AN ARTICLE
IN THE WASHINGTON POST LAST YEAR
THAT STATED THAT THE ARMY LOST
127 SOLDIERS TO FENTANYL BETWEEN
2015 AND 2022. THAT'S MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF ARMY
PERSONNEL KILLED IN COMBAT
DURING THAT TIME. WHEN WE SAY
THAT MANY OF THESE POLICIES,
THESE FENTANYL POLICIES ARE
EVIDENCE BASED, WE MEAN IT. SOME
HERE HAVE SPENT MONTHS MEETING
WITH THE NATION'S TOP EXPERTS,
AND THEY AGREE THAT EXPANDING
TREATMENT IS MORE EFFECTIVE,
MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING
CRIME AND ADDICTION THAN
INCARCERATION. THÀNH. NOW, TO BE
CLEAR, WE NEED TO BE TOUGH AND
LAW AND ORDER IS IMPORTANT.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE ABOUT IN THE
MILITARY, THE RULE OF LAW. BUT
IF WE WANT LONG TERM RESULTS, WE
NEED TO RELY ON WHAT'S WORKING,
NOT TEMPORARY FIXES. DOING THE
RIGHT THING IS OFTEN NOT THE
EASIEST THING TO DO, BUT DOING
THE RIGHT THING IS 100% WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IN THIS CASE. AND THE
RIGHT THING IS TO LOOK AT THE
PROBLEM OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE AS A
WHOLE AND BUILD SUPPORT SYSTEMS
FOR THOSE WHO ARE TRULY
SUFFERING. SO STUDIES SHOW THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WILL
ACCEPT TREATMENT WHEN IT IS EASY
TO ACCESS AND OFFERED IN A
CONVENIENT LOCATION. THAT'S WHY
THIS APPROACH IS DESIGNED TO
INTERCEPT PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE
IN EMERGENCY ROOMS, IN JAILS,
PRISONS, IN COURTS, AND CONNECT
THEM TO TREATMENT AND CONNECT
THEM TO TREATMENT. NOW WE ALSO
HAVE PROPOSALS TO INCENTIVIZE
MORE MEDICAL PROVIDERS TO TREAT
ADDICTION, EXPEDITE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF TREATMENT SITES,
AND WE INTEND TO CONTINUE TO
PUSH FOR AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKERS IN THIS STATE TO
DO THE JOB. PEOPLE WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS NEED
TREATMENT, NOT PUNISHMENT, AND
DRUG USE DISORDERS SHOULD BE
APPROACHED WITH A DEMAND FOR
HIGH QUALITY CARE AND COMPASSION
FOR THOSE AFFECTED. AGAIN, LET
ME BE CLEAR. CALIFORNIA LAW
ALREADY LETS US THROW THE BOOK
AT DRUG CRIMINALS. WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING HERE IS A NEW CHAPTER
FOR THOSE SUFFERING FROM
ADDICTION. IT'S THE RIGHT
APPROACH, AND I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT IT. BUT IT'S ALSO JUST
THE BEGINNING. WE DON'T PLAN TO
STOP WORKING ON THIS ISSUE UNTIL
OUR STATE IS SAFER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. NOW, WITH RESPECT
TO THE BILL, IT'S BILL SB SEVEN,
OR RATHER 1385. IT'S PART OF OUR
SAFER CALIFORNIA POLICY PLATFORM
, AND IT REQUIRES MEDI-CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO CREATE A
BILLING PATHWAY FOR SUBSTANCE
ABUSE NAVIGATORS PLACED IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT TO BUILD
THE MEDI-CAL PROGRAM UNDER THE
NEWLY IMPLEMENTED COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER BENEFIT. IN ORDER
TO SUSTAIN THESE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE, NAVIGATORS WHO ARE VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT IN STEERING
PEOPLE TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT. A FUNDING SOURCE IS
NEEDED, AND THIS BILL CREATES
THAT FUNDING SOURCE BY ALLOWING
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE NAVIGATORS
TO BUILD A MEDI-CAL PROGRAM FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED TO A MEDI-CAL
RECIPIENT DURING EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISIT OR AS AN
OUTPATIENT FOLLOW UP TO AN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISIT.
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. DEBATE. HEARING.
SEEING NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. IS THERE
ANY NO, WE DON'T HAVE 39 OKAY.
SO WE NEED A ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. MEMBERS. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 30.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OTTOBOCK AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMMER. AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL Ó. AYE 39. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 75
BY SENATOR WAHAB. SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1319 BY SENATOR
WAHAB. AN ACT RELATING TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU. SB 1319 WILL
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE, ACCESS AND INFORMATION,
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO RECEIVE AND
PROCESS APPLICATIONS FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FACILITIES MORE EFFICIENTLY.
THIS BILL WILL NOT CHANGE THE
APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS, BUT
SIMPLY DIRECTS DEPARTMENTS TO
COORDINATE RELATED APPLICATION
PROCESSES TO EXPEDITE APPROVALS.
SB 1319 IS A PART OF THE
SENATE'S BIPARTISAN SAFER
CALIFORNIA PLAN, WHICH INCLUDES
AN EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH TO
THE FENTANYL CRISIS THAT
INCREASES ACCESS TO TREATMENT,
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES, OR
SNIFFS SERVE AN ELDERLY AND OR
DISABLED POPULATION, MOST OF
WHOM ARE EITHER MEDI-CAL OR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES, OR BOTH.
THERE IS ALSO A SEGMENT OF SNFS
THAT PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES, IN ADDITION TO
TRADITIONAL SNIF CARE TO
RESIDENTS THAT HAVE CO-OCCURRING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS. IN
ADDITION TO THEIR PHYSICAL
NURSING NEEDS, THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT DEMAND FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SNIFF
SERVICES, BUT IT CAN BE
CHALLENGING FOR SNIFF PROVIDERS
WHO WISH TO EXPAND OR CONVERT
EXISTING SNIFF FACILITIES TO
PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
AND SKILLED NURSING SERVICES. IN
ADDITION TO THE PHYSICAL
FACILITY MODIFICATIONS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO OFFER SNIFF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES, THE
PROCESS FOR OBTAINING THE
NECESSARY APPROVALS FROM THE
MULTIPLE STATE DEPARTMENTS THAT
REGULATE DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
THE PROCESS CAN BE TIME
CONSUMING AND DELAY THE
PROVISION OF MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY. SB
1319 WILL STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
FOR EXPANDING AND CONVERTING A
WHOLE OR PART OF THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FACILITIES BY REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF TIME NEEDED FOR
FACILITIES TO OBTAIN THE
NECESSARY APPROVALS FROM STATE
AGENCIES TO BE A LICENSED AND
OPERATING MEDI-CAL PROVIDER. I
DO ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
OUR FASTEST GROWING, SUBSTANCE
ABUSE VICTIMS TEND TO BE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS, AND AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE, WE NEED TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO GET
THE TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
EIGHT HEARING AND SEEING NONE
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE? AYES 39.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR WAHAB WOULD
FOLLOW ITEM 69. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. SENATE BILL c BY
SENATOR WAHAB AND RELATING TO
CRIMES. SENATOR WAHAB. THANK
YOU. I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
982, WHICH IS PART OF THE
SENATE'S SAFER CALIFORNIA PLAN,
AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S RETAIL
THEFT PACKAGE. THIS BILL SIMPLY
ELIMINATES THE JANUARY 1ST, 2026
SUNSET TO SUSTAIN THE CRIME OF
ORGANIZED THEFT PERMANENTLY.
DESPITE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
UNDERREPORTED RETAIL THEFT,
ESPECIALLY LOW VALUE THEFT. DATA
SHOWS A 29% JUMP IN REPORTED
RETAIL THEFT FROM 2019 TO 2022.
ASIDE FROM BIG RETAILERS, MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE SUFFERING
THE CONSEQUENCES OF ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT AND OFTENTIMES DO
NOT HAVE THE SAME RESOURCES TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES. IN
CALIFORNIA, FOR NEARLY HALF OF
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE OWNED BY
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MINORITY
GROUPS. ONE RETAILERS ARE
AFFECTED BY THESE CRIMES. THEY
TYPICALLY MAKE UP THOSE LOSSES
BY RAISING PRICES, REDUCING
HOURS, OR CLOSING THEIR STORES
COMPLETELY, ULTIMATELY IMPACTING
OTHER CONSUMERS AND THE
COMMUNITY. AS A WHOLE. SB 982
WILL ENSURE ORGANIZED THEFT
REMAINS A CRIME TO GIVE
PROSECUTORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
THE EFFECTIVE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
COMBAT ORGANIZED THEFT. SB 982
IS A BIPARTISAN EFFORT THAT WILL
KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE BY
MAKING SURE LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
RESPOND TO THE CRIME OF
ORGANIZED THEFT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. GREAT ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR NILO? THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE AS A
JOINT AUTHOR IN SUPPORT OF SB
982. AS A RESULT OF THE HOOVER
COMMISSION HEARINGS HELD LAST
YEAR, I LEARNED, NUMBER ONE,
THAT THIS BILL ORIGINALLY
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMAN
JONES-SAWYER, WAS GOING TO BE
SUNSETTING AND THE DISTRICT
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS IN MY AREA
HERE, BOTH MY DISTRICT AND CLOSE
BY, FOUND THIS TO BE A VERY
USEFUL TOOL, AS WAS VERY WELL
ARTICULATED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FROM HAYWARD. AND SO I SOUGHT TO
ELIMINATE THE SUNSET. ALSO, I
INTRODUCED A BILL THAT TURNED
OUT TO BE IDENTICAL. BILL AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HAYWARD
GRACIOUSLY WELCOMED ME ONTO HER
BILL SO THAT WE DON'T ONLY HAVE
ONE DOING THE SAME THING, BUT IT
IS A VERY VALUABLE TOOL FOR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD GO AWAY SHORTLY.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING SEEING
NONE. SENATOR WAHAB, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? SHE'S NO LONGER
THERE.
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING APPLYING
THE UNANIMOUS UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL TO THIS MEASURE? HEARING.
SEEING NONE. AYES 39. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 55 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1416 BY SENATOR NEWMAN AND
ACT RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1416 WHICH IS ALSO A COMPONENT
OF THE SENATE'S WORKING TOGETHER
FOR A SAFER CALIFORNIA PACKAGE
AND WHICH CREATES A SET OF
ESCALATING ENHANCEMENTS FOR
MIDDLEMEN FOUND GUILTY OF
PROFITING FROM THE SALE,
EXCHANGE, RETURN OR ATTEMPTED
RESALE OF ITEMS OBTAINED THROUGH
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT,
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
OPERATIONS OFTEN INVOLVE
MULTIPLE PEOPLE COLLABORATING IN
A COORDINATED EFFORT TO OBTAIN
STOLEN MERCHANDISE FROM MULTIPLE
STORES IN ORDER TO AGGREGATE THE
AMOUNT OF STOLEN GOODS FOR
EVENTUAL RESALE. IN RECENT YEARS
, ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME
OPERATIONS HAVE INCREASINGLY
TARGETED SPECIFIC TYPES OF
MERCHANDISE WITH HIGH RESALE
VALUE, AND FOR WHICH THERE IS
DEMONSTRATED DEMAND. ONE VERY
PROBLEMATIC BYPRODUCT OF THE
INTERSECTION OF THE POWER OF
SOCIAL MEDIA AND THE GROWTH OF
ONLINE MARKETPLACES, IS THE EASE
WITH WHICH INDIVIDUALS AND
SYNDICATES CAN SEAMLESSLY
COORDINATE THE ACTIVITIES OF
OTHERS TO STEAL, CONSOLIDATE,
AND THEN RESELL STOLEN GOODS.
OFTEN AT LEVELS OF SCALE WHICH
HAVE BEGUN TO COMPETE WITH THE
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES FROM WHICH
THESE GOODS ARE OFTEN STOLEN
FROM IN THE FIRST PLACE. THE
ENHANCEMENTS CREATED BY SB 1416
WILL ADD ANOTHER SET OF TOOLS TO
SUPPORT THE WORK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS DOING IN THIS
AREA. AS PART OF THE WORKING
TOGETHER FOR A SAFER CALIFORNIA
PACKAGE BY ENHANCING THE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES ASSOCIATED
WITH ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT, SB
1416 WILL BETTER SAFEGUARD
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESSES BY
DETERRING THOSE WHO WOULD STOOP
TO PROFIT FROM IT. I AM
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR RUBIO? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, I ALSO STAND HERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1416. AND I
JUST REALLY WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR AND ALL OF THOSE THAT ARE
WORKING COLLECTIVELY ON THESE
PUBLIC SAFETY PACKAGES. I KNOW
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING FOR A WHILE. I JUST
WANT TO SHARE ONE PARTICULAR
INCIDENT. I HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
IN MY COMMUNITY WHO'S BEEN
ARRESTED ALMOST. I THINK IT'S 14
TIMES AT THIS POINT FOR THE SAME
EXACT CRIME. AND OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE STRUGGLING, NOT BEING ABLE
TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT. SO THIS
BILL IN PARTICULAR IS VERY
VALUABLE NOT ONLY AS A COMMUNITY
MEMBER, BUT TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND I THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT
WE GIVE THEM THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO TACKLE THIS
PROBLEM. AND THIS IN PARTICULAR
IS ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT, WHICH
IS REALLY HARMING OUR
BUSINESSES. SO ON BEHALF OF OUR
BUSINESSES AND PUBLIC SAFETY AND
OUR COMMUNITIES, IT WAS MUCH
NEEDED. SO WITH THAT, I ALSO ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER MEMBER
DESIRES TO SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR NEWMAN, YOU
MAY CLOSE. I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BALDWIN PARK, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS,
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS.
UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
55? SEEING NONE. AYES 39, NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 68 BY SENATOR
SKINNER. SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 950 BY SENATOR SKINNER. AN
ACT RELATING TO REENTRY. SENATOR
SKINNER, FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I'M VERY PLEASED
THAT SB 950 IS PART OF OUR,
SAFER FOR CALIFORNIA PACKAGE. WE
KNOW THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THOSE WHO WE HAVE INCARCERATED
IN OUR STATE PRISONS GO HOME AND
WHEN THEY GO HOME, WE WANT THEM
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THAT
REENTRY. AND WE DO NOT WANT
RECIDIVISM. SO IN 2015, OUR
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
LAUNCHED A PROGRAM CALLED THE
MALE COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAM.
NOW THERE'S ALSO THE FEMALE
COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAM, BUT
THESE ARE COLLECTIVELY KNOWN AS
CPPS. AND WHAT CCPA CPPS ARE ARE
FACILITIES IN THE COMMUNITY
WHERE A PERSON WHO IS STILL IN
CUSTODY UNDER CDCR, BUT THEY ARE
IN A PROGRAM FOR 1 TO 2 YEARS
BEFORE THEY'RE RELEASED THAT
PROVIDES MUCH MORE FOCUSED
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES AND
REALLY ASSISTS THEM IN BEING
SUCCESSFUL AT REENTRY. AND IN
FACT, THE DATA SHOWS THAT THOSE
SO FAR, THOSE PROGRAMS, THE
RECIDIVISM RATE OF MCHP
RESIDENTS IS ABOUT A 10TH OF
THOSE WHO ARE JUST RELEASED FROM
OUR STATE PRISON. WITHOUT THAT,
WITHOUT HAVING PARTICIPATED IN
SUCH A PROGRAM. NOW, ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF AN MCHP IS THAT WE
CAN WE THE STATE, CAN ENROLL
THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN THINGS LIKE
MEDI-CAL SO THAT WE CAN FULLY
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF CAL AIM. AND
IN CALFRESH AND IN OTHER
SUPPORTIVE, OTHER BENEFITS
PROGRAMS SO THAT THERE'S A
SEAMLESS TRANSITION THÀNH ONCE
THEY ARE RELEASED, THEY ALREADY
HAVE THEY'RE THEY'RE COVERED BY
MEDI-CAL. THEY HAVE THEIR HEALTH
CARE, THEY HAVE FOOD BENEFITS.
THEY HAVE THE THINGS THEY NEED
WHILE THEY GET THEIR FEET ON THE
GROUND. AND SUCCEED. NOW, WE
KNOW THAT MANY OF THE FOLKS THAT
ARE WE RELEASING FROM CDCR HAVE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. AND
WHILE THEY MAY BE CLEAN, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHILE THEY'RE IN THE
MCHP PROGRAM, THEY NEED THOSE
SUPPORTS. THEY NEED EITHER
CONTINUED, SUBSTANCE ABUSE,
SUPPORT PROGRAMS, OR THEY NEED
MAYBE THE MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT. THOSE VARIETY OF
THINGS CAN BE PROVIDED TO THEM
THROUGH MEDI-CAL AND THROUGH CAL
AIM. FURTHER, WE EVEN HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR A VERY
TEMPORARY TRANSITIONAL TIME.
HOUSING SUPPORTS. SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS DIRECTS CDCR TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE PRE-ENROLLED THE
RESIDENTS IN OUR CP PROGRAMS
INTO ALL THOSE PROGRAMS THAT I
DESCRIBED, THOSE BENEFIT
PROGRAMS. AND SO THAT WE CAN
MAXIMIZE THEIR USE AND THUS
MAXIMIZE THE SUCCESS AND THIS
DOES HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT ON OUR
FENTANYL ADDICTION PROBLEM,
BECAUSE THOSE WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS, IF THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE CONTINUED SUPPORT, THEY
VERY, VERY COMMONLY. AND THIS IS
PEOPLE ACROSS THE BOARD,
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCE IS, YOU FALL BACK
IN TO YOUR ADDICTION, THE
ADDITIONAL THING THAT SB 950
DOES IS CREATE A WORKING GROUP
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS, OUR, BSCS AND OUR
DEPARTMENT OF AGING ARE MEANING
THAT'S OUR SOCIAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT TO LOOK AT WAYS TO
CREATE ADDITIONAL REENTRY
FACILITIES FOR THOSE WITH
ADVANCED AGE AND WITH
DISABILITIES, WITH THAT, I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. MEMBERS. THIS TIÂU IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
TO FILE ITEM 68? HEARING. SEEING
NONE. AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP IS
SENATOR SKINNER. AGAIN WOULD
FOLLOW ITEM 46. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. SENATE BILL 1144 BY
SENATOR SKINNER IN AQUITAINE TO
BUSINESS. SENATOR SKINNER FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, AGAIN VERY
PLEASED THAT SB 1144 IS PART OF
OUR PART OF OUR SAFER FOR
CALIFORNIA PACKAGE, IN 2022, SB
301 WAS SIGNED INTO LAW AND IT
ESTABLISHED REGULATIONS FOR
ONLINE MARKETPLACES AND LET ME
PREFACE THIS WITH, YOU KNOW, WE
ALL KNOW INCREASINGLY GOODS ARE
PURCHASED ONLINE THROUGH THE
INTERNET. WE DO IT. EVERYBODY
DOES IT. AND, YOU KNOW, IF
YOU'RE IF PEOPLE ARE BUYING
THEIR GOODS ONLINE, THEN YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT ONLINE SALES ARE
ALSO INCREASINGLY BECOMING THE
SOURCE FOR RETAIL THIEVES TO USE
TO, IN EFFECT, FENCE THOSE
STOLEN GOODS. SO THE PURPOSE OF
THAT ORIGINAL LAW, SB 301, WAS
TO REQUIRE ONLINE MARKETPLACES
TO VALIDATE THE LEGITIMACY OF
THE SELLERS SO THAT WE COULD
HELP REDUCE THIS. USE OF OUR
ONLINE SERVICES FOR SELLING
STOLEN GOODS. SO IT REQUIRED THE
SELLER HIGH VOLUME SELLERS, TO
SHOW THAT THEY HAD A BUSINESS
LICENSE THAT THEY HAD A TAX ID,
VARIOUS THINGS LIKE THAT, THAT
MOST THIEVES DON'T LIKE TO, YOU
KNOW, DON'T LIKE TO HAVE A TRACK
RECORD WITH GOVERNMENT. NOW, THE
BILL HAS BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE.
IT'S WORKING GREAT, BUT IT WORKS
MOST EFFECTIVELY WHEN THE SELLER
HAS THE TRANSACTION FOR THE SALE
DIRECTLY ON THE MARKETPLACE, OR
RATHER ON THE PLATFORM. SO IN
OTHER WORDS, IF I'M BUYING THAT
GOOD, THEN I AM PAYING THROUGH
THAT PLATFORM AND THE SELLER IS
GETTING THE MONEY THROUGH THE
PLATFORM. NOW, WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IS A VERY LARGE RISE IN WHAT'S
CALLED ONLINE MARKETPLACES,
WHERE WE DON'T WHERE THE SELLER
ADVERTISES THE GOODS, AND I THE
BUYER WILL SAY, OH YEAH, I WANT
THAT. GOOD. BUT I DON'T MAKE THE
CASH TRANSACTION ACTUALLY,
THROUGH THAT PLATFORM, I MIGHT
DO IT THROUGH PAYPAL OR THROUGH
VENMO OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I'M NOT USING THAT PLATFORM. SO
WHAT HAPPENS THERE IS THOSE
SELLERS ARE NOT BEING REQUIRED
TO LEGITIMIZE THAT. THEY ARE
LEGITIMATE SELLERS. THEY'RE NOT
GIVING TAX ID, THEY'RE NOT
SHOWING THAT THEY HAVE BUSINESS
LICENSES. SO WE WHAT'S HAPPENED
IS, YOU KNOW, THIEVES ARE
CLEVER. THEY'RE MOVING MANY OF
THEIR SALES OF STOLEN GOODS OVER
TO THE MARKETPLACES THAT DON'T
HAVE THESE REQUIREMENTS. SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS PUT VERY
COMPARABLE REQUIREMENTS ONTO THE
ONLINE MARKETPLACES FOR THEIR
SELLERS, HIGH VOLUME SELLERS.
AND WE NEED IT BECAUSE WE NEED
TO DISINCENTIVIZE THESE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
OPERATIONS. AND WITH THAT, I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, RETAIL
THEFT IN CALIFORNIA ABSOLUTELY
IS A PROBLEM. AND I APPRECIATE
THE STEPS THAT WE'RE TAKING THIS
MORNING TO BEGIN ADDRESSING THAT
ISSUE. IN CONTRAST TO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
THIS MORNING, I DO BELIEVE THAT
PROP 47 DOES NEED A COMPLETE
OVERHAUL AND SOME REFORMS THAT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO ALL
CALIFORNIA INS TO THIS BILL,
SPECIFICALLY SB 1144, I HAVE
VOTED NO ON THIS BILL IN
APPROPRIATIONS. I BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S STILL SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
FEDERAL LAW, SOME DETAILS OF THE
ENFORCEMENT AND DETAILS OF HOW
THE ONLINE, PLATFORMS ARE GOING
TO COMPLY. BUT I'VE GOT A VERY
COMPELLING I RECEIVED A VERY
COMPELLING LETTER FROM MY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL, SO THAT THIS THIS
MORNING, I'M PREPARED TO ABSTAIN
ON A VOTE ON THIS BILL, WATCHING
HOW IT MOVES THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY AND HOPEFULLY HAVE A
BILL THAT I CAN FULLY SUPPORT
WHEN IT COMES BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. IF IT DOES, I JUST.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, FOR
THE TIME THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU. SENATOR DARLING, A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR. MR. PRESIDENT,
WILL YOU TAKE A QUESTION? YES.
WHAT IS CONSIDERED A HIGH VOLUME
SELLER? I COULDN'T FIND THE
NUMBER. IS IT A IS IT A DOLLAR
NUMBER OR AN ITEM NUMBER? IT'S A
DOLLAR NUMBER.
COLLEGES. WHY? WHILE I LOOK FOR
THAT. WHAT IS IT? I COULDN'T
FIND IT. I BELIEVE. THE. IT IS
BOTH A DOLLAR AMOUNT AND THE
NUMBER OF TRANSACTIONS. IT'S
$5,000 MINIMUM AND 200 TRANS
ACTIONS OVER THE COURSE OF 12
MONTHS. OKAY. THANK YOU. THAT'S.
I COULDN'T FIND. I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT THAT NUMBER WAS. THANK YOU.
SATISFIED? ALL RIGHT. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
OR COMMENTS ON THIS MEASURE?
HEARING. SEEING. NONE. SENATOR
SKINNER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
? THANK YOU, IN ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE OF, WHY ARE WHY DO WE NEED
TO GO AFTER THE ENTITIES THAT
ARE SELLING LARGE AMOUNTS OF
THESE STOLEN GOODS? I'LL GIVE
YOU A GREAT EXAMPLE. SOME OF YOU
MAY HAVE SEEN THIS NEWSPAPER
ARTICLE WHERE A WEALTHY COUPLE
FROM SAN DIEGO AREA WERE BUSTED,
BY THE FBI. AND SOME, I THINK
THEIR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS
ALSO INVOLVED. AND THEY WERE
ORGANIZED. THEY WERE AN
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT RING.
THEY THEMSELVES DIDN'T GO TO ANY
STORE AND STEAL ANYTHING THEY
EMPLOYED. AVOID LOW INCOME
PEOPLE TO STEAL THINGS FOR THEM,
WHICH THEY THEN UNLOADED ONLINE.
SO THE POINT OF THAT STORY IS,
AND THEY ACTUALLY WHEN THEY WERE
BUSTED AND THE NEWSPAPER ARTICLE
SHOWED IT, THERE WERE MANY EMAIL
AND TEXT MESSAGES WHERE THEY
WERE DIRECTING THESE LOW INCOME
PEOPLE LIKE, GO TO SEPHORA. WE
NEED THIS MUCH. WE NEED THIS
KIND OF THING. SO, YOU KNOW,
HERE'S ALL THE SEPHORA LOCATIONS
WE NEED, YOU KNOW, THIS KIND OF
MAKEUP OR, YOU KNOW, WHATEVER WE
NEED. AND DIFFERENT LOCATIONS OF
PLACES. SO THE POINT BEING THAT,
YES, WE WANT TO WE DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE ANYONE STEALING ANYTHING
FROM STORES. BUT IF WE DON'T GET
AT THE SOURCE OF THE UNLOADING
OF THESE GOODS YOU HAVE, YOU'RE
CONSTANTLY YOU CAN, WE CAN
ARREST AND INCARCERATE ANY
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
WHAT MIGHT BE CALLED THE
SHOPLIFTING. BUT IF THERE'S
STILL ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
RINGS LIKE THIS COUPLE IN SAN
DIEGO, THAT WILL JUST CONTINUE
TO FIND SOME PERSON IN NEED OF
MONEY TO GO AND STEAL THINGS
FROM SEPHORA, WE DON'T END THE
PROBLEM. SO BILLS IN THIS BILL
AND THE OTHERS IN THIS PACKAGE
ARE AIMED AT GETTING RIGHT AT
THE SOURCE OF THE PROBLEM. AND
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON. ITEM
46. ADAN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEAR AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DEL.
NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEMON.
AYE MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. I'M
IN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BORG AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN BECKER.
AYE. GROVE JONES. NGUYEN SATO.
WILK AYES 33. NOES ONE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 66. SENATOR
UMBERG, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 909 BY SENATOR UMBERG. AN
ACT RELATING TO PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE,
SENATOR UMBERG UMBERG THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, SB 909
IS A BILL THAT STRENGTHENS OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE BY
REMOVING THE MAXIMUM LOAN
REPAYMENT LIMIT OF THE $105,000
CURRENT LIMIT FOR THE STEPHEN M
THOMPSON, PHYSICIAN CORPS LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM, THIS ENABLES
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE IN MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
AREAS BY INCREASING THE AMOUNT
BY WHICH THEY MAY SEEK AND
RECEIVE LOAN REPAYMENT. I URGE,
AND I VOTE, THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE
MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
66? SEEING NONE AYES 39. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS SENATOR UMBERG WOULD FILE
ITEM 67. HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 910 BY SENATOR UMBERG AND
AQUILINA COURTS. SENATOR UMBERG
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, THIS
BILL IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
THE MAKING CALIFORNIA SAFER,
INITIATIVE. COLLABORATIVE COURTS
ARE THE COURTS THAT YOU SEE IN
YOUR LOCALITIES THAT ADDRESS,
FOR EXAMPLE, DRUG ISSUES,
VETERANS ISSUES, HOMELESS ISSUES
, MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES, DUI
ISSUES. THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
COLLABORATIVE COURTS. AND THE
PURPOSE IS TO TAKE OFTEN A YOUNG
PERSON WHO'S COMMITTED A CRIME,
TO STEER THEM IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BY PUTTING THEM IN A
PROGRAM, A PROCESS THAT IS QUITE
RIGOROUS. IT IS QUITE RIGOROUS,
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU HAVE TO DO BOTH
RANDOM DRUG TESTING AND OFTEN
DRUG TESTING. ONCE A MONTH, YOU
HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE TO THE COURT
THAT YOU ARE ON A PATHWAY TO
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENSHIP, EITHER
THROUGH EDUCATION OR JOB OR BOTH
, IT IS A PROGRAM THAT IS
HIGHLY, HIGHLY, HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
IN TERMS OF RECIDIVISM, SADLY,
THOUGH, SOME COUNTIES DON'T HAVE
COLLABORATIVE COURTS FOR
WHATEVER REASON. IN OTHER
COUNTIES HAVE COLLABORATIVE
COURTS THAT ARE HIGHLY DEPENDENT
UPON THE PASSION, THE DEDICATION
OF THE BENCH OFFICER. IF THE
BENCH OFFICER IS DEDICATED, IF
THE BENCH OFFICER IS, FOCUSED,
THEN THE RESULTS ARE VERY, VERY
GOOD. IF NOT, THE RESULTS ARE
NOT SO GOOD. WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS THIS BILL APPLIES BEST
PRACTICES AS ESTABLISHED
NATIONALLY, COLLABORATIVE COURTS
HAVE BEEN IN EXISTENCE
NATIONALLY FOR DECADES. AND
THERE ARE BEST PRACTICES AND WE
SHOULD EMPLOY THEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL SIMPLY
SAYS THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO IS WE'RE GOING TO PROMULGATE,
USE AND TRAIN IN TERMS OF BEST
PRACTICES. I URGE, AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE THIS
Tð IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
67? SEEING NONE AYES 39. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT
UP IS FILE ITEM 79 BY SENATOR
BOGUE. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1442 BY SENATOR
OCHOA. AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. SEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
DEDICATED TO PROMOTING THE
SAFETY AND WELL-BEING OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, I BELIEVE IT IS
CRUCIAL FOR POLICY MAKERS TO
WORK TOGETHER IN A BIPARTISAN
MANNER TO CREATE POLICIES THAT
PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS. I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLABORATE WITH OUR DEMOCRAT
SENATE PRO TEM, MCGUIRE, AND
ALSO WITH OUR REPUBLICAN SENATE
MINORITY LEADER, BRIAN JONES.
AND, IN THE OTHER HOUSE AS WELL,
WITH THE LEADERS THERE. IF WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE IMPACTFUL CHANGE,
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE BRING
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE
AND NOT WORK IN SILOS, CREATING
ECHO CHAMBERS THAT MAY PROVE OR
HAVE BEEN PROVEN DETRIMENTAL TO
OUR COMMUNITY SAFETY. IT IS
WITHIN THAT SPIRIT THAT I'M HERE
TO PRESENT THE FOLLOWING TWO
BILLS. IN OCTOBER 2023, THE FDA
APPROVED THE FIRST
OVER-THE-COUNTER POINT OF CARE
FENTANYL TEST IN AS LITTLE AS
FIVE MINUTES. THIS TEST CAN BE
CAN INDICATE TO A PROVIDER THAT
WHETHER THEY'RE, WHETHER THEIR
PATIENT HAS USED FENTANYL. THIS
INDICATION THROUGH PRELIMINARY
COULD SAVE PRECIOUS TIME IN
DIRECTING TREATMENT, LEADING TO
IMPROVED OUTCOMES SUCH
INFORMATION IS CRITICAL GIVEN
THAT MANY VICTIMS HAVE NO IDEA
THAT THE SUBSTANCE THEY WERE
USING CONTAINED FENTANYL. SB
1442 WILL EXPAND ACCESS TO POINT
OF CARE FENTANYL TEST BY
AUTHORIZING THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
, THROUGH THE CALOREX
INITIATIVE, TO ENTER INTO
PARTNERSHIPS TO DEVELOP,
PRODUCE, PURCHASE AND DISTRIBUTE
SUCH TEST BY ENSURING THE MORE
PROVIDERS CAN TEST FOR FENTANYL
USE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. SB 1442
WILL EXPAND OUR EFFORTS TO
REDUCE FENTANYL OVERDOSE DEATHS.
SB 1442 IS PART OF THE SENATE'S
WORKING TOGETHER FOR A SAFER
CALIFORNIA PACKAGE, AND HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 79. ALAN ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. AYE DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. STERN AYE. UMMER. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN. WHEN SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS ONE MOMENT. CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN. ALAN. WHEN? SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. AYE. 38. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW, MEMBERS.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FALL. ITEM 61
AGAIN BY SENATOR OCHOA BOGH.
SHE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. SENATE BILL 1468 BY
SENATOR OCHOA. AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALING ARTS. SENATOR, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS SENATE BILL
1468 WILL EDUCATE AND ENCOURAGE
PROVIDERS TO MAKE USE OF THE
2023 DRUG ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
RULE THAT ALLOWS PRACTITIONERS
TO DISPENSE A THREE DAY SUPPLY
OF NARCOTIC MEDICATION TO START
DETOXIFICATION OR MAINTENANCE
TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE WHO USE
OPIOIDS. LICENSED PRACTITIONERS
WILL RECEIVE A NOTIFICATION
PROVIDED BY BOARDS UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
THAT WILL PROVIDE HELPFUL
INFORMATION ON HOW TO PRESCRIBE
THIS MEDICATION. THE PROVIDED
RESOURCES WILL INCREASE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE LIFE SAVING
BENEFITS REGARDING EXISTING
MEDICATION THAT ASSISTS
TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER, OPIOID WITHDRAWAL
SYMPTOMS CAN BE INTENSELY
UNCOMFORTABLE, AND IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS THEY THEY THERE CAN
BE LIFE THREATENING
COMPLICATIONS. THIS ANNUAL
NOTIFICATION WILL HELP EASE THE
BURDENS PLACED ON PATIENTS
STRUGGLING WITH OPIOID USE
DISORDER, GIVING THEM A BETTER
CHANCE OF SUCCESS. SB 1468 IS
PART OF THE SENATE'S WORKING
TOGETHER FOR A SAFER CALIFORNIA
PACKAGE, AND HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE
MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
61? HEARING. SEEING NONE AYES
38. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
CORTEZ WITH FILE ITEM 65.
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 908 BY SENATOR CORTEZ, AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
SENATOR FLORES YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB 908, WHICH IS
INCLUDED IN THE PACKAGE. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THAT, IN BARELY
MORE TIME THAN I'VE BEEN IN THE
SENATE IN THREE AND A HALF
YEARS, WE HAVE LOST 25 CHILDREN,
FIVE AND YOUNGER, FROM FENTANYL
POISONING IN CALIFORNIA. IN
FACT, MORE THAN 100 INFANTS
YOUNGER THAN AGE ONE YOUNGER
THAN AGE ONE HAVE DIED OVER THE
LAST TWO DECADES. EVEN MORE
RECENTLY, VÆ IN MY OWN DISTRICT,
BABY PHOENIX, WHO WAS THREE
MONTHS OLD WHEN SHE DIED FROM A
FENTANYL OVERDOSE AND SHE WAS
THE FIRST OF THREE SOUTH BAY
TODDLERS YOUNGER THAN TWO KILLED
WITHIN SIX MONTHS. SB 908 WILL
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC EDUCATION
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO UTILIZE ALL
OF ITS AVAILABLE DATA TO SPREAD
AWARENESS AND DEVELOP GUIDELINES
TO PROTECT AND PREVENT FENTANYL
RELATED DEATHS OF CHILDREN. 0 TO
5. THIS WILL TAKE CONFUSION OUT
OF LOCAL SITUATIONS CURRENTLY
WHERE PEOPLE ARE GRAPPLING AND
DEBATING OVER HOW TO DEAL WITH
THE PROBLEM. THESE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED ANNUALLY BEGINNING
JUNE 1ST, 2025 TO LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS, COUNTY
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS AND TO THE
LEGISLATURE, AS WELL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING. SEEING. NONE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
65? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
AYES 38. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 80
BY SENATOR ASHBY. SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1502 BY
SENATOR ASHBY. AN ACT RELATING
TO CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
SENATOR FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. HONORED TO
BE ONE OF THE SENATORS
ADDRESSING THE DEADLY FENTANYL
CRISIS IN THIS SAFER CALIFORNIA
PACKAGE TODAY. SB 1502 WILL
PREVENT THE ILLICIT USE OF
XYLAZINE WHILE CREATING
GUARDRAILS FOR THE DRUG'S
CONTINUED USE IN VETERINARY
MEDICINE PRACTICE. THIS BILL IS
PART OF THE SENATE'S WORKING
TOGETHER FOR A SAFER CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE. THIS
COMPONENT, ADDRESSING THE
FENTANYL CRISIS, COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS TRANQ OR THE
ZOMBIE DRUG XYLAZINE, IS A
POTENT SEDATIVE WITH
INCREASINGLY PREVALENT IN OUR
COUNTRY. THERE IS A GROWING
TREND OF MIXING FENTANYL AND
XYLAZINE, RENDERING IT THE
DEADLIEST DRUG COMBINATION IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. SB
1502 ADDS XYLAZINE TO THE LIST
OF SCHEDULE THREE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES, WHICH ENABLES THE
DRUG ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO
RESTRICT ACCESS TO IT. XYLAZINE
IS CONSIDERED UNSAFE FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION. IT RENDERS ITS USER
INTO A ZOMBIE LIKE STATE, OFTEN
LEADING TO AMPUTATION FROM
SEVERE WOUNDS AND FATAL
OVERDOSES. UNLIKE OTHER OPIOIDS,
XYLAZINE OVERDOSES CANNOT BE
REVERSED BY NARCAN. IT'S CRUCIAL
THAT WE PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
FROM THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
XYLAZINE, AND PARTICULARLY ITS
DEADLY COMBINATION WITH
FENTANYL, BY REGULATING ITS
AVAILABILITY AND PREVENTING ITS
MISUSE. I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION, SENATOR RUBIO? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, I RISE
IN STRONG, STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
1502. WE ALREADY HAVE A REALLY
BIG CRISIS ON OUR HANDS, WHICH
IS THE USE OF FENTANYL AND
ADDING XYLAZINE TO THE MIX. IT'S
A PROBLEM ON TOP OF THE PROBLEM.
AND SO THIS BILL IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO PREVENT THE ILLICIT
USE OF XYLAZINE, ESPECIALLY AS
WE SEE ACROSS OUR NATION. IF
SOME OF YOU HAVE NOT WITNESSED
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OTHER
STATES, FOR EXAMPLE, STATE OF
PHILADELPHIA HAS COMPLETE ZONES
THAT ARE NOW REFERRED TO AS
ZOMBIE COMMUNITIES BECAUSE YOU
SEE PEOPLE WALKING AROUND NOT
AWARE OF THEIR SURROUNDINGS.
MOST OFTEN THEY'RE SLUMPED OVER,
NOT BEING ABLE TO GET UP. AND IF
WE DON'T STOP THIS HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WE WILL SEE
THAT CONTINUE TO BE USED IN OUR
STATE. AND AGAIN, WE ARE SEEING
PEOPLE THAT OUR DAUGHTERS,
MOTHERS, BROTHERS, AND THIS IS
WHERE WE STOP IT. SO I'M VERY
THANKFUL TO THE WORKING GROUP AS
WELL AS THE GREAT SENATOR FROM
SACRAMENTO FOR INTRODUCING THIS.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT AN INTENDED USE IS.
THERE IS SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE
THAT IT IS USED FOR OUR OUR
ANIMALS, WHICH IS WHAT THE
INTENT WAS. BUT AGAIN, WE NEED
TO KEEP IT AWAY FROM THE USE OF
FENCE BILL BECAUSE OUR KIDS ARE
GETTING A HOLD OF THIS AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO STOP IT.
SO AGAIN, I'M SO THANKFUL THAT
THIS BILL, ALONG WITH THE OTHER
BILLS PRESENTED BY THE SENATE'S
WORKING GROUP FOR A SAFER
CALIFORNIA, WILL HELP CURB THE
USE OF THIS DEADLY DRUG. IT
SHOULD NOT BE CONSUMED BY
HUMANS. AND WITH THAT, I ALSO
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING
SEEING NONE. SENATOR ASHBY,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? SENATOR
ASHBY, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU. URGE. AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
80? HEARING SEEING. NONE. AYES
38, NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW NEXT UP IS SENATOR
WIENER WOOD, FILE ITEM 64. HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 905 BY SENATOR
WIENER. AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMES. SENATOR WIENER, I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES SOME OF YOU MAY
RECOGNIZE SB 905 BECAUSE THIS IS
MY THIRD EFFORT AT THIS BILL.
GOING BACK TO, I BELIEVE, 2018,
SB 905 DOES TWO THINGS. FIRST,
IT HAS TO DO WITH AUTO BREAK
INS. AND FIRST IT CLOSES. WHAT
WE CALL THE LOCKED DOOR
LOOPHOLE, A NONSENSICAL BARRIER
TO HOLDING AUTO BURGLARS
ACCOUNTABLE, UNDER EXISTING LAW,
IN ORDER TO PROVE OF, THE CRIME,
THE CRIME OF BREAKING INTO A CAR
, IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO SHOW THAT
YOU FORCIBLY ENTER THE CAR. THE
DA ALSO HAS TO PROVE THAT THE
DOORS TO THE CAR THAT ALL OF
THEM WERE LOCKED. SO EVEN IF YOU
HAVE INCONTROVERTIBLE EVIDENCE
THAT SOMEONE BROKE INTO THE CAR,
IF YOU CAN'T PROVE THE DOORS ARE
LOCKED, THAT CAN CAUSE THE
ENTIRE PROSECUTION TO COLLAPSE,
SOME PEOPLE MAY NOT REMEMBER IF
THEY LOCKED THEIR CAR DOOR, IN
SITUATIONS WHERE SOMEONE IS
VISITING CALIFORNIA AND THEIR
CAR GETS BROKEN INTO, THEY MAY
NOW BE THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY,
AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO COME
BACK AND TESTIFY IN COURT. IT
MAKES NO SENSE IF YOU CAN PROVE
THAT THE CAR WAS BROKEN INTO,
THAT SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT. AND
THIS BILL WILL CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE, THE SECOND THING THAT
THE BILL DOES, HAS TO DO WITH
ORGANIZED RESALE OF GOODS THAT
ARE STOLEN FROM CARS, AUTO
BURGLARS OFTEN SEEK VALUABLE
ITEMS SUCH AS LAPTOPS, CAMERAS,
CELL PHONES, AND THEN RESELL
THEM, UNDER THIS BILL,
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE PROSECUTED IF
THEY HAVE MORE THAN $950 WORTH
OF STOLEN GOODS FROM STOLEN FROM
VEHICLES INTENDED FOR RESALE,
EVEN IF THESE GOODS WERE STOLEN
IN MULTIPLE INCIDENTS, THIS BILL
IS PART OF THE PRO TEM WORKING
TOGETHER FOR A SAFER CALIFORNIA
PACKAGE, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR JONES. MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS, CALIFORNIA'S AUTO
BREAK-IN, CHALLENGES OUR WORLD.
KNOWN, TOURISTS EVEN KNOW OF
THIS CHALLENGE. SO I'M VERY
HAPPY THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING
THIS THIS MORNING WITH SB 905. I
AM A COAUTHOR AND WILL BE VOTING
AYE AND ASK FOR THE ENTIRE BODY
TO JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO ALSO SAY I
WILL BE SUPPORTING AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S, WORK ON
SOME UNINTENDED, ISSUES THAT ARE
BEING RESOLVED. SO FOR THAT, I
WANT TO THANK AND I WILL SUPPORT
, BUT I WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS MOMENT TO GIVE A BIG
SHOUT OUT TO DETECTIVE MICHAEL
VENTURA OF THE NORTHEAST
DIVISION OF LAPD. ON SATURDAY,
WE PARTNERED TO DO AN EVENT, IN
LOS ANGELES, THE SERVICES WERE
FREE VIN, ETCHING, FREE STEERING
WHEEL LOCKS AND SOFTWARE UPDATES
FOR THE HYUNDAI VEHICLES, LAPD
AND TRAP THE TASK FORCE FOR
REGIONAL AUTO THEFT PREVENTION,
IT'S A STATE FUNDED,
MULTI-AGENCY TASK FORCE THAT
CONSISTED OF OFFICERS FROM
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT WERE
WORKING TOGETHER. SO I WANT TO
GIVE THEM A SHOUT OUT BECAUSE
THIS ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF
PREVENTION NOT ONLY AFTER THE
FACT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR CHOBOQ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I RISE
AS A PROUD COAUTHOR OF SB 905,
WHICH SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE
RISING BREAK, CAR BREAK INS AND
BURGLARIES ACROSS OUR STATE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, A VICTIM OF A
CAR BREAK IN MUST PROVE THAT
THEY LOCKED THEIR CAR DOOR IN
ORDER TO, FOR THEIR PERPETRATOR
TO BE CHARGED WITH A CRIME. SB
905 WILL MAKE CAR BREAK-INS
EASIER TO PROSECUTE AND KEEP
PERPETRATORS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS. I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE, SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR THIS WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SENATOR WIENER, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SEEING
NONE, SENATOR WIENER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, I AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS, CAR BREAK-INS ARE A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA. I DO WANT TO STRESS
THAT I KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
WORKING VERY HARD WITH
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE, AND WE SHOULD MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE DOING OUR PART.
AND THIS BILL WILL HELP DO THAT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THIS
TWO IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON FILE ITEM 64
HEARING. SEEING NONE. AYES 38.
NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO OUR LAST BILL ON
OUR SAFER CALIFORNIA PACKAGE.
AND THAT'S FILE ITEM 72 BY
SENATOR MEN. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1242 BY SENATOR MIN. AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR MANN
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. THIS
IS THE LAST BILL IN THE SENATE'S
SAFER CALIFORNIA PLAN. I'M THE
CLOSER HERE, SB 1242 WOULD ALSO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE RISING
PROBLEM OF RETAIL THEFT, WE'RE
ALL AWARE THAT RETAIL THEFT IS
GROWING DRAMATICALLY IN THIS
COUNTRY AND IN THIS STATE AND
BECOMING INCREASINGLY
SOPHISTICATED. ONE TACTIC THAT
IS INCREASINGLY BEEN USED IS
ARSON. YES. SETTING A FIRE TO
DISTRACT RETAIL STAFF SO THAT
MASS RETAIL THEFT CAN THEN OCCUR
. THIS DANGEROUS DIVERSION
ENDANGERS LIVES AND DISRUPTS
BUSINESS OPERATIONS. STORES NOT
ONLY LOSE THE STOLEN
MERCHANDISE, BUT SUFFER DAMAGES
TO THEIR BUILDINGS AND THEIR
MERCHANDISE. SOMETIMES HAVING TO
CLOSE FOR WEEKS TO MAKE REPAIRS.
SB 1242 WOULD SPECIFY THAT FOR
THE CRIME OF RECKLESS ARSON, THE
FACT THAT THE OFFENSE WAS
CARRIED OUT WITHIN A MERCHANT'S
PREMISES IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT SHALL BE
A FACTOR IN AGGRAVATION AT
SENTENCING. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL, BUT WE HAVE
AN OBJECTION TO IT. SO WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 72.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL. AYE
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BREAKSPEAR I
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ
AYE. DALLY I DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER I.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN.
ARCHULETA. BRADFORD ULTRABOOK.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AGE 36,
NOES ZERO. SO THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
BREAK FOR LUNCH. WE'RE GOING TO
THANK YOU FOR, A VERY PRODUCTIVE
MORNING. WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT
WE STAY IN THE BUILDING AND NOT
GO BACK TO YOUR OFFICE. WE WILL
HAVE A 30 MINUTE LUNCH BREAK,
AND WE'LL BE WORKING LATE THIS
EVENING. SO WE WANT TO GET BACK
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE FROM LUNCH
SO WE CAN CONTINUE THE WORK THAT
WE HAVE BEGUN. SO WE'RE GOING TO
ASK AGAIN THAT YOU STAY HERE IN
THE CAPITOL, AND THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL 1230.
MEMBERS. THE SENATE WILL CONVENE
IN 30S. THE SENATE WILL CONVENE
IN 30S.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE BACK
AT IT. WE'RE GOING TO START OFF
WITH FILE ITEM 23. AS SENATOR
WILK AT HIS DESK AND READY TO GO
. SENATOR WILK SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1194 BY SENATOR
WILK AND AQUILINO TO ELEMENTARY
AND SECONDARY EDUCATION. THÀNH
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I APPRECIATE THAT,
MEMBERS, I PRESENT TO YOU SB
1194, WHICH IS A TRANSPARENCY
MEASURE THAT REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO POST THE NAMES AND
COUNTY OF RESIDENCE FOR MEMBERS
THAT SIT ON ITS PARENTAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. THE COUNCIL
WAS FIRST CREATED IN EARLY 2022
AT THE DIRECTION OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF INSTRUCTION
TONY THURMOND. SO THAT, QUOTE,
DIVERSE PARENTS CAN DIRECTLY
WORK WITH POLICYMAKERS AND
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS TO PROVIDE
EQUITABLE CHANGE TO CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATION SYSTEM THROUGH
AUTHENTIC PARENT VOICES. IN
JANUARY OF 2023, APPLICANTS
BEGAN TO RECEIVE REJECTION
LETTERS BUT WERE NOT ABLE TO
FIND INFORMATION ON WHO WAS
SELECTED FOR THE COMMITTEE. WHEN
MY STAFF REACHED OUT TO THE CDE,
THEY WERE TOLD THAT IT WOULD BE
THAT THE NAMES WOULD BE POSTED
OF THE SELECTED COUNCIL MEMBERS.
THEY ESTIMATED THAT AT THE THAT
THE INFORMATION WOULD BE
ANNOUNCED BY THE END OF 2023.
HOWEVER, WE SIT HERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF MAY AND THAT
INFORMATION IS YET TO BE POSTED
AND NO OTHER ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION HAS BEEN PROVIDED AS
WELL. SO THIS BILL SIMPLY
REQUIRES THE CDE TO PROVIDE THE
PUBLIC WITH BASIC INFORMATION
ABOUT WHO WAS CHOSEN TO
REPRESENT PARENTS ON THIS
COUNCIL AND WHAT COUNTY THEY
REPRESENT. I THOUGHT THIS
MEASURE WAS A COMMON SENSE
TRANSPARENCY POLICY, BUT LAST
MONDAY WAS PULLED FROM THE
CONSENT. CONSENT CALENDAR. A
COUPLE SENATORS HAVE INFORMED ME
THAT THEIR PRIMARY CONCERN WAS
THAT THE BILL WITH THE BILL WAS
THE POTENTIAL COMPROMISE OF THE
COUNCIL MEMBER'S PRIVACY OR
SAFETY. THESE ARE CONSIDERATIONS
THAT I TAKE SERIOUSLY AS WELL.
SO I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFICATION FOR THOSE WHO MAY
SHARE THIS CONCERN. IT IS COMMON
PRACTICE FOR SIMILAR CDE
ADVISORY COMMITTEES TO
VOLUNTARILY POST THE NAMES
EMPLOYERS AND POSITION OF THEIR
MEMBERS. FOR EXAMPLE, THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION, THE ADVISORY
COMMISSION ON CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND THE ADVISORY COMMISSION ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION ALL POST THIS
INFORMATION. SOME COMMITTEES
EVEN POST SHORT BIOGRAPHIES AND
THE EMAILS OF THEIR MEMBERS FOR
THE FEW BOARDS THAT DON'T
DISCLOSE THIS INFORMATION, THEY
ALL INCLUDE A MEDIA ARCHIVE OF
PREVIOUS MEETINGS, UPCOMING
MEETINGS, AND INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT ANY OF
THESE MEMBERS EVER EXPERIENCED
ANY HARASSMENT OR VIOLENCE
BECAUSE THEIR NAME WAS WAS
PUBLIC ON A COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY THE PAC
SHOULD BE HELD TO A DIFFERENT
STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC
ACCESS AND TRANSPARENCY. IF
SOMEONE CHOOSES TO BECOME A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE GROUP,
THE PEOPLE THEY SPEAK TO, THEY
SPEAK FOR HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHO THEY ARE AND IF THEIR
COMMUNITY IS BEING REPRESENTED.
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN STATED
THAT THE COUNCIL WAS CREATED TO
HELP ENSURE THE CDE AS, QUOTE,
REACHING OUT TO OUR FAMILIES TO
MAKE SURE THEY ARE INCLUDED IN
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
EDUCATION LOOKS LIKE FOR
CHILDREN. END QUOTE. THAT WAS
FROM THE APRIL 5TH, 2022 PRESS
RELEASE AND HAS NOW BEEN OVER
TWO YEARS AND NO ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION HAS BEEN MADE
PUBLIC. PARENTS CAN'T BE
INCLUDED IN THE CONVERSATION IF
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHO'S
PARTICIPATING IN WHAT'S BEING
DISCUSSED. THIS BILL SIMPLY
BRINGS THE PRACTICES OF THE
PARENTAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
COMMISSION IN GREATER ALIGNMENT
WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT'S STATED
MISSION TO ENSURE FAMILIES ARE
AT THE CENTER OF ALL THE C, CDE
DOES. WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING OUR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM? WE HAVE
AN OBJECTION BY A MEMBER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MINH. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SECRETO. AYE. SKINNER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER. NO.
WILK. AYE SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA. BECKER GROVE. AYE.
LIMON PADILLA. SKINNER. AYES 33.
NOES ONE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 25 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO. HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1128 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
AN ACT RELATING TO SEX OFFENSES.
SENATOR PORTANTINO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS. SB 1128 WOULD
REQUIRE TIER ONE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION IF AN OFFENDER
ENGAGES IN UNLAWFUL SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE WITH A MINOR AND THE
OFFENDER IS MORE THAN TEN YEARS
OLDER THAN THE MINOR, FAILING TO
REQUIRE REGISTRATION FOR
OFFENDERS, ENGAGING IN UNLAWFUL
SEXUAL INTERCOURSE OF A MINOR IS
INEXPLICABLE, AND THIS UNDERCUTS
EFFORTS TO PREVENT SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION, TRAFFICKING OF
CHILDREN THROUGHOUT ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES. EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION FOR OTHER FORMS OF
SEXUAL CONTACT, BUT NOT ACTUAL
INTERCOURSE, THAT LOOPHOLE NEEDS
TO BE RECTIFIED. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO, MANY
MINORS ENGAGING IN THESE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE EXPLOITED,
MANIPULATED, AND FALL VICTIM TO
TRAFFICKING AND OTHER TYPES OF
ABUSE. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
VICTIMS COME FROM MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IS $150 BILLION A YEAR GLOBAL
INDUSTRY AND OVER 24,000 VICTIMS
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED IN
CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA
CONSISTENTLY RANKS NUMBER ONE IN
THE NATION FOR REPORTING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES. SB 1128 IS
ESSENTIAL TO PROTECTING
VULNERABLE YOUTH FOR HOLDING
SEXUAL OFFENDERS ACCOUNTABLE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS. IT WAS SPONSORED BY THE
LOS ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 25 ALAN ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY. AYE DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE LEMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO AYE. OCHOA. BORG. AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. NØ. WILK. AYE
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA BECKER. EGGMAN
NÓ. SKINNER NO. AYES 34. NOES
THREE. THE MEASURE PASSES NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM 78 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY.
MY BAD, MY BAD. WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO 27 FIRST BY SENATOR CORTEZ
. HE IS READY. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ SENATE BILL 1299 BY
SENATOR CORTEZ, AN ACT RELATING
TO WORKER'S COMPENSATION.
SENATOR CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES, I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB 1299, SOME
OF THE LARGEST AGRICULTURAL
COUNTIES IN THE STATE ARE
EXPERIENCING RECORD BREAKING
HEAT WAVES IN 2022. KING CITY IN
MONTEREY COUNTY BROKE ITS
HOTTEST TEMPERATURE EVER
RECORDED AT 116 DEGREES. FRESNO
RECORDED AN ALL TIME HIGH AT 114
DEGREES. THE INCREASED FREQUENCY
OF EXTREME HEAT CONDITIONS AND
ITS GROWING RISK TO WORKERS
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE AND
NECESSITY OF EMPLOYER COMPLIANCE
WITH CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
OUTDOOR HEAT REGULATIONS TO KEEP
WORKERS SAFE, SB 1299 PROMOTES
COMPLIANCE WITH THE EXISTING
OUTDOOR HEAT REGULATION THROUGH
A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION FOR
HEAT RELATED INJURY AND DEATH.
FARM WORKERS WHO SUFFER INJURY,
ILLNESS, OR DEATH WHILE WORKING
FOR A NON-COMPLIANT EMPLOYER
WILL BE TREATED AND COMPENSATED
EXPEDITIOUSLY. SB 1299 DOES NOT
CREATE ANY ADDITIONAL WORKER'S
COMP BENEFIT LEVEL BEYOND WHAT
IS OTHERWISE AVAILABLE UNDER THE
EXISTING WORKER'S COMP LAW, NOR
DOES IT APPLY TO COMPLIANT
EMPLOYERS. EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
COMPLIANT ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE
REMEDIES IN THIS BILL AT ALL.
FINALLY, IT DOES NOT CREATE A
PENALTY FOR NON-COMPLIANT
EMPLOYERS AT ALL. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 27. ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. NØ DODD. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NO.
NHIÀU. NO. OCHOA. BORG NO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK NO. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN.
ALVARADO. GILL NO. ARCHULETA.
DODD GLAZER. AYE. JONES NO.
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROW ONE MORE TIME. ALAN
ARCHULETA. DODD. AYE. AYES 29,
NOES NINE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM 78 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1432 BY SENATOR CABALLERO
AND AQUALINK TO HEALTH
FACILITIES. SENATOR FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS. I RISE TO PRESENT
SB 1432, WHICH CREATES
TRANSPARENCY, ACCOUNTABILITY AND
A VIABLE PATHWAY FOR HEALTH
FACILITIES TO ACHIEVE SEISMIC
COMPLIANCE. AS MANY OF YOU ARE
AWARE, HEALTH CARE ACCESS FOR
ALL IS IN JEOPARDY GIVEN THE
DISTRESSED FINANCIAL CONDITION
OF CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS. SOME OF
WHICH ARE IN YOUR DISTRICTS. THE
ALFRED Â ALQUIST HOSPITAL
SEISMIC SAFETY ACT REQUIRES THAT
BY JANUARY 1ST, 2030, ALL
HOSPITAL BUILDINGS MUST HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE PATIENT
SERVICES FOLLOWING AN EARTHQUAKE
. PURSUANT TO CURRENT LAW,
HOSPITALS THAT DO NOT COMPLY
WITH THIS 2030 SEISMIC STANDARD
WILL BE REQUIRED TO CLOSE THEIR
DOORS TO PATIENT CARE. LET ME
REPEAT THAT IF YOU ARE NOT
SEISMICALLY, IF YOU HAVE NOT
FIXED YOUR SEISMIC ISSUES AND
YOU'RE A HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
BY 2030, YOU ARE REQUIRED TO
CLOSE YOUR DOORS TO PATIENT
CARE. ALL OF YOU KNOW THAT I HAD
A HOSPITAL THAT CLOSED IN MY
DISTRICT AND THOSE OF US THAT
HAD HOSPITALS AT RISK UNDERSTOOD
COMPLETELY WHAT IT MEANS TO LOSE
A HOSPITAL TO A REGION AND DID
NOT HAVE EMERGENCY HEALTH CARE
AVAILABLE. THIS IS WHY THIS BILL
IS SO IMPORTANT. ACCORDING TO A
2019 RAND INSTITUTE STUDY, THE
ESTIMATED COST OF UPGRADES AND
CONSTRUCTION FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS TO COMPLY WITH THE
2030 SEISMIC STANDARDS RANGE
FROM 34 BILLION TO 140 BILLION,
DEPENDING ON COMPLIANCE APPROACH
. IN OTHER WORDS, WHETHER
THEY'RE RETROFITTING AN EXISTING
BUILDING OR CONSTRUCTING NEW
ONES. THE TIME FRAME AND COST TO
MEET THE 2030 STANDARDS ARE A
MAJOR CHALLENGE, ESPECIALLY FOR
FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED
HOSPITALS. THE RAND STUDY
SUGGESTS THAT THE COST OF
UPGRADES WOULD PUT 40% OF
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS IN, QUOTE,
SEVERE FINANCIAL DISTRESS IN
IMMEDIATE RISK OF BANKRUPTCY,
COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC HOSPITALS
WOULD TAKE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
HIT FURTHER HINDERING ACCESS TO
CARE FOR THE MANY MEDI-CAL AND
MEDICARE PATIENTS WHO DEPEND ON
THEM. AND THIS IS WHY INCREASING
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES
BECOMES SO IMPORTANT, BECAUSE
WITH THOSE INCREASED RATES,
HOSPITALS CAN PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE AND PUT TOGETHER THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED.
FINANCIAL STRAIN SEVERELY
IMPACTED HOSPITALS DURING THE
COVID 19 PANDEMIC, AS THEY
EXPERIENCED NEW FINANCIAL AND
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES, LEAVING
MANY HOSPITALS IN DISTRESS. FROM
FROM 2019 TO 2020. CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITAL TOTAL NET INCOME
DECREASED BY $9.49 BILLION. MORE
THAN 50% OF CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
LOSE MONEY EVERY DAY TO CARE FOR
PATIENTS. FURTHERMORE, A AS
HOSPITALS CONTINUE TO FACE
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURES, MANY
ARE FORCED TO REDUCE SERVICES TO
KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN. AND
YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD OF
HOSPITALS THAT ARE ABANDONING,
PRENATAL CARE AND MATERNITY
SERVICES, LABOR AND DELIVERY
SERVICES AND THINK ABOUT A
COMMUNITY WITH NO LABOR AND
DELIVERY SERVICES. THAT WOULD BE
ABSOLUTELY UNTENABLE. AND YET
IT'S HAPPENING AS WE SPEAK.
HOSPITALS ARE ESSENTIAL TO OUR
COMMUNITY'S HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING, AND CALIFORNIA MUST
ACT QUICKLY TO PREVENT FURTHER
LOSS OF ACCESS TO CARE. THAT'S
WHY SB 1432 IS A IS CRITICAL TO
IMPROVE SEISMIC SAFETY IN OUR
LOCAL HOSPITALS BY ESTABLISHING
A FRAMEWORK THAT IS NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH, BUT
RECOGNIZES REGIONAL HEALTH CARE
CHALLENGES AND THAT ENHANCES
TRANSPARENCY, DEMANDS
ACCOUNTABILITY, AND CREATES A
VIABLE PATHWAY FOR OUR HOSPITALS
TO MEET SEISMIC COMPLIANCE
STANDARDS. ACCORDING TO EACH
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES. WHILE THEY
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
HEALTH CARE TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
I WANT TO GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION WITH MY GOOD
FRIEND. OKAY, NOW I CAN'T
REMEMBER YOUR CITY SENATOR, BUT
MY GOOD FRIEND, THE SENATOR
RIVERSIDE, THAT'S CORRECT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. YOU SAVED ME, HE
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE, HE
WAS THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. AND HIS
COMMITTEE WAS FABULOUS,
IMPORTANT. AND THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE MET A
NUMBER OF WE MET WITH A NUMBER
OF TIMES, THIS IS A MAJOR EFFORT
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO CRAFT A SOLUTION THAT MOVES
US FORWARD. THE COST OF DOING
NOTHING IS HOSPITAL CLOSURES AND
LACK OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS TO
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD
THAT. SB 1432 IS A SOLUTION THAT
ALLOWS HOSPITALS TO SEE A VIABLE
PATHWAY TO COMPLIANCE WITHOUT
ELIMINATING CRITICAL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY,
AND TO ENSURE THAT THE INTENT OF
THE HOSPITAL SEISMIC SAFETY ACT
IS MET. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR AGREEING TO TACKLE
THIS, THORNY ISSUE. MAYBE OUR
PRO TEM WOULD HAVE ANOTHER WORD
FOR IT. SQUISHY. BUT WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE, IN A
HAPHAZARD AND ONE OFF MANNER FOR
DECADES AND DECADES AND DECADES
IN THIS STATE. AND WE NEED TO
GET THIS PROCESS ORGANIZED. WE
NEED TO GUIDE HOSPITALS TOWARD
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A MASTER PLAN
FOR SEISMIC COMPLIANCE. ALL OF
THEM, THAT LISTS GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND SETS MILESTONES
THAT CAN BE MONITORED, MEASURED,
AND FRANKLY ENFORCED AT. AND
THEN WE NEED TO HELP HOSPITALS
MOVE DOWN THEIR MASTER PLAN
THROUGH THEIR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES, HITTING THEIR
MILESTONES. AND WHEN THEY HIT A
BUMP IN THE ROAD, WE NEED TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL EXTENSIONS TO
THEM, ALL THE WHILE MARCHING
THEM DOWN THE ROAD TO FULL
COMPLIANCE. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
MOST ALL OF THE HOSPITALS IN THE
STATE WON'T COLLAPSE ON OUR
RESIDENTS, OUR CONSTITUENTS, AND
THEY WON'T BE KILLED IF WE HAVE
AN EARTHQUAKE THROUGH THE
COLLAPSE. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
MANY, MANY, MANY HUNDREDS, IF
NOT THOUSANDS OF THEM WON'T BE
FUNCTIONING BECAUSE THEY DON'T
MEET THE NON PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA FOR THEIR REQUIRED. THE
GAS LINES WON'T STAY, THE WATER
LINES WON'T WORK. THE EMERGENCY
POWER PLANTS WON'T OPERATE, THE
FOOD WON'T BE AVAILABLE TO
PATIENTS. SO IN THE END WITHOUT
THIS AND WITHOUT THE AUTHOR'S
BILL AND THE AUTHOR'S BILL,
MAKING SURE THE AUTHOR'S BILL
WORKS, WE WON'T HAVE HOSPITALS
THAT CONTINUE TO OPERATE IN THIS
STATE, WHICH WILL BE A DISASTER.
SO AGAIN, I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER HARD WORK. AND
THIS IS A GREAT BILL AND I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB 1432,
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HER COMMITMENT ON OUR
FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED
HOSPITALS. SHE OFTEN IS SERIOUS,
BUT IT KIND OF ALMOST SOUNDS
LIKE A JOKE WHEN SHE SAYS, I HAD
NO INTENTION OF WORKING ON
HOSPITAL ISSUES AND THEN WE ALL
GET TRAPPED INTO THINGS THAT
HAPPEN, THAT HAPPEN TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND OUR DISTRICT.
AND, SHE HAD A HOSPITAL THAT
CLOSED, WHICH IMPACTED OUR
HOSPITALS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
SEEKING CARE WERE GOING 6 OR 40
MILES SOUTH TO MY DISTRICT,
WHICH IS IMPACTING MY HOSPITALS.
SO I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR ENGAGING IN THIS PROCESS
BECAUSE IT IS A MULTIFACETED
PROCESS, THE RATES, OBVIOUSLY,
THAT HAVE BEEN PROMISED TO OUR
PROVIDERS AND OUR HOSPITALS THAT
SHOULD HAVE TAKEN PLACE JANUARY
1ST, THAT ARE STILL NOT BEING
PAID AT THE CORRECT RATE YET. WE
HAVE GOT A COMMITMENT THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE RETROACTIVE LIVE
BACK TO JANUARY 1ST, BUT THE
PROVIDERS OR THE HOSPITALS ARE
NOT GETTING THOSE RATES AS OF
YET, I KNOW SHE'S ACTIVELY
WORKING ON THAT. AND THEN ALSO
ADDRESSING THE SEISMIC ISSUE,
YOU KNOW, BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BEING PUT INTO, EITHER THE
CONSTRUCTION OR THE
REVITALIZATION OF SOME HOSPITAL
WINGS AND HOSPITAL, HOSPITAL
AREAS. AND IT DOESN'T MATTER, I
JUST THINK THAT WHEN WE DO
POLICY, I DON'T THINK WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS ON THE
GROUND, BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU ARE A HOSPITAL AND
YOU HAVE AN EMERGENCY SITUATION,
YOU NEED A VIABLE EMERGENCY
ROOM, AND YOU NEED A VIABLE
LABOR AND DELIVERY AND A VIABLE
CARDIAC ROOM. BUT THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE DOING ELECTIVE
SURGERIES, I MEAN, THEY CAN
WAIT, IF THAT MAKES SENSE. IF
THEIR ELECTIVE SURGERIES. SO TO
FOOLPROOF, THE ENTIRE HOSPITAL
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
REQUIRED, ESPECIALLY BY THE END
DATE THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US,
BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
TO COMPLY WITH, ESPECIALLY WHEN
OUR HOSPITALS ARE HAVING
FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES. I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
ON THE HIGH FINANCIALLY
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL BILL, WHERE
WE WERE ABLE TO ALL OF US VOTED
TO PUT MONEY INTO A FUND SO THAT
THESE HOSPITALS, MOST ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS, DID APPLY FOR THOSE
RESOURCES AND GET THEM. AND IT
SAVED A MAJORITY OF OUR
HOSPITALS. AND I THINK THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THIS IS JUST ONE MORE THING
THAT WE HAVE TO TACKLE. I'M THE
ONLY SENATOR IN THE LAST, I
BELIEVE, DECADE THAT HAS A 7.1
EARTHQUAKE IN MY DISTRICT IN
RIDGECREST, THEN A 6.9, 6.2. THE
EARTHQUAKES WENT ON FOR QUITE A
WHILE. A WEEK AFTER I BELIEVE
IN, EXCUSE ME, JULY 5TH, 19,
2019, 2019 ON JULY 5TH. AND THEY
WENT ON FOR A WEEK AFTER. AND
AGAIN, THE HIGHEST, I BELIEVE
WAS SIX POINT OR, EXCUSE ME,
7.1, THE LOWEST WAS 6.2. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THE OLD, I WANT TO
CALL IT ADOBE BRICK. PART OF THE
HOSPITAL STOOD STOOD THE TEST OF
TIME. MAN. THEY HAD TO MOVE
EVERYBODY, EVEN FROM THE NEW
SEISMIC COMPLIANT ROOMS AND THE
SEISMIC COMPLIANT TOWER THAT WAS
BUILT JUST A FEW YEARS BEFORE.
THERE WAS CRACKS IN THAT
FOUNDATION. THEY HAD PROBLEMS
WITH THAT. THEY STILL DON'T HAVE
EVERYBODY BACK INTO THAT
FACILITY, BUT THAT COST THEM
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO COMPLY
WITH THE SEISMIC THAT WAS SIGNED
OFF ON BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT PARTICULAR
TOWER DID NOT STAND THE TEST OF
TIME WITH THIS EARTHQUAKE. SO I
REALIZE THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
STAFF SAFE. WE NEED TO KEEP OUR
PATIENTS SAFE. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT BUILDINGS DON'T
COLLAPSE ON TOP OF PEOPLE. BUT
WE ALSO CANNOT PUT A DEADLINE
OUT THERE THAT'S OUT THERE LIKE
IT IS RIGHT NOW, THAT YOU WILL
CLOSE, BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU,
WITH THE EARTHQUAKES AND THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED OUT IN OUR
COMMUNITY, IF RIDGECREST
WOULDN'T HAVE HAD THAT SEISMIC
COMPLIANT BUILDING, THE NON
COMPLIANT BUILDING THAT ACTUALLY
HELPED, PEOPLE WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN THERE TO HELP PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT DESPERATELY NEEDED
IT. AND I HAD JUST SENT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY A VIDEO. SHE'S GOING TO
GO ON A TRIP. SORRY TO OUT YOU,
BUT YOU'RE GOING, SHE'S GOING TO
GO ON A TRIP IN MY DISTRICT. AND
I WAS DRIVING DOWN THE CANYON
BECAUSE I WENT TO PARDON ME,
SHE'S ALREADY OUTED. OH SO I WAS
COMING DOWN THE CANYON. AND WHY
THE RIDGECREST HOSPITAL IS SO
VITALLY IMPORTANT IS THAT IT? IT
IS THE MEDICAL FACILITY FOR THE
SOUTH CHINA SEA PROTECTOR, THE
CHINA LAKE NAVAL AIR WARFARE
CENTER, WHICH IS THE LARGEST
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT ARM FOR
THE UNITED STATES MILITARY. WE
ALL, ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
NEED THIS BASE. AND WHEN I HEAR
PEOPLE SAY, OH, IT'S ONLY 50
MILES TO THE OTHER HOSPITAL,
IT'S 50 MILES DOWN A TWO LANE
ROAD THAT IS OFTEN BLOCKED OFF
BECAUSE OF ROCKSLIDES. THERE'S A
50 FOOT WALL ON ONE SIDE OF THE
CANYON, AND THEN A 50 FOOT DROP
GOING DOWN TO THE RIVER, WHERE
MY COLLEAGUE IS GOING TO BE
WHITEWATER RAFTING SOON, IT'S
NOT LIKE A HIGHWAY 58 OR A 210
DRIVE. SO ALL OF THAT TO SAY
THAT I THINK THAT WHETHER YOU'RE
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA OR YOU'RE IN
, IF YOU'RE IN URBAN CALIFORNIA,
OUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO GO TO A HOSPITAL AND HAVE IT
AVAILABLE TO THEM. AND I THINK
THAT PUSHING THIS OUT FURTHER
AND MAKING SURE WE STILL HOLD
HOSPITALS ACCOUNTABLE, BUT
MAKING SURE THAT THEY CAN STILL
STAY OPEN TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
NEEDS IS VITALLY IMPORTANT. AND
I WANT TO APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR
TACKLING THIS ISSUE, EVEN THOUGH
IT WASN'T IN HER TOP LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES, SHE HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION ON THE ISSUE. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN
. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE AS A COAUTHOR. YOU KNOW,
EVERYBODY HERE IS PROBABLY
AWARE, SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION GOVERNING
SEISMIC RETROFITTING, OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM, ESPECIALLY
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS, HAVE
BEEN MASSIVELY IMPACTED BY A
WHOLE HOST OF UNEXPECTED EVENTS
TO INCLUDE THE PANDEMIC. AND SO
THIS BILL, ALONG WITH AT LEAST
TWO OTHERS THAT WE'VE HEARD THIS
WEEK, MAKES SENSIBLE ALLOWANCES
WHILE RETAINING PROVISIONS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AS PART OF THAT PROCESS. AND SO
WE DO APPRECIATE THE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY SOME OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
BOTH HEALTH CARE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY WORKERS. BUT TO THE
SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE POINTS,
THIS MEASURE WILL CREATE A
RESPONSIBLE, WORKABLE ROADMAP TO
FULL COMPLIANCE WHILE ENSURING
ACCESS TO CRITICAL CARE DURING
THAT PERIOD. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CORTEZ. WELL, THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I TOO, RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. BUT I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR. IF
SHE WOULD BE WILLING TO
ENTERTAIN IT. SENATOR CABALLERO,
WILL YOU TAKE A QUESTION? YES, I
WILL, THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
CONFUSION ON MY END, SENATOR, AS
TO THE PROPOSED LENGTH OF
EXTENSION AND HOW THAT WORKS,
AND I APOLOGIZE IF YOU'VE
EXPLAINED THAT OR FELT LIKE
YOU'VE EXPLAINED IT ALREADY, BUT
I JUST WANTED TO GET A CLEAR ON
THE RECORD. AND I KNOW, AMONGST
OTHER, OPPOSITION THAT CPF
PARTICULARLY HAD AN INTEREST IN
CONTINUING TO WORK TO TRY TO
JUST RESOLVE ANY DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION ON ON THE LENGTH OF
EXTENSION. AND SO THE SECOND
PART OF THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
YOU'RE YOU'RE WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON ON THAT
ISSUE TO THE EXTENT THERE'S
DISAGREEMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE FOR THE QUESTIONS,
IF I MAY. MR. PRESIDENT, THROUGH
THE CHAIR, SO FIRST OF ALL, IS
THAT THE WAY THAT THE BILL WORKS
IS, CURRENT LAW REQUIRES YOU TO
HAVE BE SEISMICALLY COMPLIANT BY
2030. THIS WOULD THIS WOULD GIVE
THE HCAI THE ABILITY TO EXTEND
THE PERIOD THREE YEARS IN DURING
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN, THERE'S A
WHOLE SERIES OF REQUIREMENTS
THAT HOSPITALS HAVE TO MEET
THEIR THERE ARE PLANNING
DOCUMENTS AND THEN MORE THAN
PLANNING DOCUMENTS, IF YOU ARE
IN A YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR
ALL OF THESE. MOST OF THE
HOSPITALS ARE PRIVATE NONPROFIT.
AND SO THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO SHARE THEIR INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR FINANCIAL
CAPABILITIES OR WHAT THEY'RE
SPENDING THEIR MONEY ON. BUT
HCAI HAS THE ABILITY NOW, AS
PART OF THE PLAN TO START
LOOKING AT THEIR FINANCIAL
INFORMATION, CLEARLY SOME ARE
CAPABLE OF STARTING A PROJECT.
AND IF YOU ARE, THEN YOU HAVE TO
START, DESIGNING IT, GETTING
YOUR PLANNING DOCUMENTS, GETTING
YOUR PERMITS. IN OTHER WORDS,
YOU HAVE TO START LINING UP YOUR
YOUR THE REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER
FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO GET
STARTED AND, AND THEN SHOW HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO FINANCE WHAT
WILL BE MASSIVE CONSTRUCTION.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND IN MANY INSTANCES,
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
IF YOU REQUIRE MORE INFORMATION
THAN HCAI WILL DETERMINE HOW
MUCH LONGER YOU NEED. AND THEY
CAN GIVE YOU UP TO FIVE YEARS,
BUT THEY CAN DO IT IN SMALLER
INCREMENTS DEPENDING ON WHERE
YOU ARE IN THE PLANNING AND
BUILDING PROCESS, SOME OF THE
HOSPITALS ARE HUGE HOSPITALS AND
HAVE A NUMBER OF CAMPUSES. AND
SO IT'S A QUESTION OF MAKING
SURE THAT THEIR, THEIR BRINGING
UP THE, THE SEISMICITY OF ALL OF
THE BUILDINGS. BUT THE OTHER
THING IS, IF THERE MAY BE
HOSPITALS THAT WILL HAVE TO
DISCUSS, CONTINUE PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY ROOM
ON THEIR ON THEIR CAMPUS TO
BUILD, AND THEY NEED TO TEAR
DOWN AND DEMOLISH BUILDINGS
BEFORE THEY BUILD NEW BUILDINGS.
AND, AND THE WHOLE POINT OF THAT
IS THAT IT MAY IMPACT THE REGION
. AND SO HCAI WILL BE LOOKING AT
THE REGION TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THE REGION CAN AFFORD FOR THAT
HOSPITAL TO LOSE THE SERVICES OF
THAT HOSPITAL AS WELL. SO IT THE
WHOLE IDEA IN THE BILL IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE AGAIN, NOT
ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL. SOME
MAY BE VERY SIMPLE, LIKE SOME OF
OUR SMALL HOSPITALS IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA, BUT SOME MAY BE PART
OF A BIGGER HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
NUMBER ONE. AND NUMBER TWO IS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO MEET. WE'VE HAD
A NUMBER OF ALL HANDS ON BOARD
MEETINGS, THAT HAVE INVOLVED ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT BECAUSE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION AS MANY OF THE
COMMENTS AS POSSIBLE. AND MANY
OF THE AMENDS THAT WERE TAKEN IN
DIRECT RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
ISSUES RAISED. FOR EXAMPLE, ONE
OF THE ISSUES RAISED IS THAT THE
LOCAL ELECTEDS HAD NO CLUE WHAT
WAS GOING ON WITH THE HOSPITAL.
THEY HAD NO IDEA THAT THE
HOSPITAL WAS UNDER, THE
REQUIREMENT TO START DOING THESE
SEISMIC PLANNING AND SO THE BILL
NOW REQUIRES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BE CONTACTED, THAT
THERE BE A PUBLIC PROCESS FOR
LOCALS TO BE INVOLVED IN, NOT
JUST LOCAL GOVERNMENT, BUT OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS,
SO THAT THEY CAN, LET HCAI KNOW
WHAT THEY THINK ABOUT THIS
HOSPITAL AND WHAT WHAT THE
CONCERNS ARE. SO, SO PUBLIC
INPUT AND TRANSPARENCY IS AN
INTEGRAL PART THAT WAS BROUGHT
TO US BY, SOME OF THE GROUPS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I URGE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU. SEN
EGGMAN, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
, AND MEMBERS, HOW DO YOU EAT AN
ELEPHANT? ONE BITE AT A TIME.
AND I THINK THAT THIS BILL IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF TRYING TO TACKLE
A REALLY BIG ISSUE AND BREAKING
IT DOWN INTO BITES AND CHUNKS
THAT WE CAN ALL UNDERSTAND, I
RISE TODAY AS A FORMER CHAIR OF
HEALTH, AND THIS HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
WORKING ON, AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN
AROUND, THIS HAS BEEN A LONG
STANDING ISSUE. AND, AND JUST TO
SAY TO MEMBERS, WHEN, WHEN, WHEN
TRAGEDIES STRIKE, OFTENTIMES WE
RUSH TO WRITE LEGISLATION THAT
WE THINK IS GOING TO FIX IT IN
THE MOMENT AND THEN DON'T OFTEN
REALIZE THAT THINGS TAKE TIME
AND PROCESSES. AND WE ARE A VERY
BIG STATE WITH A LOT OF VERY
DIFFERENT ISSUES, IT'S ANALOGOUS
TO AN ISSUE I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
IN MY DISTRICT. IT JUST FINALLY
GOT IT DONE. AFTER KATRINA. WE
PASSED A LOT OF THINGS ABOUT
LEVEES AND LEVEES SAFELY, BUT AT
THE SAME TIME, PEOPLE KEPT
DEVELOPING AND BUILDING, AND
THEN WE WERE NOT GOING TO HAVE
ANY COVERAGE FOR THEM. SO YOU
HAD TO BRING IT BACK AND SAY,
WHAT CAN WE DO THAT MAKES SENSE?
THAT KEEPS PEOPLE SAFE?
ACKNOWLEDGES, THE, THE REGIONAL
ISSUES AND ARE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD IN A, IN A WAY, I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR REALLY
COMING ON AND TACKLING THIS
PROBLEM AND STANDING WITH ALL OF
US WHO WHO REPRESENT SOUTHERN
CAL OR CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. AND
THE MORE RURAL AREAS, AND REALLY
BE ABLE TO A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH USING THE NEW AGENCIES
WE HAVE AT OUR DISPOSAL, LIKE
HCAI, TO REALLY DO REGIONAL
PLANNING, TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY FOR PEOPLE, LOCAL
OFFICIALS, AND ALLOW OUR, OUR,
OUR, THE SERVICES TO STILL BE
PROVIDED IN ESPECIALLY AREAS
WHERE SCARCITY IS A REAL DEAL. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER
. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY WITH SOME RELUCTANCE.
THE. WE ENACTED THIS REQUIREMENT
FOR SEISMIC SAFETY ON
EARTHQUAKES BECAUSE WE ARE IN A
STATE THAT IS HIGHLY EARTHQUAKE
PRONE IN MY LET ME USE BAY AREA,
THE BAY AREA, AND THIS IS BY THE
USGS AND BY, ALL THE DIFFERENT
SEISMOLOGISTS INDICATE THAT
THERE IS A 663% CHANCE OF A 6.7
MAGNITUDE EARTHQUAKE OR GREATER
IN THE BAY AREA BEFORE 2036, AND
NOTE THE DEADLINE ON THIS BILL
IS 2038 AND JUST THE HAYWARD
FAULT IN MY DISTRICT HAS A
LITTLE LOWER CHANCE BEFORE 2036.
BUT STILL, THE MAGNITUDE
EARTHQUAKE IS 6.7 OR GREATER,
AND WE KNOW THAT THE HOSPITALS
THAT NEED SEISMIC UPGRADE ARE
ALL ONES THAT COULD NOT OR NOT
LIKELY BE ABLE TO SURVIVE OR
FUNCTION WITH THAT MAGNITUDE OF
EARTHQUAKE. AND SOME WE HAVE
SOME OF OUR AND I WON'T GO IN
NAME NAMES, SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
SAY ONE HEALTH ENTITY IS BETTER
THAN OTHERS, BUT WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF HOSPITAL OPERATORS
THAT HAVE MET OUR SEISMIC
REQUIREMENTS, BUT WE HAVE OTHERS
THAT HAVE NOT AND HAVE DRAGGED
THEIR FEET. AND THERE'S SOME ONE
IN BERKELEY IN PARTICULAR THAT
HAS PUT ITS ANYBODY WHO GOES TO
THAT HOSPITAL IS AT RISK BECAUSE
IT HAS NOT DONE THIS SEISMIC
UPGRADE, AND HAS BEEN CLEAR THAT
THEY DO NOT WANT TO FOR YEARS,
AND YET THEY'RE STILL OPEN AND
OPERATING. NOW OF COURSE, WE
DON'T WANT THEM CLOSED BECAUSE
WE HAVE A HOSPITAL SHORTAGE, BUT
WE NEED THESE UPGRADES BECAUSE
WE NEED TO BE SAFE. YES, WE NEED
HOSPITALS. YES WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE, BUT A HOSPITAL DOESN'T
DO YOU A LOT OF GOOD, IF IT
WILL, IF YOU AND EVERYBODY IN IT
CAN BE SERIOUSLY HARMED IN AN
EARTHQUAKE AND THEN IN AN
EARTHQUAKE, IT'S NOT FUNCTIONAL
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INJURED IN THESE KIND OF HIGH
MAGNITUDE EARTHQUAKES. SO I LOOK
TO THE AUTHOR TO MAKE AN
IMPROVEMENTS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN AND I
KNOW THIS IS YOUR INTENT TO GET
THE SEISMIC SAFETY WE NEED AND
TO HOLD THESE HOSPITALS TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THEY NEED,
BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT FOR ALL
OF OUR SAFETY, AND WITH THAT, I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. HE'S READY. YES.
SENATOR LAIRD, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR. PRESIDENT, THERE WAS A
TIME WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY
COUNCIL THAT OUR CHIEF BUILDING
INSPECTOR CAME TO US AND SAID,
THERE ARE AN AMAZING NUMBER OF
BUILDINGS IN THE DOWNTOWN THAT
ARE NOT SEISMICALLY SAFE. AND I
SORT OF THINK YOU SHOULD
CONSIDER RED TAGGING THEM RIGHT
NOW. AND WE HAD A STATE MANDATE
THAT SAID THAT WITHIN TWO YEARS
WE HAD TO DO A COMPLETE
INVENTORY OF THE BUILDINGS
DOWNTOWN. AND SO WE DID IT. AND
IT WAS SET FOR A TUESDAY COUNCIL
MEETING. AND WHAT HAPPENED
BEFORE WE COULD GET TO THE
TUESDAY COUNCIL MEETING, WE HAD
A 7.1 EARTHQUAKE. AND THAT STUDY
WAS A PERFECT INDEX OF WHAT WAS
NOT SAFE IN THE DOWNTOWN. IN
FACT, PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN SOME
OF THE BUILDINGS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED AS NOT BEING SAFE.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT AND I
KNOW THE AUTHOR AND I WORKED TO
SAVE WATSONVILLE HOSPITAL, AND
ONE OF THE REASONS WE HAD TO
SAVE IT IS THAT VERY EARTHQUAKE
MADE IT UNINHABITABLE. AND THEY
HAD TO FIND A NEW LOCATION WHICH
SET THEM BACK ECONOMICALLY OVER
TIME IN THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY. SO I KNOW THERE'S
SOME OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND
THE OPPOSITION IS FROM FRIENDS
OF MINE. AND MY MESSAGE IS JUST
THE CLOCK IS TICKING. SOME OF
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE OPPOSED, THE
BILL SAID, WE WANT A
CONVERSATION. SO MY MESSAGE HERE
IS, IS THAT CONVERSATION HAS TO
HAPPEN. THIS IS NOT A TIME TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH NO END.
AND THE AUTHOR HAS OFFERED THE
PERFECT VEHICLE FOR IT. AND SO
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. BUT WE HAVE TO GET
TO THE END. THERE ARE HOSPITALS
THAT ARE IN THE RED THAT DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY TO UPGRADE. THERE
ARE. I WAS ASKED TO THE SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY'S POINT AFTER WE
HAD THE EARTHQUAKE, THE MEDIA
AND THE BAY AREA DID A MOCK
EXERCISE OF IF THERE WAS A
EARTHQUAKE ON THE HAYWARD FAULT.
AT 841 MORNING, I WENT AND
PLAYED THE MAYOR, AND THERE WERE
ALL THESE MEETINGS, EMERGENCY
PEOPLE. AND THEY WHEN THEY DID
THE SCENARIO, ONE OF THE THINGS
WAS, IS MOST OF THE HOSPITALS
NEAR THE EARTHQUAKE FAULT WOULD
BE UNINHABITABLE, WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO TAKE PEOPLE FROM THAT
EARTHQUAKE. SO WE CAN'T KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOREVER. WE
HAVE TO HAVE A SOLUTION. AND I
AND FOR WHATEVER REASON, THE
AUTHOR MAY NEED TO HAVE HER HEAD
EXAMINED BECAUSE SHE HAS TAKEN
THIS ON. BUT WE HAVE TO BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER AND GET TO THE
END. THIS OFFERS US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT. AND THAT'S
WHY I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WAHAB. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO SEEM TO BE
BOTHERED, SENATOR WAHAB. THANK
YOU. YEAH YOU KNOW, SO I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS EFFORT. I THINK
SENATOR CABALLERO HAS, OF
COURSE, TAKEN THIS ON, AND IT'S
A COMPLICATED ISSUE. WE WANT TO
OBVIOUSLY ENSURE THAT THE
HOSPITALS ARE UP TO STANDARD,
ESPECIALLY AS I REPRESENT THE
CITY OF HAYWARD. WITH THE
HAYWARD FAULT THAT WE HAVE
MENTIONED A NUMBER OF TIMES, AND
IN MY CITY, WE HAVE A HOSPITAL
CALLED SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL. IT
IS A SAFETY NET HOSPITAL. IT
LARGELY SERVES MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS, UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS, PEOPLE OF COLOR,
AND PEOPLE OF LOWER INCOME
BACKGROUNDS, THIS HOSPITAL HAS
ALREADY HIGHLIGHTED AND WAS ONE
OF THE BENEFICIARIES OF THE
DISTRESSED LOAN THAT WERE GIVEN
OUT ROUGHLY A YEAR AGO AND AT
THE SAME TIME, THERE IS A SISTER
BILL THAT MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
ASSEMBLY IS CARRYING TO SUPPORT
THAT HOSPITAL EVEN FURTHER, AS
IT'S IN NEGOTIATIONS TO GET
PURCHASED. THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT, AGAIN, SEISMIC SAFETY,
BUT THEN ALSO JUST THE SAFETY
NET, HOSPITALS THAT SERVE OUR
MOST VULNERABLE TODAY, RIGHT
NOW, IF THEY ARE STRUGGLING
ALREADY, ESPECIALLY WITH COVID
AND A THREE YEAR PERIOD WHERE A
LOT OF THINGS WERE MORE FOCUSED
ON SERVING THE COMMUNITY,
EXTENDING THIS TEMPORARILY OR
SHORTLY, I SHOULD SAY, IS
SUFFICIENT. SO AGAIN, I
RESPECTFULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I ASK THAT YOU ALL, YOU KNOW,
SUPPORT THE BILL. AND I TRUST
THAT THE GOOD SENATOR WILL BE
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS ANY FUTURE CONCERNS AS
IT MOVES THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND I ALSO RISE, AND
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
HER WORK ON THIS. WE HAD A VERY
ROBUST CONVERSATION IN HEALTH
COMMITTEE, AND, YOU KNOW, I HAVE
A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL BECAUSE EVERY MINUTE WE,
WE, WE WAIT TO THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SANTA CRUZ POINT, WE RISK
POTENTIALLY LOSING MORE LIFE,
WHENEVER THE MOMENT STRIKES. AND
IN ANY LOSS IS GOING TO BE TOO
GREAT BECAUSE WE'VE WAITED OVER
30 YEARS, TO NOW HAVE YET
ANOTHER EXTENSION FOR WHAT WILL
BE ANOTHER EIGHT YEARS, MY MAIN
CONCERN IS THAT WE HAVE NOT PUT
ANY ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS ON
THIS EIGHT YEARS ALONG EACH BENT
BENCH MARK. THERE IS NO REAL
SKIN IN THE GAME. THAT GIVES US
AN INDICATION, FOR WHEN A
HOSPITAL DOESN'T MEET, THE
BENCHMARK AND THE DEADLINE IN
WAYS TO INCENTIVIZE THOSE
HOSPITALS TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
THE OTHER THING I POINTED OUT IS
THAT IT WAS MENTIONED BY THE
AUTHOR THAT THERE WERE SOME
HOSPITALS THAT WERE READY TO
TAKE ACTION AND TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE RETROFIT. HOWEVER WE
DIDN'T PUT IN A MECHANISM TO
GUARANTEE THAT THEY ACTUALLY, IN
FACT, MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
RETROFIT. THEY IN FACT, NOW CAN
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BACKSLIDE BACK INTO THIS
EXTENSION PROCESS AND AGAIN, WE
IT WILL REMAIN TO BE SEEN
WHETHER OR NOT, THESE
COMMITMENTS WILL BE MET FOR
WORKERS, FOR PATIENTS, FOR
OTHERS. I HAVE HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS. AND WITH THAT, I, AM,
GOING TO LAY OFF OF THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR ROTH.
YOU KNOW, OF COURSE, THE
ALTERNATIVE TO THIS BILL IS, THE
NEXT TIME A HOSPITAL IN ONE OF
YOUR DISTRICTS COMES IN FOR AN
EXTENSION. A COMMITTEE EITHER
DENIES IT AND LEAVES THE
HOSPITAL TO ITS OWN DEVICES, OR
WE BRING TO THE FLOOR, AND YOU
ALL GET TO DECIDE WHETHER YOU
WANT TO GRANT THE EXTENSION. AND
THEN YOU ARE PUT TO THE TEST,
AND YOU CAN DENY THE EXTENSION
FOR THE HOSPITAL IN YOUR
DISTRICTS. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE LIST OF
OPPONENTS ON THIS BILL, I'M A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTED THAT SOME OF
THEM DIDN'T MODIFY THEIR
OPPOSITION BECAUSE THIS AUTHOR
HAS CONVENED SEVERAL MEETINGS
WITH VIRTUALLY EVERY OPPONENT
LISTED ON THE BACK OF THE
ANALYSIS ON THIS BILL. AND I
KNOW BECAUSE I WAS THERE
PARTICIPATING WITH THE
OPPOSITION IN IN THE
CONVERSATIONS, AND THEY ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATED IN DISCUSSING
MODIFICATIONS TO THIS BILL, HOW
WE COULD MAKE IT WORK FOR THEM.
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT LABOR AND
WE SPOKE ABOUT THE THREE YEAR
EXTENSION THAT WAS INITIALLY
THAT'S INITIALLY PROVIDED IN
THIS BILL. AND WE DISCUSSED THE
FACT THAT SOME HOSPITALS,
PARTICULARLY THE LARGER ONES
WITH WITH ASSETS AND RESOURCES,
ARE PROBABLY CLOSE AND COULD
COMPLETE THEIR RENOVATIONS IN
MAYBE A YEAR. THE TASKING AS WE
LEFT THE LAST MEETING WAS LABOR
WAS GOING TO GET TOGETHER WITH
THE GOVERNMENT AGENCY AND WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THIS BILL AND
DETERMINE WE OUGHT TO KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE, BECAUSE THE HOSPITAL
CONSTRUCTION BUSINESS IS A
PRETTY SPECIFIC THING THAT
REQUIRES APPROVAL AT EVERY
PHASE. DETERMINE WHICH HOSPITALS
ARE THAT CLOSE, AND THEN MAKE A
LIST AND THOSE THAT ONLY NEEDED
ONE YEAR WOULD GET ONE YEAR.
THOSE THAT NEEDED TWO YEARS
WOULD GET TWO YEARS. AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHETHER THERE'S
ENFORCEMENT IN THIS BILL
BUSINESS, NO HOSPITAL GETS ANY
EXTENSION UNLESS A MASTER PLAN
FOR SEISMIC COMPLIANCE. SETTING
OUT GOALS, OBJECTIVES AND
MILESTONES IS SUBMITTED IN
ADVANCE AND WITHOUT THE MASTER
PLAN, I GUESS THEY'LL FIGURE IT
OUT. MAYBE MOBILE FIELD
HOSPITALS WE CAN RENT FROM THE
ARMY WHEN THEY DON'T MEET THE
DEADLINE, AND THEN IF YOU DO NOT
MEET YOUR MILESTONES, THERE'S NO
AUTOMATIC EIGHT YEAR EXTENSION.
IF YOU GET A THREE YEAR
EXTENSION BECAUSE THEY THINK
IT'S GOING TO TAKE YOU THREE
YEARS TO GET A LITTLE FURTHER
DOWN THE ROAD, YOU DIDN'T MEET
THE ONE OR THE TWO YEAR TEST.
THEN THE NEXT SET OF MILESTONES
YOU HAVE. MAYBE IT'S
CONSTRUCTION DESIGN OR THE
RETENTION OF A CONTRACTOR. IF
YOU DON'T MEET THAT, YOU GET NO
FURTHER EXTENSION. SO IF THAT'S
NOT AN ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM TO
MOVE HOSPITALS DOWN TO THE
FINISH LINE, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS BECAUSE A $100,000 FINE OR A
$300,000 FINE, OR A HALF $1
MILLION FINE IS NOT REALLY GOING
TO DO IT. SO THIS ARCHITECT
FEATURE IS DESIGNED TO MOVE
HOSPITALS DOWN TO THE LINE. AND
IF AT THE END OF THE DAY THEY
DON'T MEET IT, WE'LL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH HOW WE PROVIDE
HOSPITAL ESSENTIAL MEDICAL
SERVICES, HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IN SOME OF THESE AREAS WITHOUT A
HOSPITAL. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU. AND AFTER
A HEALTHY DISCUSSION AND ROBUST
DEBATE, SENATOR CABALLERO, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. I'M
GOING TO, THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FROM RIVERSIDE AND, AND SAY
THAT HE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO SET UP
MILESTONES AND I, LIKE HIM, ARE
VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT, THAT
THERE WEREN'T MODIFICATIONS IN
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD
AT TRYING TO BRING THEM IN,
BEING VERY SPECIFIC AND TAKING A
LOT OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS, LET
ME JUST SAY THAT IN REGARDS TO
THE STORY THAT MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM SANTA CRUZ RECOUNTED, WHAT
HAPPENED IS THAT STATE LAW
CHANGED BECAUSE OF THOSE
EARTHQUAKES AND BECAUSE OF THE
DEATH AND DESTRUCTION THAT
HAPPENED IN OUR OLD DOWNTOWNS
AND THE LAW THAT CHANGED
BASICALLY SAID THAT CITIES WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR TO FOR INSISTING
ON THE SEISMIC RETROFIT OF
BUILDINGS IN THEIR THEIR OLD
DOWNTOWNS. THEY WERE
UNREINFORCED MASONRY BUILDINGS.
AND SO THE FIRST STEP WAS A
REPORT, AND THE SECOND STEP WAS
NOW DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. WE
SPENT YEARS, AND I WANT TO SAY
YEARS GIVING THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TIME TO RETROFIT THE
DOWNTOWN. AT THE TIME, IT WAS
VERY DIFFICULT TO CLOSE
BUSINESSES IN A STRUGGLING
DOWNTOWN THAT LOOKED LIKE K
STREET, QUITE FRANKLY, WHERE
THERE WERE LOTS OF HOMELESS,
WHERE THERE WASN'T VERY, VERY
GREAT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AND
SO WHAT ENDED? WE ENDED UP DOING
IN OUR CITY IS WE WENT TO OUR
LOCAL BANKS BECAUSE WE HAD BEEN
DOING EXTENSIONS AND EXTENSIONS,
AND WE SAID, WE NEED YOU TO DO A
LOW INTEREST LOAN PROGRAM AND
THE CITY WILL STAND AS SECURITY
FOR LOANS TO SMALL BUSINESSES SO
THAT IF THEY COULDN'T PAY THE
DEBT, THAT THE CITY WOULD STEP
IN AND PAY, EVERY SINGLE
BUILDING GOT RETROFITTED. SO
THAT IT IS NOW SEISMICALLY SAFE.
THE CITY PAID OUT NO MONEY AND
THE BANK WAS THE HERO IN THE
STORY. SO SO LET ME BE VERY
CLEAR. THIS DOES NOT ANTICIPATE
ANY MONEY. BUT WHAT I KNOW IS
THAT WE'VE PUT LITTLE PIECES OF
MONEY TOGETHER. PART OF THE VAPE
TAX GOES TOWARDS HOSPITALS TO
HELP THEM PLAN, DO THEIR
PLANNING FOR RETROFITS. AND AT
SOME POINT WE'RE EITHER GOING TO
NEED A BOND OR WE'RE GOING TO
NEED SOME RESOURCES OUT OF OUR
BUDGET IN ORDER TO HELP. SOME OF
THESE HOSPITALS ARE THERE SOME
HOSPITALS THAT HAVE DRAGGED
THEIR FEET? ABSOLUTELY BUT
THAT'S GOING TO BECOME VERY
CLEAR WITH THE NEW AUTHORITY
THAT WE GIVE HCAI TO BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THEIR FINANCES AND TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY'RE DOING
THE RIGHT THING, I AGREE WITH MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM OAKLAND.
RELUCTANTLY, I'M VOTING ON THIS
AS WELL BECAUSE RELUCTANTLY I
DECIDED TO DO THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE GOT TO GET THIS DONE. AND IF
WE DON'T GET IT DONE NOW, THE
PROBLEM BECOMES WORSE AND YOU
WILL SEE HOSPITAL AFTER HOSPITAL
COME IN HERE ONE OFFS ASKING FOR
A RELIEF. AND I THINK WE NEED TO
DEAL WITH IT AS A, AS A, AS A
PLANNED AND ORGANIZED WAY AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING ALL
THE HOSPITALS RETROFITTED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE,
VOTE FOR DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 78, ALAN
ALVARADO GILL A ARCHULETA. ASHBY
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLY I DODD I DURAZZO I
EGGMAN I GLASER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE I HURTADO. I JONES I LAIRD
I LIMON I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I
MIN I NEWMAN, I NGUYEN I NILO I
OCHOA I PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I CIERTO I SKINNER
I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS STERN I UMMER
I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA
MCGUIRE I SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. ICE
37. NO ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM 50 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. HE'S PREPARED THE
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1287 BY SENATOR GLAZER. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS ON THIS BILL, I WANT TO
START WITH THE BASICS. AND IT'S
CONTAINED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
EACH EACH MEMBER HAS BEEN GIVEN.
THE BILL DOES FOUR THINGS. IT
REQUIRES THE TRUSTEES OF THE
STATE UNIVERSITIES, THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ADOPT AND
ENFORCE POLICIES IN INSTITUTION
BASED STUDENT CODES OF CONDUCT
THAT PROHIBIT VIOLENCE,
HARASSMENT, INTIMIDATION, AND
DISCRIMINATION. THÀNH THAT
INTERFERE THROUGH FORCE OR
INTIMIDATION WITH FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS, INCLUDING
CALLING FOR GENOCIDE. THE SECOND
THING IT DOES IS THAT THEY
MAINTAIN AND ENFORCE REASONABLE
TIME, PLACE AND MANNER
RESTRICTIONS. THREE THAT THEY
DEVELOP MANDATORY TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS, AND FOUR,
THEY REQUIRE THAT EACH STUDENT
WHO SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR
OBLIGATION TO COMPLY WITH THAT
CODE OF CONDUCT. SO THIS BILL,
SENATE BILL 1287, AFFIRMS THE
ROLE THAT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES MUST
TAKE TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS CAN
EXERCISE THEIR FREE SPEECH
RIGHTS AND EXCHANGE VIEWS
RESPECTFULLY. IN RECENT MONTHS
AND WEEKS, WE'VE WITNESSED AN
ALARMING TREND OF ESCALATING
HARASSMENT, INTIMIDATION AND
VIOLENCE TARGETED AT
MARGINALIZED GROUPS ON OUR
CAMPUSES. THIS OBVIOUSLY
THREATENS THE SAFETY AND
WELL-BEING OF OUR STUDENTS, OUR
FACULTY, AND OUR STAFF, AND IT
THREATENS THE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT, AND IT THREATENS
THE FREE EXCHANGE OF IDEAS. OUR
COLLEGES HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROMOTE FREE SPEECH WHILE
PREVENTING DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT. BUT WHERE DOES FREE
SPEECH CROSS THE LINE INTO
SPEECH? THAT IS NOT PROTECTED?
NOW WE HAVE SPECIFIED THAT
SPEECH THAT CALLS FOR THE
DESTRUCTION OF A GROUP IN WHOLE
OR IN PART BASED ON NATIONALITY,
ETHNICITY, RACE OR RELIGION
CROSSES THE LINE. FREE SPEECH IS
ALSO DOES NOT EXTEND TO CALLS
FOR GENOCIDE, BUT ONLY IF THE
SPEAKER SUBJECTIVELY INTENDS FOR
HIS OR HER SPEECH TO BE
UNDERSTOOD THAT WAY, AND IF THE
SPEECH WOULD LEAD TO AN
OBJECTIVE OBSERVER TO THE SAME
CONCLUSIONS AS THE SUPREME COURT
HAS SAID, FREE SPEECH PROVIDES
STRONG PROTECTION AGAINST THE
ARBITRARY OR OVERBROAD
APPLICATION OF LAWS AFFECTING
SPEECH. WE WORKED IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THANKS TO
CHAIR UMBERG TO ADDRESS FIRST
AMENDMENT SCRUTINY, ESPECIALLY
FOR PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES WHOSE
STUDENT CONDUCT CODE INCLUDES
SUCH PROVISIONS, ENSURING THAT
THEY'RE FIRMLY ROOTED IN
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES. NOW,
IN ADDITION, CASE LAW HAS
AFFIRMED THAT COLLEGES NEED NOT
TOLERATE SPEECH THAT IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THEIR BASIC
EDUCATIONAL MISSION. THIS BILL
ALIGNS WITH THIS RESPONSIBILITY
BY REQUIRING CAMPUSES TO
INSTITUTE POLICIES THAT
EXPLICITLY PROHIBIT VIOLENCE,
HARASS, INTIMIDATION, AND
DISCRIMINATION, INCLUDING CALLS
FOR GENOCIDE. SB 1287 ALSO
REQUIRES UNIVERSITIES TO DEVELOP
PROGRAMS TO EDUCATE STUDENTS ON
HOW TO EXCHANGE VIEWS
RESPECTFULLY. EVEN WHEN WE'RE
DEALING WITH DIVISIVE ISSUES,
ALL STUDENT VOICES HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BE HEARD. NONE SHOULD
BE SILENCED. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THE SAFETY OF STUDENTS AND THE
SAFEGUARDING OF THEIR FREE
SPEECH RIGHTS. I BELIEVE THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HELP RESTORE AN
ENVIRONMENT OF CIVIL DISCOURSE
ON OUR CAMPUSES, SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL DESPERATELY WANT. FOR
THOSE REASONS, I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL 1287.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR. PRESIDENT. I
RISE TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB 1287, AND I DO SO AS CO-CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS. SB 1287 IS A JEWISH
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL, AND I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM ORINDA
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE HAS BEEN AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
MISINFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES, AT TIMES FALSELY
CLAIMING THAT IT WILL SOMEHOW
STOP PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE TO
PROTEST WHEN IT WILL DO NO SUCH
THING. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PROTECTING FREE SPEECH AND
DIVERSITY OF VIEWPOINTS ON OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. IT'S ABOUT
ALLOWING THESE VARIOUS
PERSPECTIVES TO FLOURISH WITHOUT
SILENCING PEOPLE BECAUSE OF WHO
THEY ARE. SO IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT STUDENTS FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE BE FREE AND ABLE TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES IN THEIR BELIEFS
WITHOUT FEAR OF HARASSMENT,
BULLYING, AND INTIMIDATION. AND
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW.
COLLEAGUES, THIS DOES NOT IN ANY
WAY MEAN THAT STUDENTS CAN'T
PROTEST. OF COURSE, THEY WILL
OBVIOUSLY BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
PROTEST. IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THEY CAN'T DISAGREE. WE WANT
THEM TO BE ABLE TO DISAGREE. IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT STUDENTS WILL
BE SOMEHOW PROHIBITED FROM
SAYING THINGS THAT MAKE PEOPLE
FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE. THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. THIS BILL
FOSTERS FREE SPEECH, BUT IT'S
FREE SPEECH BY VARIOUS PEOPLE.
AND NOT JUST FREE SPEECH FOR ME,
BUT NOT FOR THEE, WHICH IS WHAT
IS HAPPENING AT TIMES RIGHT NOW.
AND LET'S BE CLEAR, THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BEING MADE TO
FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE AND BEING
COERCED, BULLIED AND INTIMIDATED
AND HARASSED INTO SILENCE. WHEN
I HAVE MORE THAN ONE STUDENT ON
CAMPUSES TELL ME I NO LONGER
WEAR A KIPPAH OR STAR OF DAVID
ON CAMPUS BECAUSE I WILL GET
HARASSED. THAT IS NOT IT.
UNDERMINING FREE SPEECH THAT IS
PROMOTING PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO
EXPRESS WHO THEY ARE, WHETHER
THEY ARE JEWISH, WHETHER THEY
ARE MUSLIM, WHETHER THEY ARE
TRANS PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO
EXPRESS WHO THEY ARE WITHOUT
FEAR OF BEING HARASSED AND
INTIMIDATED. I WANT TO BE CLEAR,
THE INTIMIDATION AND BULLYING WE
ARE SEEING ON OUR CAMPUSES RIGHT
NOW, IT'S NOT HAPPENING
EVERYWHERE. IT'S NOT HAPPENING
ALL THE TIME. AND MOST PEOPLE
ARE NOT ENGAGING IN THAT
BEHAVIOR. BUT SOME ARE. AND IT'S
CREATED AN ATMOSPHERE OF FEAR
AND THAT IS THE OPPOSITE OF FREE
SPEECH, I CALL IT. I WANT TO
JUST NAME THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM. MUCH OF THE CURRENT MOMENT
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING IN SOME
OF THESE CHALLENGES IS FUELED BY
THE OCTOBER SEVENTH HAMAS
MASSACRE AND MASS RAPE IN
ISRAEL, AND THE RESULTING
HORRIFIC WAR, BOTH OF WHICH HAVE
CLAIMED AN UNCONSCIONABLE NUMBER
OF INNOCENT CIVILIAN LIVES. IT
IS MY SINCERE HOPE AND THE HOPE
I KNOW OF MANY, MANY, MANY JEWS
THAT THIS WAR WILL END QUICKLY,
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE, THAT THE
HOSTAGES WILL COME HOME AND THAT
HAMAS WILL NO LONGER GOVERN
GAZA. BUT WE ARE NOT A BODY THIS
AMAZING SENATE WITH CONTROL OVER
FOREIGN CONFLICTS. WHAT WE CAN
DO IS MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE SAFE AT HOME
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS BILL WILL HELP TO DO
THAT. I WANT TO JUST NAME SOME
OF THE INCIDENTS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED NOT JUST SINCE OCTOBER
SEVENTH, BUT BEFORE, AND NOT
ONLY RELATING TO JEWS, BECAUSE
THIS BILL IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY. THIS IS ABOUT
EVERYONE AT UC SANTA BARBARA.
BACK IN FEBRUARY, THE
MULTICULTURAL STUDENT CENTER WAS
PLASTERED WITH POSTERS SAYING
ZIONISTS WERE NOT WELCOME. THAT
DESCRIBES NEARLY 90% OF JEWS.
ZIONISTS MEANS THAT YOU BELIEVE
THAT ISRAEL IS THE JEWISH
HOMELAND. THESE POSTERS EVEN
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED A
PARTICULAR JEWISH STUDENT, THE
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT, BY
SAYING, QUOTE, YOU CAN RUN, BUT
YOU CAN'T HIDE, END QUOTE, THAT
IS NOT FREE SPEECH. THAT IS
INTIMIDATION AND BULLYING.
SHORTLY AFTERWARDS, ALSO AT UC
SANTA BARBARA, A DORM ROOM OF A
JEWISH STUDENT WITH A MEZUZAH
AFFIXED TO IT. I HAVE A MEZUZAH
AT MY HOME, AS DO MANY JEWS, WAS
GRAFFITIED WITH ZIONISTS NOT
WELCOME AND AN ARROW POINTING AT
THE MEZUZAH. SOMETIMES PEOPLE
TELL ON THEMSELVES, LIKE WHEN
THEY'RE USING THE WORD ZIONIST
AND THEY'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
JEWS AT UC BERKELEY, A LETTER
WAS SUBMITTED DEMANDING THAT A
PROMINENT ENVIRONMENTALIST
SUBMITTED BY STUDENTS, THAT A
PROMINENT ENVIRONMENTALIST AND A
MEMBER OF THE OAKLAND CITY
COUNCIL, BE DISINVITED TO SPEAK
IN A CLASS ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES BECAUSE HE IS JEWISH AND
IDENTIFIES AS A ZIONIST. THIS IS
SOMEONE WHO VOTED FOR A CEASE
FIRE RESOLUTION, BUT THAT WASN'T
GOOD ENOUGH. THE LETTER CITED
HIS AFFILIATION WITH JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS AS UNFORTUNATELY,
UC BERKELEY ALLOWED THAT DEMAND
TO BE MET AT SAN JOSE STATE, A
PROFESSOR, A PROFESSOR VISITING
FROM CSU LONG BEACH WAS
PROTESTED. SO HEAVILY A JEWISH
PROFESSOR THAT HE WAS UNABLE TO
FINISH HIS LECTURE ON A TWO
STATE SOLUTION, LITERALLY A
LECTURE ON FINDING PEACE. AND
THAT WAS SHUT DOWN IN 2019 AT UC
BERKELEY, A VIDEO WENT VIRAL OF
A RACIST, SEXIST, HOMOPHOBIC
RANT TARGETING BLACK STUDENTS,
CLAIMING THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE
RIGHTS. AT UC BERKELEY EARLIER
THIS YEAR, TWO JEWISH STUDENTS
HAD TO SEEK MEDICAL ATTENTION
AFTER ONE WAS CHOKED AND ANOTHER
WAS INJURED. AS A DOOR WAS
BROKEN OPEN BECAUSE THEY WERE
HOSTING A TALK BY AN ISRAELI
SPEAKER. OTHER STUDENTS AT THE
SAME EVENT WERE CALLED AND WERE
SPAT ON. WE SAW AT UCLA
COUNTER-PROTESTERS ATTEMPTING TO
PROVOKE PRO-PALESTINIAN
DEMONSTRATORS BY PLAYING A
PRISON ASSOCIATED MUSIC AND
TAUNTING THEM WITH EPITHETS AT
USC, A PRIVATE UNIVERSITY, THE
ADMINISTRATION CANCELED THEIR
VALEDICTORIAN DUE TO UNSPECIFIED
SECURITY CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT WAS
BEING POSTED ONLINE, AND THEY
CANCELED HER AND SAID SHE
COULDN'T SPEAK LAST YEAR, UC
SANTA CRUZ AT UC SANTA CRUZ, A
GROUP OF STUDENTS CELEBRATED
HITLER'S BIRTHDAY. AND THAT'S
THE SAME WEEK FLIERS WERE
DISTRIBUTED WITH ANTI LGBTQ AND
ANTI-SEMITIC CONSPIRACY
THEORIES. I WILL STOP THERE, BUT
I COULD GO ON FOR PAGES AND
PAGES WITH SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING ON CAMPUS,
NOT JUST TO JEWS, BUT TO OTHERS
THAT OUR COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO PUT A STOP
TO. I WANT TO JUST SAY ONE MAKE
ONE LAST POINT, COLLEAGUES. AND
I WAS NOT EVER PLANNING TO HAVE
TO MAKE THESE REMARKS ABOUT A
SPECIFIC ORGANIZATION ON THE
FLOOR OF THE SENATE, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, MORE THAN ONE OF
YOU HAVE COME UP TO ME CONFUSED
ABOUT A PURPORTED DIVISION
WITHIN THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
ABOUT THIS BILL AND ALSO ABOUT
THE HOLOCAUST EDUCATION BILL BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES.
SPECIFICALLY, PEOPLE WONDER WHY
AN ORGANIZATION CALLED JEWISH
VOICE FOR PEACE, JVP, HAS SOME
REALLY NICE SOUNDING WORDS IN
ITS NAME JEWISH VOICE. EVERYONE
LOVES A VOICE. PEACE. EVERYONE
WANTS PEACE. WHY? WHY IS A
JEWISH COMMUNITY GROUP OPPOSING
A BILL LIKE THIS? OR LIKE A
HOLOCAUST EDUCATION BILL? JVP
HAS BEEN AGGRESSIVELY LOBBYING
AGAINST THESE BILLS. JVP FALSELY
CLAIMS TO REPRESENT MAINSTREAM
VIEWPOINTS IN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY. IT DOES NO SUCH
THING. RATHER IT HOLDS WHAT CAN
ONLY BE DESCRIBED AS FRINGE
VIEWPOINTS WITHIN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY. LOBBYING AGAINST
HOLOCAUST EDUCATION AND CLAIMING
THAT YOU ARE SPEAKING FOR THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY. A RECENT
EXPOSÉ ON JVP IS ENTITLED,
QUOTE, NOT SO JEWISH, NOT FOR
PEACE. INDEED AND THIS IS JUST
STILL BLOWS MY MIND WHEN JVP
SENT REPRESENTATIVES TO MY
OFFICE TO LOBBY MY STAFF AGAINST
THE HOLOCAUST EDUCATION BILL, IT
TURNS OUT THAT OF THE PEOPLE
THEY SENT, ZERO WERE JEWISH. SO
YOU HAVE NON-JEWS CLAIMING TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY AGAINST A HOLOCAUST
EDUCATION BILL. THAT IS
OUTRAGEOUS. AND WE WOULD NOT PUT
UP WITH THAT FOR ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY. AND YET THAT IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING, AS FAR AS I
CAN TELL. JEWISH VOICE FOR PEACE
JVP HAS TWO PRIMARY MISSIONS.
ONE IS TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
COMPLETE ELIMINATION OF THE
STATE OF ISRAEL AS A JEWISH
HOMELAND. IN OTHER WORDS, FOR
ISRAEL TO NO LONGER EXIST. HOME
TO 7 MILLION JEWS AND SECOND TO
REPEATEDLY AND PERSISTENTLY OVER
TIME GIVE COVER TO TOKENISTIC
COVER TO PEOPLE WHO MAKE
ANTI-SEMITIC STATEMENTS, WHETHER
IN THE ARAB WORLD OR IN THIS
COUNTRY. ON MANY OCCASIONS, JVP
HAS DEFENDED ANTI-SEMITES AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMMITTED
VIOLENCE AGAINST JEWS. IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS THAT THIS GROUP PUTS
THE WORD JEWISH IN ITS NAME AND
YET INCLUDES MANY NON-JEWS WHO
PURPORT TO SPEAK FOR JEWS, AND
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THE POSITIONS
THAT THIS GROUP PURPORTS TO TAKE
ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO CONFUSE
PEOPLE, AND IT HAS TO STOP. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR, THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY, LIKE MANY
COMMUNITIES, HOLDS DIVERSE VIEWS
ON A LOT OF ISSUES. IF YOU'VE
EVER ATTENDED A PASSOVER DINNER
OR ANY DINNER AT MY HOME, YOU
WILL KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
ROBUST CONVERSATIONS, AND THAT
INCLUDES THE WAR ON GAZA. THERE
ARE MANY, MANY, MANY DIVERSE
VIEWPOINTS WITHIN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY ABOUT THE WAR, AND I
RESPECT THAT. AND THAT IS A
HEALTHY AND A GOOD THING. BUT
JVP AND THESE AND THESE EXTREME
POSITIONS THAT IT TAKES THAT
CONFUSE PEOPLE, THAT THAT
CROSSES THE LINE FOR ME
PERSONALLY AND I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS THAT ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS ISSUE RAISED BY
THE BILL IS VERY PERSONAL TO ME
AND MY LIFE. I HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED OVER 20 TIMES IN MY
LIFE SINCE I WAS 19 YEARS OLD. I
WALKED HUNDREDS OF PICKET LINES.
I'VE MARCHED AS SHORT AS THREE
BLOCKS TO AS LONG AS THREE DAYS.
OVER 50 YEARS AGO AT SAINT
MARY'S COLLEGE, I AND OTHER
STUDENTS TOOK OVER THE CHAPEL
AND WE STAYED THERE WITH THE
ISSUES THAT WERE VERY IMPORTANT
TO US AS LATINO AND BLACK
STUDENTS. THERE WERE NO VIOLENT
ACTIONS TAKEN AGAINST US, AND
I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO THAT FOR
THAT. I'M GRATEFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR TREATING OUR
RIGHT TO PROTEST SO RESPECTFULLY
. AND IT REMINDS ME ALSO OF WHAT
I'VE READ OF THE STUDENT
MOVEMENT AND OTHER CAUSES. THE
STUDENTS THAT PLAYED SUCH A
CRITICAL ROLE IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT, THE STUDENTS
THAT HAVE PLAYED SUCH A CRITICAL
ROLE IN THE ANTIWAR MOVEMENT,
STUDENTS HAVE PLAYED SUCH A
CRITICAL ROLE IN THE BLACK AND
LATINO CHICANO MOVEMENT.
STUDENTS HAVE PLAYED A VERY
EXTRAORDINARY ROLE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND PROBABLY THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD, IN REMINDING US OF
WHAT WE ARE ALL ABOUT AND WHAT
WE SHOULD STAND FOR. I TREASURE
THE RIGHT TO PROTEST, AND SO DO
THE HOUSEKEEPERS AND THE
IMMIGRANTS AND STUDENTS AND
TRUCK DRIVERS AND WOMEN AND
LGBTQ AND FARM WORKERS WHO ALL
PARTICIPATED IN THOSE ACTIONS.
MY HUSBAND TOLD ME STORIES OF
HOW CESAR CHAVEZ WAS
CONTINUOUSLY STOPPED FROM
MARCHING AND PICKETING IN THE
FIELDS BY THE SHERIFFS, DOING
THE WORK OF THE GROWERS. THEY
WOULD DEMAND PERMITS TO DO A
MARCH AND A RALLY AT A PUBLIC
PARK, A TACTIC TO STOP THEIR
ACTIONS. THEY WERE JAILED FOR
NOT HAVING A PERMIT. AS DOCTOR
KING SAID MANY TIMES WE MUST
PROTEST FOR THE RIGHT TO PROTEST
. ONCE I WAS EXTREMELY UPSET
WITH THE ACLU BECAUSE THEY HAD
LITIGATED THE RIGHT OF THE KKK
AND THE TO HAVE A MARCH AND TO
HAVE A RALLY, AND I JUST
COULDN'T UNDERSTAND HOW COULD
THEY DO THAT? THAT WAS SO WRONG.
HOW COULD THEY STAND UP ON THE
SIDE OF CLEAR RACISM AND CLEAR
VIOLATION? YES, BUT IT'S THE
CONSTITUTION, THÀNH. IT'S WHAT
THIS NATION. WHAT WE'RE SO PROUD
OF IN THIS NATION TODAY WE ARE
DEBATING ON THE PARAMETERS OF
THE CONSTITUTION, OUR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS WHICH MAKE
THIS NATION SO GREAT. AND WHILE
ALL OF THIS IS TAKING PLACE IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE WORLD, WE
NEED TO MAKE CLEAR THAT VIOLENCE
IS COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE. LAST
YEAR I INTRODUCED AND WITH YOUR
SUPPORT, WE PASSED A RESOLUTION
ON NONVIOLENCE. MR. PRESIDENT,
IF I COULD READ PERMISSION
GRANTED. THANK YOU. AND PART OF
IT SAYS, WHEREAS IT IS VITAL TO
THE FUTURE AND WELL-BEING OF OUR
STATE AND NATION, TO INSPIRE
PEOPLE AND STUDENTS TO THINK,
ACT AND DREAM IN THE PURSUIT OF
THE GREATER GOOD THROUGH
NONVIOLENCE, AND TO DEVELOP THE
LANGUAGE AND THE STRUCTURE
NECESSARY TO STRENGTHEN THE
CONNECTION OF ALL PEOPLE AND TO
FORTIFY THE FOUNDATION OF OUR
DEMOCRACY. AND WHEREAS ONE OF
THE LESSONS OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT IS THAT ABSENT A
FRAMEWORK FOR PEACEFUL ASSEMBLY
TO EXPRESS DISCORD AND
DISCONTENT, THAT HATRED
INEVITABLY LEADS TO VIOLENCE.
BOTH CESAR CHAVEZ AND DOCTOR
KING WERE CRITICAL OF VIOLENCE,
WHETHER IT WAS USED BY THEIR
ENEMIES OR USED BY THEIR OWN
SUPPORTERS. IN FACT, CESAR
CHAVEZ, ONE OF HIS VERY LONG
FASTS OF MANY, MANY DAYS WAS
BECAUSE SUPPORTERS AND ACTIVISTS
AND THE FARM WORKERS MOVEMENT
AND FARM WORKERS THEMSELVES WERE
RESPONDING WITH VIOLENCE TO THE
VIOLENCE ON THEM. AND HE SAID,
NO MATTER WHAT, IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE. I TRULY BELIEVE IN
THOSE PRINCIPLES. I'M AFRAID
THAT I BELIEVE THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL FALLS SHORT OF
FULFILLING OUR FIRST AMENDMENT
PROTECTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR MANN. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE AS A
COAUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE ÁP LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS, AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORINDA AND THE
JEWISH CAUCUS FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD, THESE ARE
OBVIOUSLY TRYING TIMES FOR ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND FOR THOSE
OF US WHO REPRESENT COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, I REPRESENT UC IRVINE
AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. THIS IS A
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT TIME, AND
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN IN THE NEWS
JUST LAST WEEK, THE PROTESTS AT
UC IRVINE REACHED AHEAD. AND
POLICE WERE CALLED IN. AND
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
CONTROVERSY AROUND EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED. BUT WE ARE TRYING TO
BALANCE, TWO SACROSANCT
PRINCIPLES THAT I BELIEVE
STRONGLY. AND ONE IS, THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AND THE RIGHT TO
PROTEST. BUT WE HAVE TO BALANCE
THAT ALSO WITH SAFETY AND THESE,
I KNOW, ARE DIFFICULT CONCERNS
TO TRY TO BALANCE ON OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. AND I KNOW THAT THE
DIFFERENT DEANS AND CHANCELLORS
AND PRESIDENTS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AT THESE SCHOOLS
ARE HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME OF
DOING THAT. I ALSO KNOW THAT
EXTREMISTS ON BOTH SIDES ARE
TRYING TO ABUSE THESE RIGHTS,
THAT YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO TAKE THEIR FIRST
AMENDMENT PRIVILEGES AND EXTEND
THESE INTO HARASSMENT AND
INTIMIDATION AND RACISM, WE HAVE
PEOPLE, ON THE OTHER HAND, WHO
ARE TRYING TO EQUATE ANY
LEGITIMATE CRITICISM OF ISRAEL,
WITH ANTI-SEMITISM. AND SO IN
TRYING TO CARVE OUT WHAT THE
RIGHT BALANCE IS BETWEEN
PROTECTING OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
FACULTY AND OUR CAMPUS MEMBERS,
FROM HATE AND INTIMIDATION,
WHILE ALSO TRYING TO RESPECT
FREE SPEECH RIGHTS, IT'S NOT AN
EASY THING TO DO, BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I RESPECT THIS
EFFORT. I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
IN TRYING TO FIND THAT RIGHT
BALANCE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
JUST DON'T DUCK THIS ISSUE, THAT
WE DO TRY TO PROTECT STUDENTS AT
THIS TIME WHILE RESPECTING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, WHILE
RESPECTING THAT LONG, STORIED
TRADITION OF FREE SPEECH THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
MENTIONED. SO I WANT TO URGE YOU
ALL TO VOTE. I AND I WANT TO
AGAIN, THANK THESE FOLKS FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD. THIS
IS NOT AN EASY THING TO DO, BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
MAKE THAT EFFORT AT THIS TIME
WHEN SO MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
FEELING, LIKE THEIR RIGHTS,
THEIR SAFETY, ARE BEING
CHALLENGED. THANK YOU, SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO POINT OUT MAYBE A,
UNLIKELY VIEW HERE ON THIS, AND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM EAST LA IN
NOTING THE TRADITIONS OF FREE
SPEECH, I THINK GETS RIGHT TO
THE HEART OF WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT NOT JUST THAT WE
DEBATE THIS ISSUE, BUT THAT WE
TRY TO LEGISLATE IN SOME WAY
HERE, YOU KNOW, MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO ARTICULATED
SO MANY INSTANCES OF AWFUL AND
DEMONIZING ANTI-SEMITISM THAT
ARE SPREADING LIKE WILDFIRE. SO
I DON'T NEED TO ITERATE THAT, I
WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHEN YOU
READ THE LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL,
WHO ELSE IS PROTECTED, AND WHERE
THEY'RE PROTECTED, NOT LIKE ON
THE STREETS OF SKOKIE, WHERE I,
I STILL BELIEVE IN THE ACLU'S
LITIGATION TO ALLOW THE AMERICAN
PARTY TO MARCH THROUGH A JEWISH
COMMUNITY ON THAT AWFUL DAY, I
STILL BELIEVE IN THE FIRST
AMENDMENT, BUT UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION, AS I READ IT, IF
JEWISH STUDENTS RIGHT NOW WERE
HOLDING A PROTEST AT A
UNIVERSITY MARCHING THROUGH A
DORMITORY CALLING FOR ANOTHER
NAKBA, CALL FOR THE END OF THE
PALESTINIAN STATE, EQUATING
ANYONE ARAB-AMERICAN AS A MEMBER
OF HAMAS, THAT KIND OF
INTIMIDATION AND HARASSMENT AND
THREATS OF VIOLENCE, NOT JUST
UNDERMINES OUR VALUES. IT IT
DENIES THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE
BEING TARGETED ACCESS TO
EDUCATION. IT MAKES THEM NOT
WANT TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL. IT
MAKES THEM WANT TO GO HOME,
LIKEWISE, WE WE'RE SEEING MORE
AND MORE TARGETING OF OUR LGBTQ
AND TRANS COMMUNITY. ANY TIME
SOMEONE COMPETES IN A SPORT OR
SHOWS THEIR FACE AND STANDS UP,
THEY CAN BE FOLLOWED BACK TO
THEIR DORM ROOMS. THEY CAN BE
TARGETED ON CAMPUS, IN THEIR
CLASSROOMS. AND WE ARE SEEING
THIS AROUND THE COUNTRY
EXPLOITED ON THE AIRWAVES AND
MADE INTO THEATER AND MAKING
THESE BRAVE YOUNG PEOPLE SOMEHOW
TARGETS OF A OF A HATE CAMPAIGN.
THEY TOO, WOULD BE PROTECTED AND
. I THINK THIS MOMENT IS
DANGEROUS BECAUSE IT'S DESIGNED,
JOINED TO DIVIDE US AND MAKE US
DISTRUST EACH OTHER AND PUT
SOMEHOW NO ONE COMMUNITY
SUFFERING OVER ANOTHER. AND I
HOPE WHAT WE CAN START TO DO IS
GET INTO A PLACE OF AN EVEN FORM
OF GOVERNANCE, SO THAT THE UC
SYSTEM AND THE CSU SYSTEM ARE
NOT SORT OF IMPROVISING. EVERY
TIME SOMETHING COMES UP AND WHEN
WE SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE A GOOD SECURITY PLAN,
YOU DON'T HAVE CLEARLY WRITTEN
RULES OF TIME, PLACE AND MANNER,
YOU HAVE TO SORT OF REACT ON THE
FLY AND ENTER THE POLITICAL
MOMENT. IT BECOMES A MESS. AND
WORSE YET, IT BECOMES A THREAT.
AND YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HURT
BECAUSE OF THIS DISORGANIZATION
THAT WE'VE SEEN AT A GOVERNANCE
LEVEL AROUND THESE CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS FOR SPEECH. SO IF
THERE ARE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
WORKED ON IN THIS LEGISLATION TO
MAKE THAT EQUAL APPLICABILITY,
BE CLEAR, TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ARAB AMERICAN OR OR JEWISH
STUDENT, FRANKLY, WHO WANTS TO
PROTEST THE ISRAELI GOVERNMENT
ON THEIR CAMPUS AND EVEN WANTS
TO CALL BENJAMIN NETANYAHU A WAR
CRIMINAL, THEY CAN DO THAT. THEY
CAN'T BAR STUDENTS FROM ENTERING
CLASS. THEY CAN'T FOLLOW THEM
BACK TO THEIR DORM ROOMS. WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE WHAT BECOMES A
SORT OF BATTLE OVER ACADEMIC
FREEDOM, WHERE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO TEACH THIS OR WE'RE NOT GOING
TO TEACH THAT. WE HAVE TO GET IN
THESE UNCOMFORTABLE SPACES AND
DEFEND THOSE WHOSE VIEWS ARE
OFFENSIVE TO US WITHOUT
UNDERCUTTING THE FUNDAMENTAL
FREEDOMS THAT WE HOLD SO DEAR.
YOU KNOW, MY FRESHMAN YEAR AT
HARVARD, THREE WEEKS IN MY VERY
FIRST EXPERIENCE WITH WITH A
REAL PROTEST WAS A LIVING WAGE
CAMPAIGN FOR JANITORS AT MY
SCHOOL. AND WE HAD AN
ENCAMPMENT. WE HAD TENTS IN
HARVARD YARD, WHERE A LOT OF
THIS CONTROVERSY YOU'RE SEEING
ON TV TODAY STILL HAPPENING. BUT
BUT THEN IN THAT MOMENT WHEN I
WAS IN A TENT OUTSIDE OF MY DORM
ROOM, FANCY MATTHEWS HALL AND
FEELING SO GOOD TO BE A HARVARD
FRESHMAN, I LEFT MY DORM ROOM
AND WENT INTO THE TENTS. I
WASN'T ONE OF THE ONES WHO
OCCUPIED THE ADMINISTRATIVE HALL
AND, GOT ARRESTED. BUT JUST LIKE
THE CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS ON
CAMPUS WHO FOUGHT AGAINST BLACK
DISCRIMINATION AND WERE ARRESTED
, AND MY FRIENDS IN THAT LIVING
WAGE MOVEMENT STANDING UP FOR
THE JANITORS WHO CLEANED OUR
DORMS, ALSO GOT ARRESTED. NOW,
THERE WERE THOSE WHO KEPT
GETTING A PROTEST AND I WAS
AMONG THEM, AND I LEARNED A LOT
THAT YEAR ABOUT PRIVILEGE AND
OPPORTUNITY, GOT CALLED A PINKO
BY MY CLASSMATES AND GOT TO SORT
OF ENJOY THE UNCOMFORTABLE
EXPERIENCE OF BEING A COLLEGE
STUDENT IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND THERE'S A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF THAT THAT WE HAVE TO
EMBRACE. THAT'S PART OF OUR
EDUCATION. BEYOND THAT CLASSROOM
. BUT WHAT WE CAN'T ALLOW TO
HAPPEN IS AN INTIMIDATION AROUND
THE FREEDOM AND OUR ACADEMIC
ENVIRONMENTS TO TEACH, TO HAVE
COMPETING VIEWS AND TO LET
OUTSIDE FORCES USE OUR CAMPUSES
OF TOOLS OF VIOLENCE AND
DIVISION. SO I'M GOING TO BE NOT
JUST SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE
TODAY, BUT URGING ALL OF YOU WHO
MIGHT BE ON THE FENCE OR HAVING
A TOUGH MOMENT, OR FACING LONG
BEING OR SORT OF WRESTLING WITH
THAT TENSION TO GIVE THIS BILL A
CHANCE AND TO GET OURSELVES TO A
PLACE OF CONSENSUS. IF WE CAN
MODEL SOME NEW COMPROMISE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA, I THINK, I THINK
WE CAN CHANGE THE DIALOG IN THIS
COUNTRY AND ACROSS THE WORLD. I
DON'T WANT TO GET HYPERBOLIC,
BUT I TRULY BELIEVE THE EYES OF
THE WORLD ARE ON US. AND SO I
WOULD URGE YOUR I VOTE. AND FOR
THOSE WHO FEEL SO FIRM IN THEIR
VIEWS THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
HEAR WHAT THE OTHER SIDE HAS TO
SAY, THE HEARING. THE HEARING IS
HALF THE BATTLE. YOU HAVE TO
HEAR IT. BUT WHEN THAT DENIES
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO EDUCATION
OR TO FEEL SAFE WHEN YOU'RE
GOING TO SLEEP AT NIGHT OR TO
EAT YOUR LUNCH, OR TO BE IN THAT
CLASSROOM, THAT'S NO LONGER THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, AND THAT'S NO
LONGER FREEDOM THAT WE SHOULD
ENDURE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BECKER. I THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS DEBATE. AND I WANT TO
ADDRESS, I GUESS, MAYBE FIRST OF
ALL, MY COMMENTS FROM MY, MY
FRIEND AND SEATMATE FROM, LOS
ANGELES, BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S
NOTHING MORE SACROSANCT TO ALL
OF US THAN THAT, THAT RIGHT OF
NONVIOLENT PROTEST. AND, I HAVE
A SMALL EXPERIENCE WITH IT, BUT
NOWHERE NEAR THE EXPERIENCE THAT
THAT SHE HAS. I HAD BEEN
ARRESTED, IN A PROTEST
SUPPORTING WORKERS, BUT AGAIN,
NOWHERE NEAR THE EXPERIENCE THAT
SHE HAS ON THE FRONT LINES, BUT
AGAIN, I THINK THE POINT HERE IS
THAT WE ALL WANT TO PROTECT
THAT. AND YOU KNOW, MY, MY WIFE
CALLED MY ATTENTION TO SOMETHING
ON PBS. SHE ALWAYS WATCHES THE
NEWSHOUR. AND I'D LIKE TO SHARE
THAT WITH YOU. CAN I PERMISSION
TO READ? PERMISSION GRANTED.
THIS IS FROM DAVID FRENCH ON THE
NEWSHOUR RECENTLY. AND HE SAID,
WELL, WHEN WE SAW THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT, WHAT YOU SAW
WAS PROTESTERS VIOLATING UNJUST
LAWS LIKE PROHIBITING BLACK
AMERICANS FROM EATING THE SAME
DINERS AS WHITE AMERICANS.
THEY'RE VIOLATING AN UNJUST LAW.
AND THEN ACCEPTING THE
CONSEQUENCES. SO YOU ACCEPT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF YOUR LEGAL
VIOLATION, WHICH UPHOLDS THE
RULE OF LAW. THAT'S A Kò.
THERE'S AN UNJUST LAW YOU
VIOLATE, AND THEN YOU ACCEPT THE
CONSEQUENCES. AND YOU DO IT
PEACEFULLY HERE IN MANY WAYS.
AND HE'S THEN REFERRING TO FOLKS
THAT WOULD BE AFFECTED BY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE, IS
THEY'RE VIOLATING JUST LAWS. IN
OTHER WORDS, THERE'S ACTUALLY IN
VIOLATION OF LAWS THAT PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF OTHERS AND THEN
REFUSING TO ACCEPT THE
CONSEQUENCES. AND HE GOES, SO
TALK ABOUT GOES ON, TALK ABOUT
COVERING FACES TO AVOID
DETECTION AND OTHER THINGS. BUT
BUT THAT WAS THE IMPORTANT POINT
HERE THAT, THAT I THINK IS
DIFFERENTIT DATES AND HOPEFULLY
GIVES SOME COMFORT TO MY FRIEND
FROM LOS ANGELES. WE'LL FIND
OUT. BUT THAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE AGAIN, IS TO IS TO
RESPECT IT. CERTAINLY, THAT
HISTORY OF NONVIOLENT PROTESTS.
AND I'LL LOOK AT THE DIGEST. BUT
THE DIGEST SAYS HERE CALLS ON
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES OF THE CSU
AND THE AND THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO ADOPT AND ENFORCE
POLICIES IN INSTITUTION BASED
STUDENT CODES OF CONDUCT THAT
PROHIBIT VIOLENCE, HARASSMENT,
INTIMIDATION AND DISCRIMINATION,
INTERFERE THROUGH FORCE OR
INTIMIDATION WITH FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS, OR CALLING FOR
GENOCIDE. SO THE BILL IS VERY
EXPLICITLY AND WE'RE CERTAINLY
THAT'S THE GOAL OF IT. AND ALSO
NOTE THIS BILL WAS INTRODUCED
BACK IN FEBRUARY. SO THIS WAS
BACK. THIS WAS INTRODUCED BACK
WAY BEFORE THE ENCAMPMENTS AND
SUCH THAT THAT WE'VE WE'VE SEEN
THAT REALLY KIND OF FLARED UP
HERE IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS. THIS WAS INTRODUCED WAY
BEFORE THAT. SO IT WAS NOT
INDIRECTLY FOR THAT, BUT AGAIN
TO ADOPT POLICY THAT PROHIBIT
VIOLENCE, HARASSMENT,
INTIMIDATION, DISCRIMINATION
THAT INTERFERE THROUGH FORCE OR
INTIMIDATION WITH FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS. SO THAT'S
CERTAINLY THE INTENTION HERE. AS
WITH MANY BILLS THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED THIS WEEK, THIS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS. AND I
CERTAINLY, YOU KNOW, SHE HAS MY
COMMITMENT AND YOU ALL HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS. AND IF THERE'S
REFINEMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE, WE SHOULD CERTAINLY LOOK
AT MAKING THOSE GOING FORWARD.
SO YOU CERTAINLY HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS AS WE'RE I THINK,
WORKING WITH MANY BILLS HERE
GOING FORWARD, BECAUSE I THINK
THE INTENT IS CLEAR, BUT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE, AS WITH ALL BILLS
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T
UNINTENDEDLY DO OTHER THINGS. SO
I JUST WANT TO SAY I RESPECT THE
DEBATE HERE TODAY AND I, I URGE
YOU, AS MY LAST COLLEAGUE DID,
TO KEEP THIS BILL MOVING, AND
WE'LL KEEP THIS CONVERSATION
GOING. THANK YOU, SENATOR CORTEZ
. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I DO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB 1287, BUT
I WANT IT ON THE RECORD AS TO MY
POSITION THAT I DISASSOCIATE MY
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE ON THE
RECORD TODAY ABOUT JEWISH VOICES
FOR PEACE. I DO NOT KNOW IF
JEWISH VOICES FOR PEACE IN MY
DISTRICT AND THE GOOD PEOPLE IN
THE ORGANIZATION IN MY DISTRICT
WHO HAVE STOOD WITH ME, YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR IN
NONVIOLENCE CONVENINCE SOME
STOOD WITH PEOPLE LIKE DOLORES
HUERTA IN NONVIOLENCE CONVENINCE
AS IF THEY'VE BEEN PAINTED WITH
A BROAD BRUSH TODAY AS SOMEHOW
BEING VILIFIED OVER THEIR RIGHT
TO FREE SPEECH. AND I'M SADDENED
THAT SUCH AN EXCELLENT, BILL
FROM A CRAFTSMANSHIP AND
DRAFTSMANSHIP STANDPOINT THAT
REALLY DEALS WITH FOUR ISSUES,
FOUR ISSUES THAT I CAN SUPPORT,
AND I THINK EVERYONE HERE SHOULD
SUPPORT IS SOMEHOW NOW MAY
REINFORCE FOR PEOPLE IN THE
OPPOSITION THAT IT WAS REALLY
TARGETED AT THEM. AND I KNOW IN
COMMITTEE I ASKED STRAIGHT UP
THE AUTHOR, MY FRIEND FROM
CONTRA COSTA WHETHER OR NOT THAT
WAS THE CASE, AND HE SAID
STRAIGHT UP, THAT ISN'T THE
CASE. AND NOT ONLY DO I TAKE HIM
ON HIS WORD, BUT AS AN ATTORNEY
AND AS A MEMBER OF THIS SENATE,
I'M CAPABLE OF READING THE
LANGUAGE MYSELF. AND I CAN SEE
THAT IT'S FAIR AND IT'S BALANCED
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY TIED TO
THOSE PRINCIPLES, THOSE FREE
SPEECH AND FIRST AMENDMENT
PRINCIPLES THAT WE HOLD DEAR
THAT HAVE BEEN PART OF THIS
COUNTRY FOR OVER 200 YEARS. THAT
IS ONE ISSUE. I AM NOT, THOUGH,
STANDING OR CASTING MY VOTE TO
PAINT ANY KIND OF A BROAD BRUSH
ABOUT THE ATTITUDES AND FEELINGS
OF PEOPLE IN THE OPPOSITION
GROUP, WHICH INCLUDE, BY THE
WAY, FOLKS LIKE ACLU CALIFORNIA
AND OTHERS WHO I THINK HAVE A
GOOD STANDING REPUTATION IN THIS
HOUSE WHEN IT COMES TO POSITIONS
THAT THEY TAKE, WHETHER WE AGREE
WITH THEM OR NOT, WHETHER WE
AGREE WITH THEM OR NOT. AS I
SAID, I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL
AND I BELIEVE IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO FOR OTHERS TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AS WELL. BUT
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LET ME GET ON THE RECORD,
DEFENDING THOSE GOOD PEOPLE IN
MY DISTRICT WHO DO GOOD WORK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I TOO, RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
1287. I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE JEWISH CAUCUS FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD, YOU KNOW, I
THINK SOMETHING THAT'S MISSING
OUT OF THIS WHOLE THING IS IN
THE CONVERSATION IS, IS THAT
IT'S EVERYBODY SAYS THAT THEY
SUPPORT THE CONSTITUTION AND
WHAT IT SAYS, AND PEOPLE'S
RIGHT. BUT THE ACTUAL
CONSTITUTIONAL LANGUAGE
PERMISSION TO READ? YES.
PERMISSION NO. CONGRESS SHALL
MAKE NO LAW RESPECTING AN
ESTABLISHMENT OF RELIGION OR
PROHIBITING THE FREE EXERCISE
THEREOF. FREE EXERCISE THEREOF,
OR ABRIDGING THE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH OR THE PRESS, AND THE
RIGHT FOR PEOPLE TO PEACEABLY
ASSEMBLE AND PETITION THEIR
GOVERNMENT FOR A REDRESS OF
GRIEVANCES IS, I THINK, THE BIG
THING THAT WE'RE THAT NO ONE'S
TALKING ABOUT TODAY IS THE
PEACEABLE RIGHT TO ASSEMBLE, IT
IS NOT PEACEABLE TO WALK INTO A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND THREATEN
TO COME TO CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
HOME AND BEHEAD THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT SUPPORTING A CEASE
FIRE. IT IS NOT PEACEABLE TO
TAKE OVER BUILDINGS AND REQUIRE
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO GO IN AND
HAVE THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
OCCUPYING THAT THAT THAT CAMPUS
OR THAT SCHOOL CAMPUS. IT IS NOT
PEACEABLE ASSEMBLY TO ATTACK THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT GOING INTO DIS
DIS, TO REMOVE THE ENCAMPMENTS,
IT'S NOT PEACEABLE TO HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ATTACKED BY TEAR GAS
AND OTHER THINGS. IT'S NOT
PEACEABLE. TO HAVE THREATS OF,
OF AGAINST OTHER PEOPLE'S LIVES
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE JEWISH.
IT'S NOT PEACEABLE TO CALL FOR
THEIR DEATH AND DESTRUCTION
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE RELIGION
THAT THEY'VE EXERCISED SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF TIME. IN BIBLICAL
DAYS, I, I HAVE ONE CONCERN
ABOUT THIS, BILL. I HAVE SHARED
THIS CONCERN BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THAT, I DO BELIEVE THAT
THE UNIVERSITY AND UC SYSTEMS
HAVE BELABORED THIS. YOU HAVE
UNIVERSITY AND UC PROFESSIONALS
OR PRESIDENTS THAT CAN'T EVEN
IDENTIFY THAT HATE SPEECH IS
CALLING FOR THE DEATH OF JEWS,
CALLING FROM, THE CHANTS THAT
ARE GOING ON IN THESE PROTESTS.
IS THAT HATE SPEECH? WELL, I
DON'T KNOW. IT COULD BE. I MEAN,
THEY'RE NOT EVEN STANDING UP AND
PROTECTING, THE, THE HATE SPEECH
THAT IS GOING ON IN THESE
CAMPUSES. MY CONCERN IS, IS THAT
IF THIS BILL PASSES, WHICH I
HOPE IT DOES, BUT I HOPE THAT
THERE IS A MORE THERE'S MORE
STRONGER LANGUAGE BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT THOSE PRESIDENTS
WRITING WHAT HATE SPEECH IS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE PROVEN TIME
AND TIME AGAIN IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS AND HOPEFULLY ONE DAY
IN FRONT OF US, BUT IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS, DEFINITELY. WHEN YOU
WATCH THEM, THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
HATE SPEECH IS. SO SO I WOULD
LIKE THEM NOT TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE IN THE
CURRICULUM OR HOW IT'S DESIGNED
OR THE POLICY PORTION OF IT. I
THINK PEOPLE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MORE, HAVE A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT HATE
SPEECH SHOULD PARTICIPATE IN
THAT. I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR
CLARIFYING THE JEWISH, VOICES
FOR PEACE, IF YOU LOOK ON THEIR
WEBSITE, IT SAYS THEY'RE AGAINST
ZIONISM, ZIONISM, SOMEBODY WHO
BELIEVES THAT ISRAEL BELONGS TO
THE TO THE JEWISH PEOPLE.
THEY'RE THERE FOR A COMPLETE
CEASE FIRE. THEY ARE AGAINST
ISRAEL'S THE UNITED STATES
ARMING ISRAEL TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES. THEY'RE AGAINST THE
TERRITORY OF ISRAEL BEING
DEDICATED TO THE JEWISH PEOPLE.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO CALL
THEMSELVES, JEWISH VOICES FOR
PEACE. SO I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE FOR CALLING THAT OUT
BECAUSE THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MISREPRESENTED. YOU COULD SAY
SOMETHING THAT YOU BELONG TO
ANGELS OF MERCY, AND YOU'D BE A
DEATH CAMP PLACE. I MEAN, SO I
DO APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE FOR
MAKING SURE THAT THAT WAS
ADDRESSED AND THAT, YOU KNOW,
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE JEWISH VOICES FOR
PEACE CAN SIMPLY GO TO THEIR
WEBSITE AND LOOK WHAT THEY STAND
FOR. AND I WOULD BE VERY SHOCKED
THAT ANY OF YOU WOULD STAND FOR
ANYTHING THAT THEY WOULD REALLY
SUPPORT BASED ON THE STUFF
THAT'S ON THERE, CALLING FOR THE
ANNIHILATION OF JEWISH PEOPLE.
THAT IS NOT IF THEY WERE CALLING
FOR THE ANNIHILATION OF ANYONE,
THEN WE SHOULD NOT SUPPORT ANY
GROUP LIKE THAT. SO THANK THE
AUTHOR. PLEASE, PUT SOME
PARAMETERS IN IT THAT PEOPLE
THAT DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS, AND DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE, THE PROCESS OF
PEACEABLY ASSEMBLING AND DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE CONSTITUTION AND
CAN'T CALL OUT HATE SPEECH FOR
WHAT IT IS. I WOULD APPRECIATE
YOU MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
PEOPLE DON'T PARTICIPATE IN THE
POLICY MAKING OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS ONE IS A VERY
DIFFICULT BILL. I APPRECIATE THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND WHY THEY
BROUGHT IT FORWARD. I APPRECIATE
THE CIRCUMSTANCE THAT WE ARE
FACING. AND YET I ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT IT MANY, MANY
TIMES IN RECENT AND PAST HISTORY
WHERE WE AS A SOCIETY HAVE FACED
A REALLY DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES
AND CLASHES. AND I DO NOT MEAN
IN ANY WAY TO UNDERESTIMATE
THIS. WE HAVE THERE ARE MUCH,
MANY TIMES WHERE WE WENT TOO FAR
WHERE AND I DON'T MEAN TO CITE,
I ALMOST DON'T WANT TO CITE ANY
BECAUSE I DO NOT WANT TO MAKE
ANY ANALOGIES TO THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE. BUT WE KNOW IF WE
ALL THINK ABOUT IT, WE KNOW OF
MANY TIMES IN BOTH RECENT AND
PAST HISTORY WHERE LAWS WENT TOO
FAR IN RESPONSE TO A
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT WAS CRITICAL
IN A CRISIS, BUT THEY WENT TOO
FAR. AND WHEN I LOOK AT THIS,
WHAT I BELIEVE IS REALLY THE
SANCTITY OF FREE SPEECH AND I
LOOK AT SOME OF THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL, AND I THINK IT DOES GO
TOO FAR. AND FOR EXAMPLE. AND IF
PERMISSION TO READ PERMISSION
GRANTED IN THE ACLU'S LETTER,
THEY'RE CLEAR THAT THERE ARE
ASPECTS OF THE BILL THAT REQUIRE
THE CAMPUSES TO PUNISH STUDENTS
OR SPEAKERS ON THE CAMPUS WHEN
THEY EXERCISE FUNDAMENTAL FREE
EXPRESSION. UNDER OUR FREE
SPEECH AMENDMENT. AND THAT,
UNFORTUNATELY, IS WRONG AND
UNLAWFUL. AND NOW I'M NOT
READING FROM THERE. EVEN WHEN
THAT SPEECH IS OFFENSIVE OR
INFLAMMATORY AND WE HAVE SEEN
MANY, MANY CASES. AGAIN NOT IN
THIS TYPE OF CIRCUMSTANCE, BUT
IN THE PAST, WHERE WE CONFRONTED
THIS. NOW, THE FACT THAT THE
BILL HAS PENALTIES AGAINST THE
CSU'S, COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
UCS, IF THEY DON'T COMPLY WITH
THE BILL, ANY INSTITUTION, WHEN
THEY HAVE SUCH A LAW, ALL OF US
ARE RISK ADVERSE. THEIR LAWYERS
ARE GOING TO ADVISE THEM TO GO
FURTHER SO THEY DO NOT
EXPERIENCE THE PENALTIES, IS
THEY'RE GOING FURTHER THAN
FURTHER POTENTIALLY VIOLATING
OUR FREE SPEECH RIGHTS. NOW, ONE
OF THE SPECIFICS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS ASSOCIATION
POINTED OUT WAS, FOR EXAMPLE,
THAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO LIMIT
THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH, INCLUDING
A CALL FOR GENOCIDE. NOW, I AM
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSED TO OPPOSE
ANYONE'S DESIRE FOR GENOCIDE IN
ANY CONTEXT. AND YET IS THE
CALLING FOR IT SIMPLY AND ONLY
SOMETHING THAT THEN, WHILE IT IS
ABHORRENT, IS IT SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD MAKE BY LAW UNLAWFUL?
AND THERE ARE ALSO PHRASES IS
THAT SOME OF US FULLY UNDERSTAND
IMPLY A CALL FOR GENOCIDE, BUT
OTHERS DO NOT. AND SO IF SOMEONE
USES THAT PHRASE, DOES THAT THEN
BECOME THAT THEY HAVE BROKEN
THIS LAW. SO I THINK THERE ARE
MANY ASPECTS OF THIS BILL THAT
NEED TO BE REVISED. I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY. I RESERVE
THE RIGHT NOT TO SUPPORT IT WHEN
IT RETURNS TO US. I HOPE THAT IT
IS THAT THE THINGS THAT I'VE
RAISED GET ADDRESSED AND REVISED
. AND BECAUSE I RESPECT THE
LEGITIMATE PURPOSE TO TRY TO GET
CLEARER CODES OF CONDUCT THAT
HELP REDUCE THE VIOLENCE AND THE
INTIMIDATION. HOWEVER, I'D ALSO
POINT OUT THAT IT IS ALREADY
UNLAWFUL TO HARASS OR
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST SOMEONE DUE
TO THEIR RACE, ETHNICITY, OR
RELIGION THAT IS ALREADY
UNLAWFUL, AND OUR UNIVERSITIES,
OUR STATE CAPITAL, ALL OF US
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ACT ON THAT.
WE DO NOT NEED THIS LAW TO DO
SO. AND IF THE PROBLEM IS THAT
OUR UNIVERSITIES HAVE NOT DONE
SO ADEQUATELY, WE NEED TO WORK
WITH THEM TO IMPROVE THAT. BUT
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL LAW THAT
CREATES THE TYPE OF CONSEQUENCES
THAT THIS LAW DOES. AND I THINK
DEPENDING ON WHO'S READING IT
AND WHEN, THE INTERPRETATION
VERGES ON INFRINGING FREE SPEECH
RIGHTS, THAT IS VERY SERIOUS.
AND SO I FELT I NEEDED TO STAND
UP TO EXPRESS THOSE WITH GREAT
RESPECT TO WHAT? TO THE REAL
ISSUES THAT WE ARE CONFRONTING.
THANK YOU, SENATOR PADILLA.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
BRIEFLY. I DIDN'T INTEND TO RISE
DUE RESPECT TO MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE FROM THE BAY AREA. I
FELT THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
ADD TO THE RECORD ON THIS. TO BE
CLEAR, I CERTAINLY RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT COLLEAGUES TO REMEMBER
THAT OUR SYSTEM OF LAWS IS
STRONG, SOLID AND CONSISTENT
ABOUT FOCUSING ON THE IMPACTS TO
THE SOCIAL CONTRACT, TO SOCIETY,
TO THE DAMAGE DONE BY
INCITEMENT, INCITEMENT FEDERALLY
AND IN MANY STATES, INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA, IS A CRIME. IT IS A
CRIME TO UNLAWFULLY INCITE TO
PANIC OR TO RIOT. WE HAVE A
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES CURRENTLY UNDER FEDERAL
INDICTMENT FOR INCITING TO AN
INSURRECTION AGAINST THE CAPITAL
OF THE UNITED STATES. MANY ARGUE
THAT SUCH INCITEMENT OR
ARTICULATION OR EXPRESSIONS ARE
PROTECTED SPEECH. OUR SYSTEM OF
LAWS HAS CONSISTENT HELD AT
EVERY LEVEL THAT THEY ARE NOT. I
CANNOT FATHOM, I CANNOT FATHOM
CIRCUMSTANTIALLY IN THE MODERN
HISTORY OF THE WORLD, A MORE
INAPPROPRIATE INCITEMENT OR
CALLING THAN THAT TO THE CRIME
OF GENOCIDE. AND HISTORY SHOULD
HAVE TAUGHT US THIS A LONG TIME
AGO. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WAHAB. THANK
YOU, I DIDN'T ACTUALLY HAVE
TALKING POINTS FOR THIS. I DO
JUST WANT TO SAY, YOU KNOW, I
REALLY APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
FOR, YOU KNOW, PUSHING SOMETHING
FORWARD THAT THEY BELIEVE REALLY
WILL, WILL TACKLE ON THE ISSUES
THAT WE ARE SEEING. I DO
BELIEVE, AND I WILL PREFACE MY
COMMENTS AS ANYTHING I WILL SAY
WILL BE A PROBLEM FOR ONE GROUP
OR ANOTHER, BUT I DO BELIEVE IN
FAIRNESS AND I ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT
ANTI-SEMITISM, ISLAMOPHOBIA,
RACISM, BIGOTRY, ANY CALLS FOR
GENOCIDE AND GENOCIDE ITSELF
OBVIOUSLY IS WRONG. FIRST AND
FOREMOST. AND YET AT THE SAME
TIME, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING ACROSS THIS NATION AS
WELL AS ACROSS THE WORLD,
SIGNIFICANT PROTESTS AND
PROTESTS ABOUT ONE ISSUE OR
ANOTHER, ABOUT ONE LEADER OR
ANOTHER. AND PEOPLE WANT ACTION.
AND WE HAVE SEEN TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
PROTESTS WHERE THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL GO FURTHER
THAN SOME OF THE ORGANIZERS OF
THE PROTESTS, WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BLACK LIVES
MATTER, WHETHER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT,
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, THE PROTESTS AGAINST THE
VIETNAM WAR AND MUCH MORE. NOW
AS AN AFGHAN AMERICAN AND AS THE
ONLY MUSLIM IN THIS SENATE, I
CAN SPEAK VERY CLEARLY THAT EVEN
AFTER NINE OVER 11, AN AFGHAN
WOMAN WAS SHOT AND KILLED IN
FREMONT AND SHE WORE A HIJAB AND
VERY IDENTIFIABLY A MUSLIM WOMAN
. AND I HEAR THE COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES, AND I'VE HAD MANY
GROUPS REACH OUT TO ME
HIGHLIGHTING THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO BE WHO THEY
ARE IN DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES,
WHETHER AT SCHOOL, AT WORK, OR
JUST WALKING TO THE GROCERY
STORE. AND IN CALIFORNIA, IN THE
UNITED STATES, THAT SHOULD NOT
TAKE PLACE. YOU SHOULD BE VERY,
VERY MUCH ABLE AND FREELY WEAR
THE STAR OF DAVID. YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO WEAR THE HIJAB. YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO WEAR THE
CROSS. THE FACT THAT WE ARE
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS HERE
IN THE 21ST CENTURY IS
DISAPPOINTING TO ME AS A HUMAN
SOCIETY, AND I WANT TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT I DO BELIEVE IN
THE RIGHT TO PROTEST AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LÀ MENTIONED,
PROTESTING IS VERY MUCH AN
AMERICAN PRINCIPLE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, INCLUDING PROTEST, IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE ALLOWED TO
DO, AND WE MUST PROTECT BECAUSE
STIFLING FREE SPEECH IS
PROBLEMATIC IN ITSELF. YOU KNOW,
WHEN WE ARE UNABLE TO BE HONEST
ABOUT ISSUES AND I REALLY WANT
TO THANK THE JEWISH CAUCUS
MEMBERS, SINCE MUCH OF THE
DEBATE HAS HAPPENED OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS, WE
JOINTLY WROTE A LETTER TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN AS WELL AS
SECRETARY BLINKEN, TO HIGHLIGHT
ONE OR UNITY THAT WE SHOULD NOT
BE SUPPORTING ONE OVER ANOTHER.
AND THAT'S WHAT MY MUCH OF THE
DEBATE HAS BEEN, IS THAT EITHER
YOU'RE FOR THIS OR FOR THAT, AND
THAT'S NOT ACCURATE AS WELL. AND
I KNOW THAT MANY, MANY PEOPLE
ARE VERY UPSET INTERNATIONALLY
ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON AND WHAT
HAPPENED IN ISRAEL ON OCTOBER
7TH AND THE ATTACKS ON ISRAEL
AND THE HOSTAGES AND THE PEOPLE,
AND MUCH MORE. I ALSO KNOW THAT
MANY PEOPLE ARE VERY, VERY UPSET
WITH THE RESPONSE AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN GAZA. AND
AGAIN, I REALLY WANT US TO THINK
ABOUT THE POLICIES THAT WE ARE
PUTTING FORWARD. I DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS PARTICULAR BILL NEEDS
A LITTLE BIT MORE WORK. I WOULD
LIKE FOR THE AUTHOR TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS FROM THE
OPPOSITION. I DO BELIEVE THAT IT
IS OUR RIGHT AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO CRAFT THE BEST
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
PROTECTS ALL PEOPLE, AND RIGHT
NOW, I THINK THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF DEBATE
ABOUT THIS, AND I PERSONALLY
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
AS IS, BUT I AM MORE THAN HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND HAVE
MORE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
SPECIFIC BILL AND SOME OF THE
PIECES TO IT, BUT I ALSO THINK
THAT IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TO PRIORITIZE AND SAFEGUARD THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
STUDENTS AND UPHOLD THE
PRINCIPLES OF FREE SPEECH AND
ACADEMIC FREEDOM. I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT AS CHAIR OF
PUBLIC SAFETY, MY DEEPEST
CONCERN IS THAT IF IMPLEMENTED,
AND LET'S SAY A STUDENT WHO IS
18, 19, EVEN POTENTIALLY 17, IN
THESE SYSTEMS DOES SOMETHING AND
THEIR BRAIN AGAIN, YOU KNOW, WE
DEBATE ON THIS FLOOR OFTEN THAT
THE BRAINS ARE NOT FULLY
DEVELOPED AND THEY'RE STILL
GETTING TO KNOW WHO THEY ARE AND
FINDING THEIR VOICE. WHAT
HAPPENS TO THAT PARTICULAR
STUDENT. RIGHT. HOW ARE THEY
AFFECTED IN THE ACADEMIC ARENA?
ARE THEY GOING TO BE BLACKLISTED
OR ARE THEY ALLOWED IN THE UK'S
AND SO MUCH MORE. AND THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT ARE
BEING BROUGHT UP. SO WHETHER
IT'S THIS ISSUE THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT, RIGHT NOW AND
TODAY, OR AN ISSUE THAT COMES UP
20 YEARS FROM NOW, THAT IS MY
CONCERN WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PUBLIC POLICY. AND SO I RESPECT
AGAIN THE EFFORT OF THE AUTHOR
AND THE OFFICE. AND I FULLY
SUPPORT THAT EFFORT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE FEELS SAFE IN AN
ACADEMIC INSTITUTION. OAN I
JUST THINK THAT THIS REQUIRES A
LITTLE BIT MORE WORK. SO I WILL
NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING, SEEING
ANY ANYONE? NO MORE,
MICROPHONES. SENATOR GLAZIER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. WELL
MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR THE GOOD
DEBATE AND CONVERSATION. THIS
AFTERNOON. I, I WANT TO SAY
THAT, AFTER OCTOBER 7TH, A
NUMBER OF YOU REACHED OUT TO ME,
AND I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES WITH
COMFORTING CALLS AND TEXTS AFTER
THAT, THAT HORRIBLE DAY. AND I
MEANT A LOT TO ME, I KNOW, AND I
SO APPRECIATE IT. AND, YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD ME TALK ABOUT IN
REGARD TO THIS BILL IS ANY
SPECIFIC, SPECIFIC INCIDENT IN
OUR COUNTRY, IN THE WORLD AS IT
RELATES TO THE ELEMENTS OF THIS
BILL, THAT IT'S IN ITS CONTENT
NEUTRAL. I KNOW THAT GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH WE FIND
OURSELVES, IT'S EASY TO CONNECT
IT TO EVENTS HAPPENING, ON OUR
CAMPUSES TODAY AND AROUND THE
WORLD. I UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT I
ALSO WANT TO CALL YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE NARROWNESS IN WHICH THIS
BILL IS CRAFTED IN ITS CONTENT
NEUTRAL WAY. LET ME USE THAT AS
I FINISH MY REMARKS. BUT I WANT
TO GO DOWN A LITTLE BIT OF A
ROAD FIRST, I LOVE THE COMMENTS
FROM THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES REFLECTED ON HER, ACTIVE
REYES NOT JUST AS A STUDENT, BUT
IN LIFE IN TERMS OF RAISING HER
VOICE AND ENGAGING IN PROTESTS,
I IT BRINGS ME BACK TO MY
COLLEGE DAYS, AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY, WHERE I WAS A LEADER
ON THE CAMPUS IN FIGHTING THE
APARTHEID IN SOUTH AFRICA, NOT
JUST ON MY CAMPUS, WHERE WE
DIVESTED FROM BANKS THAT HAD
INVESTMENTS IN SOUTH AFRICA, BUT
I ACTUALLY TRAVELED AROUND THE
STATE TO RECRUIT OTHER COLLEGES,
STUDENT UNIONS TO ENGAGE IN
THAT, THAT GOOD CAUSE OF THE
RIGHTS OF STUDENTS IN SOUTH
AFRICA, OF ALL OF ALL
NATIONALITIES AND ETHNICITIES,
TO, GO TO SCHOOL AND BE THE BEST
THAT THEY CAN BE. BUT THE
CONCERN THAT WAS RAISED WAS THAT
SOMEHOW THIS BILL WOULD
INTERFERE WITH THE RIGHT TO
PROTEST IT. AND IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T INTERFERE WITH THE RIGHT
TO BE ON A PICKET LINE. IT
TO PEACEFUL PROTESTS, EVEN
ILLEGAL PROTESTS OR SIT INS OR
ILLEGAL ENCAMPMENTS. THIS BILL
DOES NOTHING, DOESN'T SPEAK TO
ANY OF THOSE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES. THIS BILL IS ONLY
ABOUT PROTECTING SPEECH, ONLY
ABOUT PROTECTING FREEDOM OF
SPEECH OF STUDENTS ON CAMPUSES
TO BE FREE OF VIOLENCE,
HARASSMENT, INTIMIDATION AND
DISCRIMINATION, INCLUDING CALLS
FOR GENOCIDE. THAT'S THE
NARROWNESS OF THIS BILL, AND I
APPRECIATED THE COMMENTS FROM
THE SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO
WHO RAISED, EXAMPLES OF HATE NOT
JUST AGAINST JEWISH STUDENTS,
BUT AGAINST MUSLIM STUDENTS. HE
BROUGHT UP, QUITE CORRECTLY, THE
REFUSAL TO HAVE A MUSLIM STUDENT
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BE THE VALEDICTORIAN
SPEAKER, WHICH I THOUGHT WAS A
TERRIBLE THING TO HAVE OCCURRED,
TERRIBLE THING. AND I AND I SAID
THAT IN A PUBLIC ARENA, NOT JUST
HERE TODAY, BUT REALLY WHAT I
HOPE THAT YOU FOCUS ON MEMBERS
IS THAT IS THE UNIFYING MESSAGE
OF THIS BILL. IF WE REALLY THINK
ABOUT IT, THIS BILL IS, IS, IS,
IS ABOUT PROTECTING ALL STUDENTS
OF ALL SHAPES AND SIZES AND
COLORS AND VIEWS. THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT, AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAIR TO CONFLATE IT
TO ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING OUT THERE, BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T. IT JUST SAYS THAT IF
YOU'RE A STUDENT ON A CAMPUS,
THAT YOUR RIGHTS TO FREE SPEECH,
YOUR RIGHTS TO BE WHO YOU ARE,
WHOEVER YOU ARE, SHOULD BE
PROTECTED AND HONORED. AND
THAT'S IT. AND IT'S NARROW TO
THE EXTENT THAT I THINK EVEN THE
SENATOR FROM BERKELEY MENTIONED
THAT A NUMBER OF THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE IN THE LAW
TODAY, BECAUSE MANY OF THEM ARE
ONE OF THE PROTECTIONS THAT IS
NOT IN THE LAW TODAY, IS THE
CALL FOR GENOCIDE. DODD. AND I
EXPLAINED IN MY OPENING REMARKS
THAT IT'S NOT JUST A CALL FOR
GENOCIDE, THAT THE PERSON HAD TO
INTEND TO KILL, AND THE PERSON
HEARING IT HAD TO INTEND THAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY MEANT TO KILL.
AND SO IT'S A VERY NARROWLY
CONSTRUCTED, BUT IT'S ONE OF THE
FEW THINGS IN THIS BILL THAT
STANDS OUT FROM MANY OTHER
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN OUR LAWS
TODAY. SO I GUESS AS WE CLOSE
THIS DEBATE TONIGHT, I JUST
THINK THAT YOU SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THE UNIFYING THEME THAT
THIS BILL PROVIDES FOR ALL OF US
TO SAY ALL STUDENTS SHOULD BE
PROTECTED, ALL STUDENT RIGHTS
SHOULD BE PROTECTED, BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU ALL.
DISCUSSION. DEBATE HAVING
CEASED, SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 50. ALAN
ALVARADO, GILL ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE. DALLY.
DODD. AYE DURAZZO. EGGMAN. AYE
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. I
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO
AYE. OKOBO AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB NÓ. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. DALLEY AYE.
DURAZZO ROTH. SKINNER SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. EYES 30. NOSE ONE. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW. MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING BACK IN
ORDER. WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM
2728. SENATOR DURAZZO, SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1325 BY SENATOR
DURAZZO. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS. SENATOR
DURAZZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL SIMPLIFIES
THE PUBLIC CONTRACTING PROCESS
FOR STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES BY
CREATING AN AUTHORIZING STATUTE
FOR BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT. WHAT
THAT MEANS THAT IT EMPOWERS
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES TO CONSIDER
IMPORTANT FACTORS SUCH AS
PRODUCT QUALITY ON TIME, BUDGETS
, COMMUNITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS WHEN DETERMINING A
SUCCESSFUL BIDDER, BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT DIFFERS FROM OTHER
PROCUREMENT MODELS, SUCH AS
LOWEST RESPONSE BIDDER, BY
ALLOWING FACTORS IN ADDITION TO
PRICE TO BE EVALUATED AND SCORED
WITHIN THE BID PROCESS. AN
EXCELLENT EXAMPLE OF BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT IS LA METRO'S
MANUFACTURING CAREERS POLICY,
WITHOUT QUALITY AND STANDARDS IN
OUR PUBLIC CONTRACTS, CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS COULD END UP
SUBSIDIZING JOBS AND COMPANIES
IN OTHER STATES. BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT IS A PROVEN WAY TO
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS OF PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES,
AND I THANK YOU. AND I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL ON FALL ITEM 28 ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. AYE I ATKINS I BECKER. I
BLAKE. SPEER. I. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD I DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN
I GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ I GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO I JONES. NØ. LAIRD.
AYE LEMON I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I.
MEN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NÓ. NILO
NO. OCHOA. NO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMMAT I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN ARCHULETA. DALY. NO.
MCGUIRE. GROVE. I DON'T KNOW.
AYES 29. NOES EIGHT. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 32 BY
SENATOR DALLI. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1062 BY SENATOR DALLI. AN
ACT RELATING TO ENERGY. SENATOR
DALLI THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1062. CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED
SOME OF THE MOST DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES IN THE RECENT YEARS.
ONE OF THE MAJOR CONTRIBUTING
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO THESE
FIRES WAS YEARS OF FOREST
MANAGEMENT AND BUILD UP OF
EXCESS WOODY BIOMASS TO REDUCE
THE THREAT OF WILDFIRES AND
PROPERLY UTILIZE VALUABLE FUEL
SOURCE. SB 1062 WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
TO CREATE THE BIOMASS TECHNOLOGY
TRANSITION PROGRAM TO FACILITATE
THE CONVERSION OF BIOMASS ENERGY
GENERATION FACILITIES TO THE
NEWER ADVANCED BIOENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES. IN DECEMBER OF
2022, CARB PASSED A RESOLUTION
REGARDING THE 2022 CLIMATE
CHANGE SCOPING PLAN. IN WHICH
THE BOARD RESOLVED THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NON COMBUSTION
AND BIOMASS SOLUTIONS NEED TO BE
PRIORITIZED, AND THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
GOAL OF PRIORITIZING ALTERNATIVE
BIOMASS ENERGY GENERATION
METHODS BY CREATING A GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WOULD ASSIST
PARTICIPATING BIOMASS GENERATION
FACILITIES IN ACQUIRING THE
OFTEN EXPENSIVE ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY GENERATION BIO BIOENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES. THESE TECHNOLOGIES
WILL ENABLE THESE FACILITIES TO
CONTINUE USING BIOMASS AS A
VALUABLE FUEL SOURCE, WHILE
REDUCING EMISSIONS AND REMAINING
CONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA
REGULATIONS. AS PART OF THE
PROGRAM, THE PARTICIPATING
FACILITIES MUST DEVELOP BUSINESS
PLANS TO INCORPORATE THE
TECHNOLOGIES ONCE THEY BECOME
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE AND
VIABLE. THE BUSINESS PLANS
PROVIDE THE FACILITIES WITH
FLEXIBLE NEEDED, THE FLEXIBILITY
NEEDED TO PROPERLY ON BOARD THE
NEW TECHNOLOGIES, ENSURE THAT AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS OF THESE SPECIFIC AIR
BASINS, THIS BILL WOULD HELP
KEEP BIOMASS FACILITIES OPEN AND
IN COMPLIANCE WITH CALIFORNIA
REGULATIONS, AND WOULD ENSURE
THAT FOREST HEALTH AND
RESILIENCE IS AN ONGOING
PRIORITY. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS MEASURE?
HEARING. SEEING NONE. AYES 37.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM 33
BY SENATOR GROVE. SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1264 BY SENATOR
GROVE, AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SB 1264, WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE PROVIDE A LIMITED,
ABILITY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO ALLOW SWORN
EMPLOYEES TO BE TESTED FOR
CANNABIS USE. THE BILL IS
NARROWLY DRAWN TO PROVIDE
TARGETED EXEMPTION FOR JUST
THOSE SWORN LAW ENFORCEMENT
APPLICANTS AND EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
UNDERTAKING DIFFICULT DUTIES,
DIRECTLY ASSOCIATED OR RELATED
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS IS THE
SAME EXEMPTION THAT THE BUILDING
TRADES AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
CURRENTLY HAVE IN STATUTE. THE
WORK OF BOTH OF THESE
PROFESSIONS IS IMPORTANT AND HAS
IMPORTANT IMPLICATIONS,
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND RESPONSIBILITY. PEACE
OFFICERS ARE EXPECTED TO
OVERCOME INTENSE PHYSICAL
CHALLENGES AND MAKE SPLIT DESK
SECOND DECISIONS IN LIFE OR
DEATH SITUATIONS, AND THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE GENERALLY
INCOMPATIBLE WITH THE EFFECTS OF
CANNABIS USE. SB 1264 WILL
ENSURE DEPARTMENTS RETAIN THE
ABILITY TO TEST EMPLOYEES FOR
CANNABIS USE TO ENSURE THE
HIGHEST PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS
ARE MET, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 33. ALAN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
BREAKSPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ DALLI.
AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. DURAZZO. AYE TO NO.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. AYE LEMON MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE.
OKUBO AYE. PADILLA. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEGATO
AYE. SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. WIENER. NO WILK. AYE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
BECKER. AYE BRADFORD. GONZALEZ
LIMON. MCGUIRE PADILLA. AYE.
SKINNER NÓ. WAHAB. AYES 30. NOS.
THREE. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 36. SENATOR DURAZZO, SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1447 BY SENATOR
DURAZZO. AN ACT RELATING TO
HOSPITALS. SENATOR DURAZZO,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
ON SB 1447 REGARDING THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL SEISMIC. AND
I WANT TO TAKE THE TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE, MY COLLEAGUES,
SENATOR FROM MERCED AND THE
SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS. THIS IS ABOUT A
PARTICULAR HOSPITAL IN LOS
ANGELES TO PROVIDE AN EXTENSION
FOR CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL LOS
ANGELES IS A PREMIER PEDIATRIC
HOSPITAL PROVIDING CARE FOR SOME
OF THE MOST DIFFICULT PEDIATRIC
CASES IN THE REGION AND THE ONLY
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN THE
REGION. IT HAS BECOME MORE
IMPORTANT SINCE OTHER HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH CARE FACILITIES HAVE
BEGUN CLOSING OR DOWNSIZING
PEDIATRIC CARE UNITS IT
RECEIVES. THE HOSPITAL RECEIVES
REFERRALS FROM OTHER HOSPITALS.
THOSE CASES ARE TAKEN WITHOUT
REGARD TO ABILITY TO PAY.
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL DOES NOT
TURN ANYONE AWAY. IN FACT, 70%
OF THE CHILDREN ARE INSURED BY
MEDI-CAL, YET THEY GET THE
HIGHEST QUALITY MEDICAL
ATTENTION. CHLA HAS MET THE
PRIMARY EARTHQUAKE RETROFIT
STRUCTURAL STANDARDS REQUIRED BY
LAW TO ASSURE THAT ITS
STRUCTURES CAN SURVIVE A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE AND BE FUNCTIONAL.
THE NEXT SET OF RETROFIT
STANDARDS APPLICABLE TO THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ARE AIMED AT
VARIOUS INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS TO ASSURE THAT THE
HOSPITAL AND ITS CAMPUS HAVE
ADEQUATE WATER, SEWER AND POWER
GENERATION, AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
OPERATION OF THE HOSPITAL, FOR A
MINIMUM OF 72 HOURS AFTER AN
EARTHQUAKE WHILE THE HOSPITAL
HAS BEEN WORKING TO BOTH PLAN
FOR AND ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE UPDATES, IT ALSO HAS A
PRIMARY ROLE TO PROVIDE ACUTE
HEALTH CARE FOR THE REGION'S
CHILDREN. AS A RESULT, COMPLYING
WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE HAS
PLACED A SEVERE HARDSHIP ON THE
HOSPITAL, PROVIDING THE
EXTENSION WILL ALLOW FOR BOTH
THE FINANCING PLAN AND THE
CONSTRUCTION TO BE IMPLEMENTED
WHILE THEY CONTINUE TO PROVIDE,
CRITICAL CARE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THE
REMAINING CONCERNS AND I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR JONES? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB 1447, AND I THINK THAT
EXTENDING THE DEADLINE ON
HOSPITAL SEISMIC RETROFITS IS A
GOOD IDEA AND HOPE THAT WE ALL
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT AS
WE MOVE ALONG. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS MATTER? SEEING NONE.
SENATOR DURAZZO, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SO NOTED. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL NÓ. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THIS MEASURE? SEEING NO
OBJECTION? AYES 37, NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES IS. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM M 14 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1072 BY SENATOR PADILLA. AN
ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR PADILLA,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1072, WHICH
CLARIFIES THE EXISTING LAW IN
THE EVENT PROSPECTIVELY, IF A
COURT DETERMINES THAT A FEE OR
CHARGE FOR PROPERTY RELATED
SERVICE, INCLUDING WATER, SEWER
OR REFUSE COLLECTION VIOLATES
PROP TWO, 18, THE REMEDY FOR THE
VIOLATION WOULD BE A CREDIT
TOWARDS THE AMOUNT OF THE FEE OR
CHARGE ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE
VIOLATION. TODAY, RETAIL, WATER
AND WASTEWATER AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE FACING
LEGAL CHALLENGES TO THEIR
SERVICE FEE STRUCTURES. THREE OF
THESE CHALLENGES ARE IN MY
DISTRICT, BUT THE THREAT IS REAL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE THESE
CHALLENGES ARE MOVING THROUGH
THE APPELLATE REVIEW,
CLARIFICATION FOR THE REMEDY,
WHICH IS SEPARATE AND DISTINCT
IN THESE CASES, IN THE LAW, IS
NEEDED TO PROTECT THE SOLVENCY
OF WATER AGENCIES AND WATER
RATES FOR ORDINARY CUSTOMERS.
HIGHER WATER USERS, USERS
BRINGING THESE LAWSUITS ALLEGE
THAT THEY WERE OVERCHARGED BY
THE WATER AGENCIES, AND THAT MAY
ULTIMATELY BE DETERMINED THAT
LOWER WATER USERS SHOULD HAVE
PAID MORE, AND THAT HIGH WATER
USERS SHOULD GET A REFUND. LET'S
BE CLEAR WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT BILLING ERRORS BECAUSE
THEY ARE EXPLICITLY EXCLUDED IN
THIS BILL BECAUSE THEY ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE IN NATURE. WE ARE
NOT ALSO TALKING ABOUT FEES OR
CHARGES WHERE REFUNDS ARE
ALREADY PROVIDED FOR IN STATUTE.
PUBLIC WATER DISTRICTS OFTEN
HAVE NO REVENUE SOURCE OTHER
THAN RATES AND CHARGES. A PUBLIC
AGENCY SETS ITS RATES TO MERELY
RECOVER COSTS ANNUALLY AND
RECEIVES NO PROFIT, SO ANY
REFUNDS TO PAST HIGH WATER USERS
WOULD NEED TO BE FUNDED BY
RAISING RATES ON ALL FUTURE
RATEPAYERS. SB 1072 WOULD
CLARIFY EXISTING LAW THAT IF A
COURT DETERMINES AN EXCESS FEE
HAS BEEN CHARGED, THE AGENCY
MUST CREDIT THE OVERPAYMENT
AMOUNT AGAINST THE OVERALL COSTS
OF PROVIDING THE SERVICE GOING
FORWARD. THIS IS A MATTER OF
EQUITY. SB 1072 ENSURES THAT THE
LOWER WATER USERS ARE NOT
SUBSIDIZING THE OTHERS. IT IS VÌ
VITAL. IT IS VITAL THAT PEOPLE
GET THE MONEY THAT THEY ARE DUE.
IF THEY ARE OVERCHARGED AS A
RESULT OF A BILLING ERROR. WE
MUST ALSO SAFEGUARD EQUITABLE
APPROACHES TO SETTING WATER
RATES WHILE WE PROVIDE OUR
AGENCIES WITH THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT THEY NEED TO OPERATE, AND
SB 1072 ACHIEVES THAT BY
PROVIDING FOR A PROSPECTIVE
REMEDY OF THESE SPECIFIC TYPES
OF CHALLENGES. THE BEARD. THE
BILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF AQUA
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION, CSAC AND MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION, AND
AGENCIES OF ALL SIZES UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. BECAUSE OF THE
RECOGNITION THAT WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE CLARIFICATION, THEY
TOO WILL ENCOUNTER SOME OF THE
SAME ISSUES THESE AGENCIES AND
OTHERS WILL FACE IN THE FUTURE.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING
SEEING NONE SEN. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 14. ALLEN
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA. DALY GROVE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. STURDY NOES FIVE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM
37. WE HAVE SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SHE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. SENATE BILL 954 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. AN ACT
RELATING TO SEXUAL HEALTH.
SENATOR FLORES YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES WE
VOTED THIS VERY SIMILAR BILL OFF
THIS FLOOR LAST YEAR. I'M COMING
BACK WITH YOU ONCE AGAIN NOW
WITH SB 954, TO REQUIRE ALL
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS TO MAKE
INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL CONDOMS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS BY THE
START OF THE 2025 SCHOOL YEAR.
UPON APPROPRIATION TO ADDRESS
THE INCREASE IN STIS AMONGST
THOSE BETWEEN 15 AND 24 YEARS
OLD, IT WOULD REQUIRE A NOTICE
TO BE POSTED INFORMING STUDENTS
OF WHERE TO GET CONDOMS ON
CAMPUS AND WHERE TO FIND SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES. IT
WILL BAR HIGH SCHOOLS FROM
PROHIBITING CONDOM DISTRIBUTION
IN THE CONTEXT OF EDUCATIONAL
AND PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS. AND
FINALLY, IT WILL PROHIBIT
PHARMACIES AND RETAILERS FROM
ASKING FOR PROOF OF AGE PER
CONDOM OR CONTRACEPTIVE
PURCHASES, WHICH IS NOT A LAW
RIGHT NOW. RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 37 ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL NÓ. ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NØ. DODD DURAZZO. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. I'M NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OKUBO
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
GLASER GROVE. NO. MCGUIRE.
GLASER. AYE DODD. AYE. AYES 28.
NOES NINE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ITEM 38 BY SENATOR ROTH. HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1042 BY SENATOR
ROTH. AN ACT RELATING TO
NURSING. SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THIS IS A BILL TO CREATE A
CLINICAL PLACEMENT INVENTORY FOR
NURSING SCHOOLS AND NURSING
STUDENTS, BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE. IT'S AN INVENTORY THAT
WE DESPERATELY NEED IN ORDER TO
PRODUCE MORE TRAINED NURSES IN
THIS STATE. AS YOU WELL KNOW,
FOR DECADES WE'VE SUFFERED FROM
A SHORTAGE OF REGISTERED NURSES
IN CALIFORNIA. IN FACT,
CALIFORNIA RANKS NEAR THE BOTTOM
NUMBER 40 OUT OF 50 STATES IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF NURSES
PER 100,000 PEOPLE. ONE
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO ALL OF
THIS IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
NURSING SCHOOL CAPACITY HAS NOT
BEEN ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH
DEMAND. ONE REPORT REFLECTS THAT
DURING THE 20 2122 SCHOOL YEAR
IN CALIFORNIA, OVER 47,000
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS FOR OUR
NURSING SCHOOL PROGRAMS WERE
TURNED AWAY FOR LACK OF CAPACITY
. Kò IN ADDITION TO MONEY, ONE
MAJOR REASON THAT WE'VE BEEN
UNABLE TO GROW CAPACITY IN OUR
NURSING PROGRAMS IS THE
CHALLENGE OF LOCATING AND
SECURING THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THE
CLINICAL TRAINING REQUIRED TO
OBTAIN A NURSING DEGREE AND A
LICENSE. THIS WAS CONFIRMED BY
THE STATE AUDITOR IN A 2020
AUDIT REPORT ON THE BURN. THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING,
WHERE THE AUDITOR FOUND THAT THE
BOARD LACKED CRITICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LOCATION
AND AVAILABILITY OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS TO MAKE
ENROLLMENT DECISIONS. NOW,
DURING MY THREE YEARS AS CHAIR
OF THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE, WE
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN THE
NURSING EDUCATION AND THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT ISSUE. OTHER
THAN ANECDOTAL INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY NURSING SCHOOL DEANS
AND OTHERS, I WAS UNABLE TO FIND
OUT. THE SOURCE OF THE PROBLEM
WAS THE PLACEMENT SHORTAGE
CAUSED BY THE FACT THAT NURSING
SCHOOLS AND IN ANY PARTICULAR
REGION WERE ALL TRYING TO PLACE
STUDENTS AT THE SAME TYPE OF
HOSPITAL. WAS IT BECAUSE NURSING
SCHOOLS WEREN'T ATTEMPTING TO
UTILIZE CLINICS, OUTPATIENT
SURGERY FACILITIES, OR OTHER
SIMILAR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
FOR PLACEMENTS? WAS IT BECAUSE
THOSE COMPLAINING OF A LACK OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS WERE
ALL TRYING TO FIT INTO A MONDAY
THROUGH FRIDAY, 8 TO 5 SCHEDULE?
NO. ONE, ABSOLUTELY NO ONE
REALLY KNEW THE ANSWER. AND
THAT'S THE REASON FOR THIS BILL.
WE NEED A NURSING CLINICAL
PLACEMENT INVENTORY IN THE
STATE, AN INVENTORY OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS, SLOTS, NÓ NOT
ONLY LOCATED IN OUR HOSPITALS,
BUT SLOTS LOCATED IN OTHER
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
CLINICS AS WELL. AND THE WAY THE
BILL WORKS TO COLLECT CLINICAL
PLACEMENT DATA. IS THIS AT THE
END OF EACH YEAR, NURSING
SCHOOLS, PUBLIC AND PRIVATE, ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT TO THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING ONE. THE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS NEEDED
FOR THE FOLLOWING ACADEMIC YEAR
AND TWO THE NUMBER OF CLINICAL
SLOTS THE BOARD OR THE SCHOOLS
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO FILL WITHIN
THE LAST ACADEMIC YEAR UNDER
THIS BILL. WITH RESPECT TO
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
CLINICS, THOSE FACILITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND INFORMATION.
HCAI THE ESTIMATED NUMBER OF
DAYS AND SLOTS THAT WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE FOLLOWING
CALENDAR YEAR FOR NURSING
STUDENT USE FOR EACH TYPE OF
LICENSED BED OR UNIT. MED SURG
MATERNAL K¾T AND THE LIKE ONE
TWO. THE NUMBER OF DAYS AND
SHIFTS UTILIZED WITHIN THE
PREVIOUS CALENDAR YEAR BY
LICENSED BETTER UNIT AND THE
NURSING SCHOOL PROGRAM USING
UTILIZING THE SLOTS, THE BOARD
PROVIDES ITS SCHOOL DATA TO HCAI
AND HCAI CORRELATES THAT DATA
WITHIN THE DATA HCAI RECEIVES
FROM THE HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
AND CLINIC, AND POSTED ALL ON
THE HCAI WEBSITE AVAILABLE TO
ALL NURSING SCHOOLS, PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE. SO HOW IS THE DATA
UTILIZED? ANY SCHOOL, PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE, MAY USE THE DATA TO
SECURE ADDITIONAL CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS FROM HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND CLINICS, IF ANY
SCHOOL, PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
REQUESTS HELP FOR THE BURN. THE
BOARD MAY, BUT IT IS NOT
REQUIRED TO HELP IF IT HAS
EXISTING RESOURCES TO DO SO. IT
MAY, AND IT MAY ASSIST THE
SCHOOL BY REVIEWING THE REPORTED
AND UNUSED CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS IN AN ATTEMPT TO IDENTIFY
THOSE THAT MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
SCHOOL. NOW, THIS IS A POINT OF
SOME CONTENTION. THE BILL
PRIORITIZES, ALLOWS THE BOARD TO
PRIORITIZE THE REQUESTS SO IF
THE BOARD RECEIVES MULTIPLE
REQUESTS FOR ASSIST FROM US OR
FOR ASSISTANCE FROM PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS, THE BOARD HAS
TO TRIAGE THE REQUESTS AND FIRST
ADDRESS THE REQUESTS, NOT
PRIORITIZE PLACEMENTS, BUT
ADDRESS THE REQUESTS FOR
ASSISTANCE RECEIVED FROM OUR
PUBLIC COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND CSU
NURSING SCHOOL PROGRAMS. BUT IS
ALSO REQUIRED TO ADDRESS
REQUESTS RECEIVED FROM PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. AND THE REASON FOR THAT
IS DURING THE THREE YEARS I
CHAIRED THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE, THE BULK
OF THE COMPLAINTS WERE COMING
OUT OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE NURSING
PROGRAMS, NOT THE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS. THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS
WANTED ADDITIONAL PLACEMENTS TO
EXPAND THEIR PROGRAMS. THEY WERE
NOT COMPLAINING THAT THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO ADMIT THE
STUDENTS, THAT THEY HAD ADMITTED
FOR THEIR PROGRAMS. SO SO, ONE
OTHER POINT THE BOARD HAS NO
AUTHORITY OVER HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. LET ME MAKE THAT
CLEAR. SO IF THE BOARD ELECTS TO
WORK WITH THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY, THAT'S FINE. BUT THE
HEALTH CARE FACILITY OR CLINIC
INVOLVED MAY ELECT, BUT IS NOT
REQUIRED TO MAKE THOSE EXISTING
OR NEW. BUT UNUSED CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS AVAILABLE TO ANY
NURSING SCHOOL. IT'S PERMISSIVE
ON THE PART OF THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IN THIS BILL. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS NOT TO DISPLACE
ANY STUDENTS, NOT TO SHIFT
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS FROM
ONE SCHOOL TO ANOTHER SCHOOL.
THE INTENT IS TO IDENTIFY NEW
AND UNUSED CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS, AGAIN, NOT TO SUPPLANT OR
SWAP OUT ONE SCHOOL FOR ANOTHER.
NO EXISTING CLINICAL PLACEMENT
ARRANGEMENTS BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES ARE TO BE
DISRUPTED. UNDER THE TERMS OF
THIS BILL. IN FACT, THE BILL
PROVIDES AT THE PROPOSED HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE SECTION ONE,
27752D IN THE BILL. ANY ATTEMPT
TO CREATE OR SECURE ADDITIONAL
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS BY THE
BOARD, A HEALTH FACILITY OR A
CLINIC SHALL NOT SUPPLANT OR
DISRUPT THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT
OF ANY NURSING STUDENT FOR WHOM
A CLINICAL PLACEMENT IS ALREADY
IN PROGRESS OR HAS ALREADY BEEN
SCHEDULED. I CAN ADDRESS SOME OF
THE COMMENTS OF THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL, BUT I
THINK I'LL WAIT FOR QUESTIONS.
MR. PRESIDENT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK, BUT NOT FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
JONES? THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, MEMBERS, I AM REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH SB 1042 BECAUSE
I UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM THAT
EXISTS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS HERE. I I'M JUST HAVING
SOME CHALLENGES WITH THE DETAILS
OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL. THE, IT
I BELIEVE IT FAILS TO ADDRESS
THE LARGER PROBLEM OF THE
SHORTAGE OF THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS FOR SCHOOL NURSING
STUDENTS. I THINK IT WOULD BE
BETTER IF, WELL, HERE'S THE
QUESTION. IS IT THE PROPER ROLE
OF THIS BUREAU AND THE
GOVERNMENT TO PICK WHERE THESE
SLOTS GO AND WHICH SCHOOL HAS,
FIRST ACCESS TO THEM RATHER THAN
SHOULD WE BE DISCUSSING TODAY,
INCENTIVIZING AND CREATING MORE
SLOTS AND OR REMOVING BARRIERS,
WHATEVER REGULATORY BARRIERS ARE
IN PLACE CURRENTLY THAT ARE
CREATING, PREVENTING THESE SLOTS
FROM BEING CREATED. AND, YOU
KNOW, I THINK ONE OF THE THIS
MAY OR MAY NOT BE RELATED, BUT,
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE WITNESSING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH NURSING HEALTH
CARE IS TRAVEL NURSES. AND WE
HAVE NURSES THAT ARE TRAVELING
ALL OVER THE STATE BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEING AWARDED BONUSES,
FROM, FOR TRAVELING INTO AND
FILLING POSITIONS IN HOSPITALS
THAT ARE SHORT OF NURSES. BUT
HAVE WE CREATED A SITUATION
WHERE WE HAVE NURSES FROM
SACRAMENTO TRAVELING TO SAN
DIEGO AND RECEIVING BONUSES? AND
DO WE HAVE Ã AND NURSES FROM
SAN DIEGO TRAVELING TO
SACRAMENTO, TO FILL THESE
VACANCIES IN THE NURSE, THE
NURSES THAT WE NEED. THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE AND WE NEED MORE
NURSES IN CALIFORNIA, I DON'T
THINK SO. MY MAIN PROBLEM WITH
THE BILL IS THE LANGUAGE DEALING
WITH WITH PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
AND COLLEGES VERSUS PRIVATE, AND
THEN ONE CONCERN RAISED BY THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
THÀNH. MR. PRESIDENT, IF I MAY
HAVE PERMISSION TO READ, BRIEFLY
, MR. PRESIDENT, MAY I HAVE
PERMISSION TO READ? PERMISSION
GRANTED. THANK YOU. MR.
PRESIDENT, QUOTE FROM THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
THESE PROVISIONS GO BEYOND
SOLVING THE PROBLEM IDENTIFIED
BY THE STATE AUDITOR ARE
DUPLICATIVE OF WORK BEING
ALREADY BEING DONE EFFECTIVELY
THROUGH REGIONAL CONSORTIUMS AND
WOULD INAPPROPRIATELY,
INAPPROPRIATELY URGE THE BRN TO
INTERFERE WITH DECISIONS BY
HEALTH FACILITIES ABOUT HOW MANY
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS THEY
CAN ACCOMMODATE AND WHEN, AS
WELL AS WHAT DEGREE CATEGORY OF
NURSING STUDENTS THEY SHOULD
PRIORITIZE FOR THOSE PLACEMENTS.
END QUOTE I'VE NOTICED ON THE
LIST OF OPPOSITION THAT MOST OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL, HAVE
TALKED ABOUT AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION.
THÀNH MR. PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS,
I'M GOING TO VOTE NO TODAY, BUT
HOPING THAT THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WILL TAKE PLACE. AND, IF IT
COMES BACK ON CONCURRENCE WILL
BE A BETTER BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE.
SENATOR ROTH, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? CERTAINLY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LET ME TRY TO RESPOND
TO THOSE COMMENTS. I, I TRIED TO
COVER IT IN MY PRESENTATION. THE
BOARD HAS NO AUTHORITY OVER
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
ABSOLUTELY OR AT ALL. THE BOARD
IS SIMPLY A FACILITATOR. AND THE
BOARD DOES DEAL WITH THE NURSING
SCHOOLS AND THE NURSING
PROGRAMS. SO THE BOARD WAS
INSERTED IN HERE TO TRY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF
THOSE NURSING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
HAVING DIFFICULTIES SECURING
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS, PRIMARILY
PRIMARILY OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NURSING PROGRAMS, BUT NOT
EXCLUSIVELY SO. THE BOARD
GATHERS THE DATA ABOUT WHAT
SCHOOLS NEED, AND THE BOARD
LOOKS ON THE HCAI WEBSITE TO SEE
WHERE HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
HAVE UNUSED SLOTS AND PROVIDES
THAT INFORMATION TO THE NURSING
SCHOOLS FOR THEIR USE. THE BOARD
MAY CONTACT A HEALTH CARE
FACILITY AND ASK THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IF THOSE WHAT APPEAR TO
BE NEW OR EXISTING UNUSED SLOTS
MAY BE AVAILABLE AND PROVIDES
THAT INFORMATION TO THE SCHOOL,
BUT THE BILL CLEARLY SAYS THAT A
HEALTH CARE FACILITY MAY BUT IS
NOT REQUIRED TO DO ANYTHING. IN
RESPONSE TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING OR REQUEST
FROM A NURSING SCHOOL. SO
HOPEFULLY THAT ADDRESSES THE
CONCERN OF MY COLLEAGUE WITH
RESPECT TO WHETHER WHETHER
HOSPITALS OR HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES ARE GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO DO ANYTHING. I I
NOTE THAT THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES, THE PRIVATES
SAY FUNCTIONALLY THE LANGUAGE
FUNCTIONALLY MANDATES THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING TO
PRIORITIZE MEETING THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT NEEDS OF NURSING
PROGRAMS. NOTHING COULD BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH. WITH
RESPECT TO THIS BILL. THE
PRIVATES HAVE. CERTAINLY, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE SUCCESS RATE AND THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS, THEY HAVE NO
PROBLEM SECURING CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS ANYWHERE,
ANYWHERE, ANY TIME, ANY PLACE,
AT LEAST AS FAR AS I CAN TELL,
THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS FOR
EXAMPLE, WHAT WHAT WHAT HAS COME
OUT IN THE COURSE OF THIS BILL
IS THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS ARE
PREFERRING STUDENTS WHO ARE
ENROLLED IN BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
OF NURSING DEGREE PROGRAMS OVER
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE, ASSOCIATE
DEGREE STUDENTS AND THE
COMMUNITY AND THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS HAVE STATED THAT
ESSENTIALLY IN THEIR OPPOSITION
LETTER, IF YOU HAVE IT IN YOUR
PACKAGE, THAT, OF COURSE, IS THE
PROBLEM I'M TRYING TO ADDRESS
WITH ANOTHER BILL THAT I WILL BE
PRESENTING LATER ON, THE
SHORTAGE OF BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
DEGREE NURSES AND HOW WE DEAL
WITH THAT. THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING TO FORCE THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS TO TAKE ANYONE OTHER
THAN A STUDENT IN A BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE DEGREE NURSING PROGRAM.
IF THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING APPROACHES THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN LOS
ANGELES AND SAYS, HOW ABOUT
TAKING A COMMUNITY, GIVING SOME
PLACEMENT SLOTS TO THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT, NURSING PROGRAMS?
THERE ARE 2 OR 3 OF THEM. THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL CAN SAY,
HEY, THANK YOU FOR CALLING. NO
THANKS. UNDER THIS BILL. SO
HOPEFULLY THAT ADDRESSES THE
CONCERNS. WE DO NEED THE
CLINICAL INVENTORY BECAUSE
OTHERWISE IT'S THE WILD, WILD
WEST OUT THERE IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
PLACEMENT SLOTS ARE, WHICH ONES
ARE AVAILABLE, WHAT REGIONS
THEY'RE IN AND WHO CAN USE THEM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
VOTE ON DEBATE HAVING CEASED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 38 ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NÓ. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. NO. OKUBO
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER ALAN ARCHULETA. MCGUIRE.
CIERTO. AYE. 34 NOS. TO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR, I
WANT TO TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE TO
RECOGNIZE A SPECIAL GUEST HERE
ON THE SENATE FLOOR AND GIVE HIM
A STRONG CALIFORNIA'S SENATE
WELCOME. OUR SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION AND FORMER
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY. NONE OTHER THAN TONY
THURMOND. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS. NEXT UP IS SENATOR FILE
ITEM 39. SENATOR MENGIBAR. SHE
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1057 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR AN AQUILONS JUVENILES.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
APOLOGIZE. THIS IS GOING TO BE A
LITTLE BIT LONG WINDED BECAUSE I
NEED TO MAKE CLEAR WHAT THIS
BILL REALLY DOES AND DOES NOT DO
. SB 1057 SEEKS TO CREATE A MORE
EQUITABLE COMPOSITION OF THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE COORDINATING
COUNCIL. SO THE TOP LINE IS THAT
WE NEED TO INCLUDE THE EXPERTISE
OF THOSE WHO ARE MOST IMPACTED
BY THE SYSTEM AND THOSE WORKING
ALONGSIDE THEM. WITH THE TRAUMA
INFORMED HEALING FOCUSED LENS.
CURRENT STATUTE RIGHT NOW
ALREADY REQUIRES THIS COUNCIL TO
EXIST IN EVERY COUNTY. CURRENT
LAW ALREADY REQUIRES EACH
COUNCIL TO BE MADE UP OF AT
LEAST 30 PEOPLE REPRESENTING THE
DA'S OFFICE, POLICE, PROBATION,
PUBLIC DEFENDERS, PUBLIC HEALTH,
SOCIAL SERVICES AND OTHERS. MY
BILL WOULD CHANGE THE MAKEUP OF
THE MEMBERSHIP, BUT NOT REMOVING
A SINGLE PERSON THAT IS STILL
PART OF THAT COUNCIL. IT
REQUIRES EACH COUNTY TO MAKE
SURE THEIR COUNCILS CONSIST OF
AT LEAST 50% COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES, AND REMOVES THE
MINIMUM MINIMUM 13 MEMBERSHIP
REQUIREMENT, ADDING MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR COUNTIES TO
CHOOSE THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE TO
BE ON THE COUNCIL. OPPOSITION
STATES THAT I AM LOOKING TO ADD
PEOPLE WITH NO DEMONSTRATED
EXPERIENCE OR KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
KEY ISSUES IMPACTING JUSTICE
INVOLVED YOUTH, BUT MY BILL
DEFINES A COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVE AS SOMEONE WHO IS
CURRENTLY OR FORMERLY JUSTICE
SYSTEM INVOLVED A SYSTEM
IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBER OR A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM A NONPROFIT,
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
THAT PROVIDES SERVICES TO YOUTH
MEMBERS. YOU TELL ME HOW IS A
JUVENILE WHO WENT THROUGH THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM NOT AN EXPERT IN
THE TOPICS? THE COUNCIL DEALS
WITH? OPPOSITION STATES THAT THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE COUNCIL TO
MEET THREE TIMES A MONTH AND TO
MAKE THEIR MEETINGS PUBLIC IS
TOO BURDENSOME. BUT MY COUNCILS,
BUT MANY COUNCILS ALREADY ARE
MEETING QUARTERLY, AND THE
COUNCILS ARE SUBJECT TO THE
BROWN ACT, SO THEY MUST MEET IN
PUBLIC. OPPOSITION IS CLAIMING
THIS IS UNION BUSTING AND OR A
JOB KILLER, BUT NOTHING IN MY
BILL REMOVES ANY MEMBER WHO IS
CURRENTLY PART OF THE COUNCIL.
NOTHING IN MY BILL MANDATES
COUNTIES TO CLAW BACK, DEFUND OR
DECREASE ANY FUNDING ATTACHED TO
CURRENT PROGRAMS. IN FACT,
CURRENT LAW ALREADY STATES THAT
IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE VERBATIM
WHAT THE LAW SAYS IN ORDER TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR JUVENILE JUSTICE
GRANTS, EACH COUNTY IS REQUIRED
TO ESTABLISH A MULTI-AGENCY
JUVENILE JUSTICE COORDINATING
COUNCIL THAT DEVELOPS AND
IMPLEMENTS A CONTINUUM OF COUNTY
BASED RESPONSES TO JUVENILE
CRIME, AND I HAVE TAKEN MANY
AMENDMENTS, HAVE MET WITH THE
OPPOSITION OVER A LOT OF TIMES,
AND HAVE TAKEN AMENDMENTS
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE BULK OF
THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS. BUT
THOSE CONCERNS APPARENTLY STILL
EXIST. IT APPEARS THAT THE
OPPOSITION SIMPLY DOES NOT WANT
TO ADD MORE COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES TO THE COUNCIL
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THE STATUS
QUO IS WORKING. HERE ARE A FEW
EXAMPLES OF WHAT CURRENTLY IS
THE STATUS QUO. A 2020 STATE
AUDIT FOUND THAT SOME COUNTIES
DID NOT EVEN HAVE A COUNCIL AT
ALL. SOME COUNTIES HAD VACANCIES
ON THEIR COUNCIL, AND SEVERAL
COUNTIES ONLY MADE LIMITED
REVISIONS TO THEIR PLAN OVER THE
LAST TWO DECADES. DESPITE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN THE
STATEWIDE JUVENILE JUSTICE
LANDSCAPE, RIVERSIDE COUNTY GOT
SUED FOR SPENDING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FUNNELING CHILDREN INTO
AN UNCONNECTED PROBATION SYSTEM
THAT DENIED THEM THEIR DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS AND SUBJECTED
THEM TO OPPRESSIVE, INVASIVE
POLICIES. THEN THEY WERE FORCED,
THROUGH LAWSUITS TO ADD FIVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
JUST LIKE MY BILL IS ASKING.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WAS ALSO SUED
FOR ALLEGATIONS OF CONDUCTING
THEIR WORK IN VIOLATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S OPEN MEETING AND
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION LAWS, KNOWN
AS THE BROWN ACT, AND RESULTED
IN HAVING THEM TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN
THEIR COUNCIL AND ADDING MORE
OPTIONS FOR GREATER
COMMUNICATION, COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION, EVERYTHING MY
BILL IS ASKING TO DO. SO I'M
ASKING YOU, DO WE WANT COUNTIES
TO CONTINUE TO BE SUED AND LOSE
MONEY HAVING TO LITIGATE THESE
LAWSUITS? OR ARE WE ASKING THEM
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
FOLLOWING CURRENT LAW AND
DOUBLING DOWN ON THAT LAW?
YOU'VE HEARD THAT THE STATUS QUO
IS NOT WORKING. COUNTIES ARE
TURNING AWAY YOUTH FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE COUNCILS
BECAUSE, FOR EXAMPLE, THEY ARE
CURRENTLY ON PROBATION. ISN'T
THAT THE VERY SAME TYPE OF
PEOPLE WE NEED TO HEAR FROM? SO
LET'S ADD MORE COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES TO THE COUNCIL.
LET'S HAVE A CO-CHAIR AND ENSURE
THESE MEETINGS ARE PUBLIC TO
ADDRESS THE DEFICIENCIES WE ARE
SEEING ACROSS THE STATE. THIS
WON'T DICTATE HOW COUNTIES SPEND
THEIR THEIR JUVENILE JUSTICE
GRANT FUNDS. IT WON'T TAKE AWAY
ANY FUNDING FROM COUNTIES AND
WON'T MAKE ANY CHANGES TO
PROBATION BUDGETS OR FUNDING
STREAMS. IT WON'T PREVENT
PROBATION PROGRAMS FROM
RECEIVING FUNDS. IT WON'T REMOVE
PROBATION OR ANYONE ELSE FROM
POSITIONS, PROGRAMS OR
PROCESSES. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
ASHBY? THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT SB
1057. I'M SURE I'M NOT THE ONLY
SENATOR IN THE ROOM WHO HAS
RECEIVED A FEW LETTERS ABOUT
THIS BILL. HOWEVER EVEN THOUGH I
HAVE FOLKS LOCALLY WHO HAVE
REACHED OUT TO ME AND HAVE
CONCERNS, I NOTED THAT SOME OF
THE LETTERS ARE DATED PRIOR TO A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO, WHEN THE
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES TOOK
MANY AMENDMENTS TO HER BILL. I
KNOW THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES TO BE EXTREMELY DILIGENT
, AND ALSO TO BE EXCEPTIONALLY
GOOD AT WORKING WITH PEOPLE WHO
HAVE OPPOSITION OR QUESTIONS OR
ISSUES WITH HER BILL. SO I HAVE
A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR. MR.
PRESIDENT, SENIOR MENGIBAR WILL
YOU TAKE A QUESTION TO THE
CHAIR? OKAY THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT, I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE AUTHOR IF SHE WOULD BE
WILLING TO NOT ONLY WORK WITH
OPPOSITION, BUT PARTICULARLY
WITH SPECIFIC COUNTIES THAT HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION
AND ABOUT FUNDING AND ABOUT HOW
THIS PARTICULAR LAW SHOULD MAKE
ITS WAY ALL THE WAY THROUGH AND
WOULD IMPACT THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY CURRENTLY HAVE TO SERVE
YOUTH IN OUR COUNTIES. MR.
PRESIDENT, AS YOU HEARD AND
COLLEAGUES IN MY REMARKS, WE
EVEN WENT FURTHER IN AMENDMENTS
TO EVEN FURTHER CLARIFY THAT
FUNDING WAS STILL EXIST AND
STREAM DOWN TO THE COUNTIES. I
DO, HOWEVER, COMMIT TO CONTINUE
BEING THE SAME KIND OF MEMBER
WHO DOES MEET WITH EVERY SINGLE
OPPOSITION THAT COMES THROUGH
HER DOOR, THAT IT TAKES
AMENDMENTS ON GOOD FAITH,
THINKING THAT THAT WOULD REMOVE
OPPOSITION AND IT DOES NOT. BUT
I WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT.
AND I KNOW IN THE ASSEMBLY I
WILL CONTINUE TO TAKE ON
AMENDMENTS THAT HOPEFULLY WITH
FURTHER DISTANCE, THEIR
OPPOSITION, BUT YES, BOTTOM
LINE, I DO COMMIT TO THAT. THANK
YOU. I JUST WOULD FINISH MY
COMMENTS THEN ON MY OWN TIME BY
SAYING THIS. I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT THIS AUTHOR IS
TRYING VERY HARD TO CLARIFY
EXISTING LAW TO MAKE THINGS
EASIER AND BETTER FOR OUR
COUNTIES AND FOR OUR YOUTH. AND
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I KNOW
THAT SHE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THOSE WHO HAVE QUESTIONS.
SO I'LL BE VOTING. AYE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ALVARADO. GIL
PERMISSION TO ASK A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR? SENATOR MEJORADA,
WILL YOU TAKE A QUESTION? YES
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR, WHO I
KNOW IS A VERY STAUNCH ADVOCATE
FOR YOUTH IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
I HAVE BEEN VERY, SORRY THE
BUZZ, I'VE BEEN I'VE BEEN VERY
HAPPY VÆ TO SEE, BILLS THAT COME
FROM THE AUTHORS DESK. MY
QUESTION IS, IF THIS BILL WERE
TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN SOME OF THE
SMALLER COUNTIES IN THE RURAL
AREAS WHERE OUR POPULATION IS
LESS THAN 30,000, HOW WOULD YOU
SEE THIS IMPACTING THOSE
COUNTIES THAT ARE ALREADY
LOOKING TO AGGREGATE THEIR
SERVICES WITH NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES, AND PERHAPS ARE NOT
ABLE TO MEET THE, REQUIRED
AMOUNTS IN YOUR BILL, EITHER DUE
TO DISTANCE OR SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH
NONPROFITS OR, JUST, OUTSIDE
GROUPS TO BE ABLE TO MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS. HOW WOULD YOU SEE
THAT PLAYING OUT? THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT, TO THE SENATOR FROM
JACKSON, THE SENATOR BRINGS UP A
VERY GOOD POINT, AND IT'S A
CONSIDERATION THAT I HAVE
STARTED WORKING ON BECAUSE I
KNOW IT'S VALID. I KNOW THAT IN
RURAL AREAS THERE ARE EVEN LESS
RESOURCES POTENTIALLY LESS
PEOPLE INTERESTED IN
PARTICIPATING IN THIS. MY
COMMITMENT TO THE SENATOR AND
EVERY OTHER SENATOR HERE IS THAT
WHILE RIGHT NOW I'M ASKING FOR
50, I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO GET TO A
NUMBER WE DON'T KNOW IF ONCE IT
COMES BACK TO THIS BODY, ONCE
AGAIN, ON CONCURRENCE, IF IT
WILL BE AT 50, BECAUSE I WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT'S ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED. THIS BILL IS KIND
OF A CLEAN UP BILL TO WHAT THE
PREVIOUS BILL IT ATTEMPTED TO
DO. AND AFTER THE AUDIT SHOWED
THAT A LOT OF COUNTIES AREN'T
DOING I DON'T WANT TO PASS A
BILL JUST TO PASS A BILL. I WANT
TO MAKE SURE IT'S ACTUALLY BEING
ABLE TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN EVERY
SINGLE COUNTY, JUST LIKE HER
COUNTY. THE SENATOR FROM
JACKSON'S COUNTIES TO MY
COUNTIES IN LA. THANK YOU.
SATISFIED, SENATOR DODD, YES, I
HAVE MY COUNTIES HAD THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT THE SENATOR FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY HAD. AND I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
BASED ON THE COMMENTS, FROM FROM
FROM THE AUTHOR, THERE WAS SOME
OTHER CONCERNS, TOO, THAT I'M
JUST GOING TO POINT OUT, BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW IF THE AMENDMENTS
ALREADY TOOK PLACE AND THE
LETTERS WERE BEFORE. SO I THINK
THAT'S A VERY FAIR COMMENT. BUT,
SOME OF THE REQUIREMENTS WERE
VERY, VERY PRESCRIPTIVE. AND I
THINK THAT THAT MAKES SENSE TO
LOOK AT THAT AS WELL. BUT I WILL
BE GOING UP ON THE BILL. BUT
LOOK, AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU
KNOW, IT'S GOING TO COME BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE AND WE CAN ALL
DECIDE WHERE WE ARE AT THAT
TIME. BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION, DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM, SENATOR LAIRD? I
HAVE GENUINELY BEEN LISTENING TO
THE DEBATE, AND I HAVE GENUINELY
BEEN TORN ON THIS ISSUE. I AM
HEARING FROM MY LOCAL DEPARTMENT
STRONGLY THAT IT'S NOT WORKABLE.
I READ THE FACT SHEET FOR IT. I
READ THE LETTER AGAINST IT, I
TALKED TO THE AUTHOR AND I WAS
CONCERNED THAT IT SEEMS OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE IN SOME PLACES.
I'VE STAFFED COUNTY GROUPS. I'VE
STAFFED LOCAL GROUPS, EVEN DOWN
TO THE POINT THAT IT SAYS
THERE'LL BE EQUAL ONE SIDE AND
EQUAL THE OTHER SIDE, WHERE YOU
ALWAYS HAVE AN ODD NUMBER SO
THAT VOTES ARE BROKEN. WHEN YOU
DO THAT, AND THE IN SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT IT, IT WAS
THAT SOME OF THESE THINGS ARE
ALREADY IN THE LAW, BUT THEY'RE
NOT BEING ENFORCED. SO THEN THEY
GET REITERATED IN THIS BILL WHEN
THEY'RE ALREADY IN THE LAW. AND
IT MIGHT WELL BE AN ENFORCEMENT
ISSUE RATHER THAN A REITERATION
IN THE BILL ISSUE. AND SO THAT'S
WHY I WAS TORN, IS I JUST DIDN'T
FEEL LIKE THIS WAS TOGETHER. AND
THERE'S STRONG CRITICISM FROM MY
DISTRICT, AND I FEEL LIKE I'M
WILLING BEGRUDGINGLY, TO CAST A
YES VOTE. AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT OF THE AUTHOR. BUT
THERE IS AN AMAZING AMOUNT OF
WORK TO BE DONE HERE, AND I
THINK THE REAL ISSUE, BECAUSE
I'VE HEARD FROM OTHER PEOPLE
THAT IT'S GIVING A VOICE TO
THOSE THAT ARE IN THE SYSTEM.
AND I THINK IN SOME WAYS IT'S
BACKING OFF OF SOME OF THE
PRESCRIPTIVENESS AND JUST MAKING
SURE THERE'S A WAY YOU GET THE
VOICE IN THE SYSTEM, RATHER THAN
THINKING IT'S GOING TO COME FROM
SOME SPECIFIC, OVERLY PRESCRIBED
STRUCTURE. SO I HEARD THE
COMMITMENT OF THE AUTHOR, AND I
WOULD JUST OFFER THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S THE DIRECTION IT'S
GOING TO HAVE TO GO TO MAKE THIS
WORK. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM,
HEARING AND SEEING NONE. SENATOR
MEJORADA, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK, THE
SENATORS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
GOING UP ON THIS VOTE THAT I
ORIGINALLY DIDN'T COUNT IN MY
VOTE CARD, I SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT. I ALSO WANT TO
SAY I'VE DONE AN AMAZING AMOUNT,
AMAZINGLY AMOUNT OF WORK. I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THE SENATOR
FROM SANTA CRUZ REFERENCE
ALREADY DOING AMENDMENTS ON
THIS. AND IT DID HAVE AN
ENFORCEMENT POINT, IT DID HAVE
ENFORCEMENT LANGUAGE WHEN I
FIRST STARTED THIS BILL, BUT I
HAD TO REMOVE THAT ENFORCEMENT
LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT WASN'T GOING
TO GET TO THE SENATE FLOOR. YOU
CAN IMAGINE THAT WE START OUR
BILLS OVER EAGER, IF YOU WILL,
AND WE HAVE TO TRIM AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TO GET IT TO THE FINISH
LINE. YOU'RE RIGHT. RIGHT NOW,
THE STATUS QUO, EVEN THOUGH
THERE IS AN ENFORCEMENT TOOL, IS
NOT ACTUALLY BEING ENFORCED BACK
, HAS THE POWER RIGHT NOW TO
WITHHOLD FUNDING FROM EVERY
SINGLE COUNTY WHO IS NOT
FOLLOWING THE LAW RIGHT NOW. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT, WE HAVE YOUTH
IN AREAS LIKE IN LA COUNTY THAT
ARE BEING FORCED TO PARTICIPATE
IN A FIGHT CLUB BY THEIR OWN
PROBATION OFFICERS, WHERE LÀ
PROBATION HAS HAD TO PUT ON
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE 64 OF THEIR
PROBATION OFFICERS. THOSE ARE
THE SAME INDIVIDUALS WHO WE WANT
TO ONLY BE PART OF THESE
COUNCILS. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF WE WANT TO SEE CHANGE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA, WE NEED TO
BRING THOSE OTHER VOICES.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
HESITANCY FROM THE POWER WHEN
THEY'RE FEELING THAT THEIR POWER
IS BEING RESTRICTED OR REMOVED.
IT'S BECAUSE WE NEED TO DO THAT.
WE NEED PEOPLE WHO HAVE LIVED
EXPERIENCES TO BE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION, TO CHANGE THE STATUS
QUO. I 100% COMMIT MYSELF TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COUNTIES, PROBATION AND EVERY
OTHER OPPOSITION TO FIND A
MIDDLE GROUND, BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY, I AM LOOKING TO CHANGE
THE SYSTEM, AND THE SYSTEM IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WANT TO
PUSH BACK. AND I WILL GIVE A
LITTLE, BUT NOT ENTIRELY,
BECAUSE THEN THERE WILL BE NO
CHANGE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ALL. DEBATE
HAVING CEASED, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 39
ALAN ALVARADO GILL NÓ ARCHULETA.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN. WHEN
NØ. NILO. NÓ. OCHOA. BORG NO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO CIERTO. NØ.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBER. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA. DALY NO. GROVE. NO
JONES. MIN NEWMAN. RUBIO AYE.
UMBERG. EYES 26. NOS. EIGHT. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 40. SENATOR
BECKER, YOU'RE PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1060 BY SENATOR BECKER, AN
ACT RELATING TO INSURANCE.
SENATOR BECKER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1060. I
HEAR ALL THE TIME FROM
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE EITHER
LOST INSURANCE OR HAVE INSURANCE
PREMIUMS INCREASED AT EXORBITANT
RATES. AND I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
DO AS WELL. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY FROM THE OUTSET THAT THIS
BILL IS NOT A REPLACEMENT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE,
SUSTAINABLE INSURANCE STRATEGY
OR THE TERRIFIC WORK OF OUR
INSURANCE CHAIR. MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM BALDWIN PARK, WHO WAS
WORKING FOR THREE YEARS TO
STABILIZE OUR INSURANCE MARKETS.
AND WE WILL PART OF THAT WORKING
GROUP TO WORK WITH HER. WE FEEL
THIS BILL IS VERY COMPLEMENTARY
TO THAT EFFORT. THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE CAN ONLY WORK ON
RATING AND PRICES, BUT PRICES
ONLY MATTER IF INSURANCE IS
OFFERED AT ALL. THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE HAS NO AUTHORITY
OVER THE UNDERWRITING MODELS
THAT INFLUENCE THOSE
UNDERWRITING DECISIONS. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
AS SHERIFF SUB TIÂU, I SEE THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE MAKE IN OUR
WILDFIRE RESOURCES. OVER 500
PEOPLE ADDED TO CAL FIRE, THE
LARGEST AERIAL FIREFIGHTING
FORCE IN THE WORLD. NOW THAT WE
HAVE OVER 69 AERIAL VEHICLES,
AS, THE OTHER PARTS OF IT, I
THINK WHAT HAVE NOW BECOME A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY, I ALSO
SEE THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
WE'VE ALLOCATED AT THE STATE
LEVEL, BUT ALSO GET TO SEE WHAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND COUNTIES
HAVE DONE ON HAZARDOUS FUEL
REDUCTION, AS WELL AS COMMUNITY
WIDE HOME HARDENING AND CREATING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE. ALL RECOGNIZED
APPROACHES FOR REDUCING THE
SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES. WITH THIS
BILL IS ABOUT IS ASKING
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT, INTO THEIR
UNDERWRITING MODELS, TELL US IF
THEY'RE SHOWING THAT IT DOESN'T
REDUCE THE RISK, THEN WE SHOULD
PROBABLY BE ALLOCATING THE MONEY
DIFFERENTLY. BUT WE WANT THEM TO
TAKE THIS INTO ACCOUNT IN THEIR
UNDERWRITING MODELS. THAT WAY,
ALL THE INCENTIVES ARE ALIGNED,
THE COMMUNITIES ARE DOING WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO. THE STATE IS
DOING WHAT IT NEEDS TO DO, AND
WE CAN GET BACK ALONG WITH THE
OTHER GREAT WORK BEING DONE BY
OUR INSURANCE CHAIR AND OUR OUR
OUR TEAM HERE TO HAVING A STABLE
INSURANCE MARKET. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. AYE ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI. NØ DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MINH AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO. OCHOA.
BOG. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. CABALLERO JONES. NO.
MCGUIRE. AYES 28. NO EIGHT. THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS. BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM, I
JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE FORMER CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEN COOLEY
UP IN THE GALLERY. FORMER RULES
CHAIR. WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. AND I ALSO SAW
ADAM GRAY AS WELL, FORMER
ASSEMBLYMAN ADAM GRAY UP IN THE
GALLERY AS WELL. SO WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
NEXT MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 41 BY SENATOR LAIRD.
HE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ SENATE BILL 1064 BY
SENATOR LAIRD, AN ACT RELATING
TO CANNABIS. SENATOR LAIRD,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR.
PRESIDENT. SENATE BILL 1064 AIMS
TO MODERNIZE THE STATE'S
CANNABIS LICENSING PROCESS BY
CLARIFYING THE ROLES OF STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
LICENSING AND OVERSIGHT,
ELIMINATING DUPLICATION OF
EFFORTS, AND REDUCING REGULATORY
BURDENS WHILE MAINTAINING THE
OVERSIGHT. RECENT AMENDMENTS
COMING OUT OF APPROPRIATIONS
ADDRESSED DRAFTING ERRORS AND
DELAY THE BILL'S IMPLEMENTATION
TO 2028 TO SAVE COSTS IN THE
LATEST ANNUAL REPORT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL,
HERE ARE THE FOLLOWING.
LICENSING, PROCESSING TIMES.
CULTIVATION 221 DAYS.
MANUFACTURING 180 DAYS.
DISTRIBUTION 287 DAYS. TESTING
LABORATORY THREE 851 DAYS.
RETAIL LICENSES 183 DAYS.
MICROBIAL BUSINESS 244 DAYS.
EVENT ORGANIZER 153 DAYS.
TEMPORARY CANNABIS EVENT 59
DAYS. THIS IS JUST NOT WORKING
AND IT'S OUR GOAL THAT THESE
TIMES BE REDUCED WHILE
MAINTAINING MONNING THE
OVERSIGHT AND THE REGULATORY
PROCESS. QUESTIONS THAT ARE
ANSWERED UNDER CURRENT LAW.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT ROLES
IN LICENSING AND OVERSIGHT ARE
NOT WELL DEFINED AND
DISTINGUISHED. AS A RESULT, THE
LICENSING REVIEWS CONDUCTED
OFTEN DUPLICATE THE REVIEWS
CONDUCTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THIS WILL CLARIFY THE STATE AND
LOCAL ROLES. THE LICENSING
REFORM FRAMEWORK WITHIN THIS
BILL WAS DEVELOPED FROM
RECOMMENDATIONS WITHIN THE
RECENT CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
REPORT. LICENSING AND MARKET
ACCESS PUBLISHED BY THE CANNABIS
POLICY LAB. THERE IS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. THERE
HAVE BEEN NO NO VOTES. WE'VE
BEEN TALKING TO VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THIS BILL
DOESN'T HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND IF ANY
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS ARISE, I
PLEDGE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO RESOLVE THEM. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 41. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
NILO AYE. OCHOA BORG AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SATO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYES STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
HURTADO. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
NGUYEN RUBIO. WE'RE NOW LOOKING
FOR HURTADO.
AYES 34. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 42.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SHE'S
PREPARED. SENATOR, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1067 BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AND AQUILINO
TO HEALING ARTS. SENATOR FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU. MEMBERS AND GRAB THE RIGHT
FORM HERE, GOOD AFTERNOON. I AM
PRESENTING SB 1067. THAT WOULD
CREATE AN EXPEDITED LICENSURE
PROCESS AT THE HEALING ARTS
BOARD FOR PRACTITIONERS WHO PLAN
TO WORK IN MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. I HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THE BILL IN
THE SCOPE. AND NOW THE BILL WILL
FOCUS PRIMARILY ON INCLUDING THE
DENTAL BOARD, THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES, AND THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING.
DESPITE SERVING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES LIKE
THOSE IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES, MANY
PROVIDERS HAVE REPORTED HIGH
VACANCY RATES AND PROLONGED
PERIODS TO FILL STAFF VACANCIES
FOR KEY POSITIONS LIKE
PHYSICIANS, DENTISTS, NURSES,
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND OUR
DEEPENING HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE.
SHORTAGE SURGES. EXPEDITING
LICENSES FOR PRACTITIONERS WHO
PLAN TO SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IS A
VALUABLE INCENTIVE TO WORK IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THEM.
THE MOST RECENTLY, THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA ESTABLISHED
THEIR OWN PROCESS TO EXPEDITE
LICENSE APPLICATIONS FOR
PRACTITIONERS SERVING IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS, AND
SB 1067 IS MODELED AFTER THIS
PROCESS TO DIRECTLY BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES WITH A
HIGH NEED OF ACCESSING OF
NEEDING TO ACCESS QUALITY HEALTH
CARE. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 42. ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE. DALLI.
DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO JONES. NO.
LAIRD. AYE LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. BORG.
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN ARCHULETA.
CABALLERO. AYE DALLY. AYE.
HURTADO MCGUIRE. NGUYEN. DIALLO.
JONES. NO TO. AYE GROVE. NO TO.
AYE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
HURTADO. MCGUIRE. NGUYEN NILO. I
THOUGHT IT WAS GONZALEZ.
AYES 34. NØ ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SENATE RULE 55 WILL BE SUSPENDED
TO ALLOW GUESTS ON THE FLOOR.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 43. SENATOR MENGIBAR,
SHE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ SENATE BILL 1079 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR, AN ACT
RELATING TO THE YOUTH HOUSING
BOND ACT OF 2024, BY PROVIDING
THE FUNDS NECESSARY THEREFOR
THROUGH AN ELECTION FOR THE
ISSUANCE AND SALE OF BONDS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND FOR
THE HANDLING AND DISPOSITION OF
THOSE FUNDS, AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. APOLOGIZE FOR THE LONG
TITLE THERE IN 2023. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. 2023 CALIFORNIA
COUNTED 10,173 YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ON
THEIR OWN, AND ANOTHER 2219 WHO
WERE HOMELESS AND PARENTING ON
THEIR OWN. THOSE NUMBERS PUT THE
STATE IN FIRST PLACE FOR YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS, ACCOUNTING FOR 29%
OF ALL CASES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
SB 1079 WOULD ESTABLISH THE
YOUTH HOUSING BOND ACT OF 2024
BY CREATING A DEDICATED FUNDING
SOURCE FOR YOUTH HOUSING
PROJECTS. SB 1079 WILL HELP TO
COMBAT HOUSING INSECURITY FOR
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH ONE OUT OF
FOUR FOSTER YOUTH WHO LEAVE
EXTENDED CARE WILL EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS. 50% OF CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS POPULATION CAN HAVE
THEIR FIRST EXPERIENCE OF
HOMELESSNESS WHEN THEY WERE
UNDER THE AGE OF 25. THEREFORE,
HOPEFULLY UPON APPROVAL OF THE
VOTERS IT WOULD ALLOCATE THIS
BILL, WOULD ALLOCATE WILL HELP
ALLOCATE $1 BILLION IN GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND SALES. IT WILL
ALLOW BOTH PUBLIC AND COMMUNITY,
BOTH PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WITH SPECIFIC YOUTH EXPERTISE TO
APPLY FOR THE YOUTH BOND.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HEARING
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ADAM ALVARADO.
GILL. ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLI. NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO
JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LEMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA. BOGUE AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. SUGIARTO NO.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA
HURTADO. AYE. MCGUIRE RUBIO. AYE
. AYES 29. NO. SEVEN. ON THE
URGENCY. AYES 29. NOES SEVEN ON
THE MEASURE. MEASURE PASSES.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 49 BY SENATOR LAIRD.
HE HAS PREPARED SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ SENATE BILL 1205 BY
SENATOR LAIRD, AN ACT RELATING
TO WORKER'S COMPENSATION.
SENATOR LAIRD, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. A SENATE
BILL 1205 WILL GUARANTEE WORKERS
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE FOR ON
THE JOB INJURIES BY PROHIBITING
EMPLOYERS FROM RETALIATING
AGAINST WORKERS WHO MUST RECEIVE
MEDICAL CARE DURING BUSINESS
HOURS. AMENDMENTS TO AN
APPROPRIATION LIMIT THE
EXTENSION OF EXISTING TEMPORARY
DISABILITY BENEFITS TO EMPLOYEES
WITH OCCUPATIONAL INJURIES WHO
MUST WORK FOR MEDICAL CARE, AND
WHO HAVE ALREADY, EXHAUSTED,
EARNED SICK LEAVE UNDER THE
LABOR AND EDUCATION CODE.
CURRENTLY, EMPLOYEES WITH
OCCUPATIONAL INJURIES WHO SEEK
EMPLOYER REQUESTED MEDICAL CARE
ARE ENTITLED TO TEMPORARY
DISABILITY BENEFITS, BUT THE
SAME ENTITLEMENT DOES NOT EXTEND
TO EMPLOYEES WITH OCCUPATIONAL
INJURIES WHO MUST SEEK CARE ON
THEIR OWN, IN THESE CASES, A
DECISION EVEN ALLOWS EMPLOYERS
TO DENY INJURED WORKERS THE
RIGHT TO USE THEIR EARNED SICK
LEAVE. OPPOSITION HAS CONCERNS
ABOUT TEMPORARY DISABILITY, AS
PART OF THIS BILL AND THE COSTS
AND THE NECESSITY OF THE BILL,
THEY'VE SENT US LANGUAGE THAT
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS, BUT WE
STILL HAVE SOME OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM. THIS PROTECTS
INJURED WORKERS BY ENSURING THAT
THEY CAN ACCESS TIMELY MEDICAL
CARE WITHOUT RETALIATION FOR
THEIR OCCUPATIONAL INJURIES. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM 49. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
AYE Ã. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MINH AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO. OKUBO.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA.
BECKER AYE. EGGMAN. AYE MCGUIRE.
AYES 28. NOES EIGHT. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 57
BY SENATOR STERN. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. SENATE BILL 1508 BY
SENATOR STERN. AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTRICITY. SENATOR STERN,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TAKES A CLOSER LOOK
AND MORE EXPANSIVE MODELING,
LOOKING AT TECHNOLOGIES THAT
INVOLVE LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE. LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE ARE NOT THE KIND OF
SHORT TERM BATTERIES THAT WE
RELY ON FOR OUR GRID RIGHT NOW.
BUT MULTI-DAY ENERGY STORAGE
FLOW BATTERIES, COMPRESSED AIR
STORAGE, NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
ION AIR AND EVEN PUMPED HYDRO
THESE ARE ALL FERM ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES THAT WE BELIEVE WILL
NOT ONLY STABILIZE OUR GRID AND
LEAVE THE LIGHTS ON, BUT ALSO
DISPLACE FOSSIL FUEL GENERATION.
US DOE AND THE CEC HAVE BOTH
FUNDED THESE EFFORTS, AND WE
THINK WE CAN NOT JUST GET BETTER
MODELING, BUT HOPEFULLY GET SOME
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO TAKE PRESSURE
OFF RATEPAYERS AND KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON. THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY IN
OPPOSITION AND HAVE SINCE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION. SO WE
HAVE ALL THOSE CONFIRMATIONS IN
WRITING, AND I JUST WANT TO
STATE THAT THE OPPOSITION IS OFF
THIS BILL. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 57 ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER I BLAKE
SPEAR. I BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DEL.
NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO CIERTO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE STERN. AYE. UMMAT AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA. MCGUIRE RUBIO.
AYE AYE. LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ONE MORE TIME. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA. MCGUIRE WILK. NO AYES
29, NOES EIGHT. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE. ITEM 58. IS
THE AUTHOR PREPARED? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1509 BY
SENATOR STERN. AN ACT RELATING
TO VEHICLES. SENATOR, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. AYE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS SB 1509
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF EXTREME
SPEEDING THAT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING,
WORKING PEOPLE, COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND EVERYONE WHO HAS TO
WALK, RIDE A BIKE, WAIT AT A BUS
STOP. EVERYONE KNOWS SOMEONE IN
THEIR COMMUNITY WHO'S BEEN
KILLED BY EXTREME SPEEDERS, AND
THIS BILL HOPEFULLY BEGINS TO
CHIP AWAY AT THAT ISSUE, IN A
MANNER THAT ATTACKS ONLY THE
MOST EXCESSIVE, THE BILL WAS
AMENDED THANKS TO THE
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR'S GOOD WORK
ON THIS. THIS BILL THAT, ONLY
ROADS THAT ARE 55 MILES AN HOUR
AND UNDER. SO NOT FREEWAYS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SURFACE
STREETS AND SOME HIGHWAYS WHERE
YOU ARE TRAVELING 26 MILES AN
HOUR OR OVER WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO, POINTS ON YOUR RECORD, TWO
POINTS, BASICALLY ANALOGOUS TO
WHAT YOU'D GET FOR RECKLESS
DRIVING CHARGE. THE DIFFERENCE
IS YOU WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO
IMPRISONMENT LIKE YOU ARE UNDER
CURRENT RECKLESS DRIVING. SO
THIS WOULD JUST BE AN INFRACTION
THANKS TO AMENDMENTS IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE, LAST
WEEK IN PASADENA, FOR EXAMPLE, A
DRIVER WAS SPEEDING JUST UNDER
100 MILES AN HOUR IN A 35 MILE
AN HOUR ZONE, KILLED THREE
PEOPLE, INJURED THREE MORE. BUT
BECAUSE HE WASN'T GOING OVER 100
IS NOT CONSIDERED RECKLESS
DRIVING. IF THEY HADN'T KILLED
THOSE PEOPLE, YOU JUST GET A
SPEEDING TICKET AND MOVE ON WITH
YOUR DAY. WE FEEL THAT THAT'S
UNJUST, NOT JUST TO THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN INJURED, BUT TO
EVERYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO JUST
GET DOWN THE STREET, WALK THEIR
KIDS TO SCHOOL WITHOUT PUTTING
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE, IN
TERMS OF THE EQUITY FOCUS OF
THIS BILL, WE'VE BEEN RELYING ON
A RECENT STUDY FROM UCLA. THE
TITLE OF THE STUDY IS
PRIORITIZING BLACK LIVES IN LA'S
TRAFFIC SAFETY EFFORTS. AND IN
THIS STUDY, IT NOTES THAT SPEED
RELATED DEATHS ARE 28% HIGHER
AND COMMERCIAL VEHICLE DEATHS
ARE IN FACT 82% HIGHER. IN
COMMUNITIES WITH AN AVERAGE
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF $50,000 OR
LESS. SO THIS IS MAKE NO
MISTAKE, THIS IS NOT A WEALTHY
PERSON ISSUE. AND THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT MALIBU, BLACK
ANGELENOS, FOR EXAMPLE, MAKE UP
ONLY 8% OF LA'S POPULATION, BUT
ARE 22% OF PEDESTRIAN FATALITIES
AND 20% OF BICYCLE FATALITIES.
SO WE FEEL STRONGLY AS DO
ADVOCATES ACROSS THIS STATE,
THAT NOW IS THE TIME TO MAKE A
CHANGE AND SAY, NOT IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'VE LIMITED COSTS
TO DMV AS THEY GO THROUGH THEIR
OVERHAUL, SO THIS WON'T REQUIRE
A WHOLE IT PROJECT TO GET IT
DONE. PROUD TO HAVE A BROAD
COALITION OF SUPPORT AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
NEIL? THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS, I AM A COAUTHOR OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE I HAVE VERY STRONG
FEELINGS ABOUT WHAT I PERSONALLY
AM OBSERVING ON OUR ROADS THESE
DAYS, PARTICULARLY SINCE THE
PANDEMIC DRIVING HABITS WERE
DEVELOPED, WERE CHANGED FOR A
LOT OF DRIVERS OUT THERE WHEN
THERE WEREN'T ANY CARS ON THE
ROAD. SO THE CARS COME BACK ON
THE ROAD AND THOSE HABITS DON'T
CHANGE, AND THE SPEEDING THAT I
OBSERVE, THE WEAVING IN AND OUT
OF LANES, THAT I OBSERVE THE
RUNNING OF RED LIGHTS. I SAW ONE
JUST THIS MORNING. IN FACT,
FRANKLY, IT REALLY IRRITATES ME.
AND WE NEED MORE ENFORCEMENT AND
CONSEQUENCES. THAT'S WHY I HAVE
NOT SUPPORTED THE MEASURES THAT
HAVE THAT, THAT HAVE, THAT USE
TRAFFIC CAMERAS AND ISSUE
TICKETS, BUT NO CONSEQUENCE
OTHER THAN THE TICKET THAT'S NOT
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR. I WANT
PEOPLE TO FEEL FINANCIAL PAIN
FOR BREAKING LAWS IN THE BLATANT
WAY THAT WE DO. AND I HAVE TO
SHARE A HEARTWARMING EXPERIENCE
I HAD THAT I RELATED AT A PRESS
CONFERENCE. ORGANIZED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES. I
WAS I CAME OUT ON THE FREEWAY
AND A CAR PASSED ME, ON MY LEFT,
ACCELERATING FROM BEHIND AND
KEPT ON ACCELERATING AND
DISAPPEARED. AND I CAME UP TO IT
A COUPLE OF MILES DOWN THE ROAD.
IT WAS ON THE SIDE WITH A POLICE
CAR, WRITING OUT A TICKET. JUST
WARMED MY HEART. WE NEED TO SEE
MORE OF THAT. AND THIS BILL
OFFERS REAL CONSEQUENCE, I URGE,
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR DURAZO, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, OF COURSE, I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR AND OTHERS WHO
EXPRESSED EXTREME CONCERN OVER
THE DANGERS OF SPEEDING. I JUST
WANT TO REMIND US THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FOR SOME PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD AN ATTORNEY TO DEFEND
THEM, THE CONSEQUENCES CLEARLY
WOULD BE LOSING YOUR JOB, LOSING
YOUR LIVELIHOOD. IF YOU'RE A
DRIVER, PROFESSIONAL TRUCK
DRIVER, OR OTHER KIND OF DRIVER.
IT ALSO WOULD HAVE AN ENORMOUS
IMPACT ON ON THE PURCHASE OF
INSURANCE, CAR INSURANCE, IF
IT'S DIFFICULT. NOW IMAGINE WITH
THIS. SO, WHILE I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR'S INTENTION OF
BRINGING THIS TO LIGHT IN A MUCH
MORE SERIOUS WAY, THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE FAR MORE
SERIOUS WHEN IT COMES TO A
FAMILY TRYING TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES. THEN I THINK WHAT
MOST OF US WOULD FACE THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SENATOR
SATO, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. I'M ALSO A COAUTHOR
ON THE BILL, THE REASON I
SUPPORT THIS BILL IS BECAUSE
THIS WILL ULTIMATELY, MAKE
PEOPLE THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WHEN THEY'RE OUT THERE Ã
26 MILES AN HOUR OVER THE SPEED
LIMIT IN A RESIDENTIAL AREA OR A
FEEDER TO A RESIDENTIAL AREA IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU DO
PASSIVELY. THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE DOING AGGRESSIVELY.
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU ARE WELL
AWARE OF. HOW FAST YOU ARE GOING
DOWN A STREET WHEN YOU'RE GOING
26 OR 25, 26 MILES AN HOUR OR
ABOVE OVER THE SPEED LIMIT. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS THIS TARGETS
THOSE FOLKS. AND AS FAR AS
CONSEQUENCES AS TO HAVING TWO
POINTS ON YOUR YOUR RECORD, THAT
IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT YOU NEED
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION WHEN
YOU'RE GOING TO BE THAT
IRRESPONSIBLE, WHEN I HAD MY
CLASS A LICENSE FOR DRIVING A
FIRE ENGINE AND A AND A TRUCK, I
HAD A I HAD THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO DRIVE WITH
OVER A 0.04 BLOOD ALCOHOL, WHICH
TOLD ME I WOULDN'T EVEN HAVE A
BEER WHEN I WENT OUT BECAUSE
THERE WERE SEVERE CONSEQUENCES
IF I DID. AND SO THIS IS ABOUT
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY. THIS
BILL TARGETS PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
TAKING THAT RESPONSIBILITY. IN A
IN A SERIOUS MANNER. AND AND SO
I THINK IT'LL MAKE AN IMPACT. I
THINK IT'LL GIVE THE POLICE A
BREAK ON HAVING TO WATCH THE
SAME PEOPLE OVER AND OVER AS
THEY CONTINUE TO SPEED, BECAUSE
ALL THEY DO IS GET A, A SPEEDING
TICKET, AND SOME OF THEM CAN
AFFORD TO DO THAT AND THEY JUST
PAY IT. BUT WHEN YOU START
FEELING THE CONSEQUENCES OF YOUR
INSURANCE AND THOSE OTHER
THINGS, MAYBE YOU'LL SLOW DOWN
AND MAYBE YOU'LL SAVE SOME
LIVES. SO THAT'S WHY I'M
SUPPORTING THIS. I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR BRINGING IT UP. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OH, I'M. I'M SORRY. YOU THE
RIGHT TO CLOSE. SENATOR STERN,
PLEASE CLOSE. SORRY I'LL MAKE A
BRIEF. I JUST WANT TO APPRECIATE
MY AUTHOR FROM THE EAST SIDE OF
LA ON HER CONCERNS AND, YOU
KNOW, I TRUCK DRIVING, SCHOOL
BUS DRIVING, METRO DRIVING.
THESE ARE THESE ARE HARD JOBS.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO PUT PEOPLE
OUT OF WORK FOR SURE, I HOPE
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT HAVE TO
BE ENFORCED FOR SCHOOL BUS
DRIVERS WHO ARE ON THEIR OFF
TIME, OR DRIVING 65 MILES AN
HOUR AND A 25, WE. AND IF THEY
ARE, THEY SHOULDN'T BE DRIVING A
SCHOOL BUS, THEY SHOULDN'T BE
DRIVING A TRUCK, WE THINK THAT
THE TRAINING OUT THERE,
ESPECIALLY FOR COMMERCIAL
DRIVERS, IS, IS SO CENTRAL TO
THEIR PROFESSION, AND THEY TAKE
IT SO SERIOUSLY THAT THIS,
THOSE, THOSE SORT OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES REALLY WON'T COME
TO BEAR, BECAUSE THEIR UNIONS,
THEIR AGENCIES WILL HELP MAKE
CLEAR TO THEM THAT, YES, IF
YOU'RE, IF YOU'RE, YOU KNOW,
GOING 70 MILES AN HOUR ON A
SURFACE STREET, YOU COULD LOSE
YOUR LICENSE, SO, SO WE HOPE
THAT THOSE CONSEQUENCES DON'T
HAVE TO BE BORNE, BUT LOOK, IF
THEY DO IN THOSE CASES, I HATE
TO SAY IT, BUT YOU SHOULDN'T BE
DRIVING MY KID TO SCHOOL ANYMORE
OR OTHERS, SO I'M HOPING WE CAN
WORK THROUGH THOSE ISSUES,
THOUGH. IN THE NEXT HOUSE. I
DON'T WANT TO BE SO HARD NOSED
TO SAY THERE'S NO WIGGLE ROOM
THIS IS CURRENTLY 26 MILES AN
HOUR OR OVER, WE'RE OPEN TO
CHANGES. THE CHANGES OFFERED IN
COMMITTEE WERE TO SAY YOU HAVE
TO BE GOING 50 MILES AN HOUR
OVER THE SPEED LIMIT. THAT WAS
TOO MUCH FOR US, BUT WE'RE
HOPING TO LAND THAT ISSUE. SO
ANYHOW, I'M HOPING YOU GUYS CAN
ALL KEEP THIS BILL MOVING TODAY
AND WE CAN MAKE THE STREETS
SAFER IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 58. ALAN ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA ASHBY. ATKINS
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD
I. CABALLERO CORTEZ I. DALY DODD
I. DURAZZO EGGMAN I GLASER. I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES. NÓ. LAIRD I LEMON I
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN. NILO I OKUBO. PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
CIERTO I SKINNER. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
WIENER I WILK I. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN ARCHULETA
ASHBY ATKINS I BECKER. CABALLERO
I DALY. DURAZZO GROVE. MCGUIRE
NGUYEN. OKUBO. SKINNER WAHAB.
EYES 27. NOSE ONE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. YEA I GOT IT NOW.
SENATOR WIENER, IS HE PREPARED?
FILE ITEM 59. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 960 BY SENATOR
WIENER. AN ACT RELATING TO
TRANSPORTATION. SEN WIENER. I
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT SB
960 WHICH REQUIRES CALTRANS TO
IMPROVE PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLIST
SAFETY AS WELL AS PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION ON CALTRANS OWNED
SURFACE STREETS. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT, STATE OWNED ROADS THAT
ARE REALLY CITY STREETS. THE
BILL CODIFIES THE DEPARTMENT'S
COMPLETE STREETS POLICY BY
REQUIRING SHOP PROJECTS,
STARTING WITH THE 2026 SHOP, TO
INCLUDE PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE
IMPROVEMENTS, AND FOR PROJECTS
COMMENCING WITH THE 2028 SHOP TO
ALSO INCLUDE TRANSIT PRIORITY
IMPROVEMENTS. SB 960 REQUIRES
ENGAGEMENT WITH LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS, ESPECIALLY IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES, IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE PROJECTS,
THE BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
CHANGES TO FREEWAYS. THE BILL
REQUIRES CALTRANS TO DEVELOP BY
JANUARY 1ST, 26 TRANSIT PRIORITY
POLICY TO HELP DEFINE THE
DIFFERENT ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROGRAMS,
DIVISIONS, DISTRICTS, AND
OFFICES, AND SUPPORTING THE
MOVEMENT OF TRANSIT VEHICLES IN
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM,
FINALLY, SB 960 REQUIRES
CALTRANS TO ESTABLISH A
DEDICATED PROJECT INTAKE,
REVIEW, AND APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS, INCLUDING
CITIES AND TRANSIT AGENCIES,
WHICH ARE TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
COMPLETE STREET PROJECTS ON THE
STATE RIGHT OF WAY OR ON
FACILITIES THAT INTERSECT WITH
THE STATE RIGHT OF WAY, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 59 ALAN ALVARADO.
GIL ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NØ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES LAIRD. JONES. NO.
LAIRD. AYE LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OKUBO.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN. ALVARADO.
GIL ARCHULETA. MCGUIRE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. ROTH. IRA. NO
. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. AYES 27. NOES NINE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. OUR MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM 62. SENATOR
ROTH, SHE PREPARED. HE IS
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 885 BY SENATOR ROTH. AN ACT
RELATING TO POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. SENATOR FLORES YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
ANOTHER NURSING BILL FOR OVER 40
YEARS, OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE IN NURSING
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN THE BASIC
CREDENTIAL REQUIREMENT FOR
EMPLOYMENT AS A REGISTERED NURSE
AND A HEALTH CARE FACILITY.
HOWEVER, DUE TO A PUSH BY
CREDENTIALING ORGANIZATIONS TO
INCREASE THE PERCENTAGE OF
NURSES HOLDING BSN DEGREES TO
80% OF THOSE EMPLOYED IN HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES, THE BSN DEGREE,
THE BACHELOR'S DEGREE, IS NOW
BECOMING THE NEW INDUSTRY
STANDARD FOR EMPLOYMENT IN
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS. A BSN ALSO
HAPPENS TO BE A REQUIREMENT FOR
ATTAINMENT OF A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN NURSING AND A DOCTORATE OF
NURSE PRACTICE DEGREE, THOSE
HELD BY FACULTY MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN 2021, A HEALTH
IMPACT REPORT FOUND THAT 18% OF
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS SURVEYED
STATED THAT A BSN WAS REQUIRED
FOR EMPLOYMENT TWICE THE
PERCENTAGE NOTED IN 2017, AND
54.3% REPORTED A PREFERENCE FOR
HIRING BSNS AND MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY, 31.5% OF THE NEW
18 RN SURVEYED. THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE NURSES STATED THAT THE
LACK OF A BSN DEGREE WAS GIVEN
AS THE REASON FOR THEIR FAILURE
TO BE HIRED. THIS DEMAND FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF BSN CREDENTIALED
REGISTERED NURSES CONTINUES TO
INCREASE IN CALIFORNIA, AND OUR
PRODUCTION HAS NOT MET DEMAND.
THIS BILL PROPOSES TO UTILIZE
EXISTING ADN PROGRAMS THAT ARE
UNDERUTILIZED COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ON A LIMITED BASIS TO SUPPLEMENT
THE WORK OF OUR PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE BSN PROGRAMS. TO MEET
THIS DEMAND IN THE STATE, THE
BILL CREATES A PILOT PROGRAM AND
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO SELECT UP TO 15
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS WITH
EXISTING, NATIONALLY ACCREDITED
ADN PROGRAMS TO OFFER A BSN
DEGREE TO UP TO 25% OF EACH ADN
CLASS OR 35 STUDENTS, WHICHEVER
IS GREATER. WHEN STUDENTS ENTER
THE BSN PHASE OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM, THEY WILL HAVE ALREADY
EARNED THEIR ADN PASSED THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL LICENSURE EXAM.
THE NCLEX AND THE SECURED THEIR
RN LICENSE, SO THERE ARE ALREADY
NURSES PARTICIPATING. STUDENTS
WOULD THEN TAKE THE ADDITIONAL
NON-CLINICAL COURSEWORK
NECESSARY TO EARN THE BSN AT
THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
ALLOWING THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK AS NURSES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AROUND THEIR CLASS
SCHEDULE AND FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES. FROM A
CURRICULUM STANDPOINT, THE
NURSING CLINICAL COMPONENT OF
THE ADN PROGRAM IS THE SAME AS
THE CLINICAL PROGRAM APPLICABLE
TO BACHELOR OF SCIENCE IN
NURSING PROGRAMS AND THE NCLEX
AND THE RN LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS ARE THE SAME. THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
PROGRAMS CONSISTS OF
APPROXIMATELY 30 CREDIT HOURS OR
UNITS, WHICH GENERALLY INCLUDE
HUMANITIES AND MANAGEMENT
COURSEWORK IN ONE COMMUNITY
HEALTH COURSE. THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT PRIORITY PARTICIPATION BE
GRANTED TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS LOCATED IN UNDERSERVED
NURSING AREAS, AND REQUIRES THAT
THE STATE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
DEVELOP A PROCESS TO ASSIST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
WITHOUT NATIONAL ACCREDITATION
TO ATTAIN IT PRIOR HUSING,
SPECIFICALLY, THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OF CALIFORNIA, BY SUPPLEMENTING
THE WORK OF OUR EXISTING PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE BSN PROGRAMS IN THIS
WAY, ADDITIONAL BSN DEGREED
NURSES WILL BE ADDED TO THE
WORKFORCE. NURSES WHO ARE
QUALIFIED TO BECOME SUPERVISORS
AND MANAGERS IN HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES, AND NURSES WHO WERE
QUALIFIED TO BECOME MASTERS OR
DOCTORATE DEGREE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS IN INDEPENDENT
PRACTICE SETTINGS AND DODD AS
NURSING SCHOOL FACULTY MEMBERS.
SENATORS. NO ONE SEEMS TO
DISAGREE. THE PUBLIC'S, THE
PRIVATES, THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, THE HEALTH CARE
COMMUNITY THAT WE NEED MORE
CREDENTIALED NURSES NOW AND IN
THE FUTURE. THE STUDIES AND
SURVEYS, THE WORKPLACE AND THE
GROWING TREND TO PREFER BSN
STUDENTS IN HOSPITAL CLINICAL
PLACEMENT PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW,
SPECIFICALLY THOSE DISTRICT AND
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS, ALL TELL
US THAT. SO GIVEN OUR CURRENT
AND FUTURE BUDGET CHALLENGES AND
THE HIGH COST OF SETTING UP AND
EXPANDING UNDERGRADUATE NURSING
PROGRAMS, BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
COST OF THE EQUIPMENT AND THE
BRICK AND MORTAR FACILITIES, AND
THE LOW STUDENT TO FACULTY
RATIOS REQUIRED FOR CLINICAL
PROGRAMS. WHY NOT TRY USING THE
UNDERUTILIZED TEAM MEMBER HERE,
WITH CAMPUSES MOST ACCESSIBLE TO
STUDENTS, ONE WITH A CADRE OF
FULLY TRAINED AND LICENSED ADNS
READY TO EARN THE RELATIVELY FEW
HUMANITIES AND LEADERSHIP COURSE
UNITS REQUIRED FOR THE BSN
CREDENTIAL AT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS THEY
PERFORM CRITICAL HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY DUTIES IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES, IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE USE ALL THE TOOLS IN THE TOOL
CHEST TO ADDRESS THIS NEED. THE
TIME TO TRY IT IS NOW AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY NÓ THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. AM I
CORRECT? IS 37 NOES ZERO? THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING
BACK ON OUR SCHEDULE AND WE'RE
MOVING TO 48. YES, WE'RE MOVING
BACK TO FOLLOWING 48. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, YOU'RE PREPARED,
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1193 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR AN
ACT RELATING TO AVIATION.
SENATOR FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SB 1193
PHASES OUT THE SALE OF SALE OF
HARMFUL LEADED AIRPLANE FUEL
THAT ENDANGERS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PARTICULARLY THE LONG TERM
HEALTH OF CHILDREN. THE SECOND
MOST POLLUTING AIRPORT RESIDES
IN MY DISTRICT AND IT'S
DRASTICALLY IMPACTING MY
COMMUNITY. VÆ. THIS BILL CAME
DIRECTLY FROM MY COMMUNITY
ASKING THAT WE ADDRESS THE
INCREASE OF LEADED AVIATION
POLLUTION IN SD 20 AND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN OCTOBER 2023, THE
FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY ANNOUNCED ITS FINAL
DETERMINATION THAT EMISSIONS OF
LEAD FROM AIRCRAFT THAT USE
LEADED FUEL CAUSE OR CONTRIBUTES
TO AIR POLLUTION THAT ENDANGERS
PUBLIC HEALTH UNDER THE CLEAN
AIR ACT. THERE IS CURRENTLY NO
EVIDENCE OF THRESHOLD WHICH
THERE ARE NO HARMFUL EFFECTS ON
COGNITION FROM LEAD EXPOSURE, NO
LEVEL, NO MATTER HOW LOW IT IS,
IS SAFE, ESPECIALLY FOR CHILDREN
. IN LEADED AVIATION, FUEL IS
MOST COMMONLY USED IN SMALL
PISTON ENGINE AIRCRAFTS AND IS
NOT USED FOR COMMERCIAL FLIGHTS.
LEAD HAS ALREADY BEEN PHASED OUT
OF. AS WE KNOW, MOST OF OUR
PRODUCTS FOR ITS DANGER TO THE
PUBLIC INCLUDED IN PAINT AND OUR
CAR GASOLINE IN CALIFORNIA ACTED
BEFORE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
UNLEADED CAR GASOLINE, AND WAS
ULTIMATELY EXEMPTED FROM THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS BECAUSE OUR
BAN WAS FIRST AND STRONGER.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE WAY WITH REMOVING LEAD
FROM EVERYTHING, INCLUDING
AVIATION FUEL. IN FACT, SANTA
CLARA COUNTY ALREADY BANNED THE
SALE OF LEADED AVIATION FUEL,
AND BUSINESS CONTINUES AS IT WAS
BEFORE. SB 1193 ALIGNS STATE LAW
WITH THE US. EPA'S DETERMINATION
THAT LEADED AIRPLANE FUELS
ENDANGER THE LIVES AND SAFETY OF
CHILDREN AND PUBLIC HEALTH BY
PHASING IN A BAN. HOW WILL SB
1193 PHASE IT IN JUST LIKE THIS?
BY 2027, WE WILL LOOK INTO WE
WILL LOOK TO BAN THE SALE OF
LEADED AVIATION FUEL, FUEL IN OR
ADJACENT TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BY 2028. BAN THE
SALE OF LEAD AVIATION FUEL IN OR
ADJACENT TO URBAN GROWTH
BOUNDARIES, AND THEN FINALLY BAN
IT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA BY
JANUARY FIRST, 2030. WE HAVE
ALSO CREATED AN OPT OUT OPTION
FOR COUNTIES TO PURSUE IF THEY
FIND THAT AN UNLEADED
ALTERNATIVE IS NOT AVAILABLE.
ONCE AGAIN, ENSURING THAT IF
THERE ISN'T AN AVAILABILITY,
THEY CAN OPT OUT. RECENT
APPROPRIATION AMENDS INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING THAT REALLY ADDRESS
SOME OF THE AIRPORT CONCERNS. WE
REMOVED PROVISIONS THAT WOULD
HAVE THAT WOULD HAVE REQUIRED
CALTRANS TO IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES FOR REDUCING PUBLIC
HEALTH BY FOR REDUCING PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPOSURES, TO LEAD
ASSOCIATED WITH AIRPORT
OPERATIONS, AND TO PUBLISH
GUIDANCE FOR AIRPORT OPERATORS
REGARDING BEST PRACTICES. WE
ALSO DELETED PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD HAVE REQUIRED AIRPORT
OPERATORS TO SUBMIT PLANS AND
STATUS REPORTS TO CALTRANS FOR
IMPLEMENTING BEST PRACTICES TO
MINIMIZE IMPACTS. WE RECOGNIZE
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A HUGE BURDEN
ON THE AIRPORT OPERATORS TO DO
THAT. THEREFORE, WE REMOVED THAT
FROM THE BILL. ADDITIONALLY,
SINCE THIS BILL WAS INTRODUCED
SINCE IT CAME OUT OF
TRANSPORTATION, ONE OF THE
LARGEST FUEL DISTRIBUTORS HAS
PARTNERED WITH GÂY TO MAKE THE
FIRST HIGH OCTANE 100 UNLEADED
FUEL COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE AND
SB 1193 PROVISIONS POSSIBLE IN
THE MEDIA FUTURE, AND OTHERS ARE
STILL ARE ALSO IN PROGRESS TO
CREATE COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE
UNLEADED FUEL WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
SEYARTO? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL, BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL,
I'LL START OFF WITH THIS. THE
FAA IS ALREADY WORKING ON A
NATIONWIDE TRANSITION PLAN THAT
ENSURES AN ORDERLY TRANSITION
THÀNH TO UNLEADED FUEL BY 2030.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THIS
ORDERLY TRANSITION BECAUSE
APPROPRIATE FUEL BLEND FOR ALL
TYPES OF SMALL AND MEDIUM
AIRCRAFT ENGINES, BECAUSE YOU
NEED THE CORRECT FUEL BLEND FOR
OPTIMAL ENGINE PERFORMANCE, AND
IT LIMITS THE DAMAGE. AND YOU
ALSO YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO
COORDINATE THIS NATIONWIDE AND
POTENTIALLY HAVE SOME
COORDINATION WITH OUR
NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES BECAUSE
SMALL AIRCRAFT, THE VERY NATURE
OF AIRCRAFT IS THAT YOU'RE
FLYING BECAUSE IT'S EASIER AND
QUICKER THAN DRIVING. AND SO A
LOT OF TIMES YOU ARE DRIVING OR
FLYING TO AN ADJACENT COUNTRY,
SAY, MEXICO OR YOU'RE FLYING
OVER OR YOU'RE FLYING OVER TO
ONE OF OUR OTHER STATES. AND IF
YOU'RE PUTTING HIGH OCTANE FUEL
THAT'S UNLEADED IN CALIFORNIA
AND THEN FLY INTO AN AREA WHERE
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT, THEN YOU
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PUT LEADED
FUEL IN YOUR ENGINE. THAT'S USED
TO HIGH OCTANE UNLEADED FUEL,
WHICH CAUSES YOUR ENGINE TO
KNOCK, AND THAT KNOCKING ISN'T
JUST AN ANNOYING NOISE. I KNEW
THIS BECAUSE I HAD A 78 DOTSON
PICKUP. THAT WAS A IT WAS A GAS.
IT WAS A LEADED GAS PICKUP. I
HAD TO PUT LEAD LEADED ADDITIVE
IN EVERY ONE OF MY THINGS WHEN
THEY SWITCHED OVER COMPLETELY,
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO GET RID
OF THE CAR YET. SO THAT THAT
KNOCKING AND PINGING IS ENGINE
DAMAGE HAPPENING IN REAL TIME IN
YOUR ENGINE AND, AND WHILE IN A
CAR, IF SOMETHING GOES WRONG
WITH YOUR ENGINE AND YOU THROW A
ROD OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT, YOU
CAN PULL OVER AND THE WHEN
YOU'RE IN FLIGHT, YOU CANNOT DO
THAT. SO IT MAKES IT A, IT MAKES
IT DANGEROUS TO BE ABLE TO, IF
YOU DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT FUEL
AND YOUR ENGINE ISN'T USED TO
THAT, YOU CAN'T SWITCH BLENDS
FROM ONE TIME. YOU KNOW, ONE
TYPE OF BLEND TO ANOTHER. AND IF
IT'S NOT AVAILABLE, THEN THE
LOGISTICS OF YOUR TRIP BECOME
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT. AND, THERE
ARE OTHER MAJOR SOURCES OF LEAD
THAT CAN ACCOUNT FOR A LOT OF
THE, THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
HAVING WITH LEAD. AND THEY'RE
VERY COMMON. THE SOIL THAT WE
WALK ON, HOUSEHOLD DUST,
POTTERY, TOYS, SOME COSMETICS
HAVE LEAD IN IT. HERBAL OR FOLK
REMEDIES CAN BE FROM MEXICO THAT
IS MADE WITH TAMARIND HAS LEAD
IN IT. AND OF COURSE IF YOU'RE
AT A FIRING RANGE FIRING BULLETS
, YOU'RE EXPOSING YOURSELF TO
LEAD. THEY'RE ALSO AN
OCCUPATIONALLY. IF YOU ARE
WORKING IN AUTO REPAIR, MINING,
PIPE FITTING, AND ALSO
CONSTRUCTION, ALL OF THESE
THINGS EXPOSE YOU TO LEAD AND
NOT MUCH AND PROBABLY GREATER
QUANTITIES THAN A PLANE. THAT'S
FLYING OVERHEAD. SO I THINK WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THIS. I
THINK WE NEED TO LET THE FAA DO
THEIR JOB AND ENSURE THAT THERE
IS A SAFE CORE AND SAFELY MANAGE
AND COORDINATE THE RESPONSIBLE
TRANSITION TO A FUEL BLEND OR
FUEL BLENDS THAT OFFER THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF PROTECTIONS
FOR THE AVIATION EQUIPMENT THAT
SERVES THE FLYING PUBLIC. I ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE. I ASK YOU TO
LET THE FAA DO THEIR JOB. THIS
IS IN THEIR PURVIEW AND NOT PUT
CALIFORNIA ON A FLYING ISLAND.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM?
HEARING. SEEING NONE. SENATOR
MACGYVER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR
FROM, MURIETTA TO BRING FOR
BRINGING UP OTHER ITEMS THAT
CURRENTLY CONTAIN LEAD. I HOPE
EVERY SINGLE COLLEAGUE HERE NEXT
YEAR INTRODUCES A BILL TO REMOVE
LEAD FROM THOSE ITEMS THAT THE
MEMBER BROUGHT UP TODAY, BECAUSE
THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD
ANYWHERE. AND I THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE REMOVING
LEAD FROM EVERY SINGLE OPTION.
BUT I'M GOING TO START FROM LEAD
IN AVIATION FUEL. AND THIS IS
WHY I INTRODUCED THE BILL,
BECAUSE I WASN'T AWARE OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT CONTAINED
LEAD. AND I'LL MAKE SURE I COME
BACK AND FOCUS ON THOSE ITEMS
NEXT YEAR. FOR NOW, I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I'M PROTECTING THE
CHILDREN IN MY DISTRICT FROM THE
SECOND MOST POLLUTED AIRPORT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE TOP TEN IN
THE UNITED STATES. THERE IS NO
SAFE LEVEL. I RECOGNIZE RIGHT
NOW THAT THERE ISN'T A DIRECTLY,
RIGHT NOW, COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE UNLEADED FUEL, BUT
WE'RE ON THE PATH FORWARD. WE
ALREADY LED THE WAY WITH
REMOVING LEAD FROM OUR CARS AND
AGAIN, CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE
WAY. WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS. THE GOOD THING
IS THAT UNLEADED FUEL IS A DROP
IN REPLACEMENT. NO, NO TANK.
NOTHING HAS TO BE CHANGED. NO
ENGINE HAS TO BE CHANGED FROM
FROM THE FROM THE, AIRPLANES
BECAUSE IT'S A DROP IN.
ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL DOES NOT
SAY THAT YOU CANNOT FLY INTO
CALIFORNIA CARRYING LEADED FUEL.
IT ONLY SAYS THAT CALIFORNIA
WILL PHASE OUT THE SALE OF
LEADED FUEL. SO SOMEONE FROM OUR
NEIGHBORING, STATES CAN STILL
FLY INTO CALIFORNIA. THEY JUST
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE WHEN THEY'RE
GOING TO REFUEL AND THEY'RE
LOOKING TO PURCHASE. IF THEY
DIDN'T BRING EXTRA WITH THEM. I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S ACTUALLY
TRUE, SO MAYBE I'LL PULL THAT
COMMENT BACK, IS THAT THEY'LL
HAVE TO BUY UNLEADED FUEL AT THE
END OF THE DAY. THIS IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OF OUR OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR NIVO. THANK YOU ALL.
DEBATE HAVING CEASED ON THIS
ITEM, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 48 ADAM
ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
AYE Ã. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA
NO. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMMER. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ADAM ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. BRADFORD AYE. ROTH.
AYE. 29 NOS. EIGHT. MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR CORTEZ, ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR FILE ITEM 51?
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1298 BY SENATOR CORTEZ AND
ACT RELATING TO ENERGY. SENATOR
CORTEZ, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB 1298, A BILL THAT
INCREASES THE THRESHOLD FOR DATA
CENTER ELIGIBILITY FOR
CONSIDERATION UNDER THE SMALL
POWER PLANT EXEMPTION PROCESS
FROM 100MW TO 150MW. THIS BILL
WILL CREATE LARGER DATA CENTER
FACILITIES THAT BETTER MEET THE
DEMANDS OF CALIFORNIA INDUSTRIES
. ESSENTIALLY, IT WILL CREATE
MORE WHERE WE HAVE A SERIOUS
VACANCY PROBLEM RIGHT NOW, THE
SMALLER POWER PLANTS SMALL POWER
PLANT EXEMPTION PROGRAM ALLOWS
CEC TO EXEMPT FROM ITS LICENSING
AUTHORITY THERMAL POWER PLANTS
THAT DO NOT EXCEED 100MW. THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION CAN
GRANT AN EXEMPTION IF IT FINDS
THAT THE PROPOSED FACILITY WOULD
NOT SUBSTANTIALLY IMPACT THE
ENVIRONMENT OR ENERGY RESOURCES
IF THE EXEMPTION IS APPROVED.
THE PROJECT DEVELOPERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SECURING ALL
LOCAL, STATE AND FEDERAL PERMITS
TO CONSTRUCT AND SAFELY OPERATE
THE FACILITIES SO THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING TO IMPACT LOCAL LAND USE
DECISIONS ON POWER PLANTS, DATA
CENTERS. I'M SORRY. THIS BILL AT
ITS CORE IS AN ECONOMIC
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL. THE DATA
CENTERS ARE NECESSARY, AS WE
KNOW AND ARE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THEY'RE THE
BACKBONE NOT JUST FOR APPS AND
PLATFORMS AND SERVICES INTEGRAL
TO DAILY LIFE, BUT HOSPITALS AND
OTHER LIFE SAVING ENDEAVORS AS
WELL. CONNECTING INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS. ÓRDENES NOT JUST
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, BUT
WORLDWIDE. DESPITE THE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES MADE IN
RECENT YEARS TO EXPAND THE DATA
CENTER CAPACITY, THE DEMAND FOR
DIGITAL SERVICES CONTINUES TO
SURGE. CURRENTLY IN SILICON
VALLEY, THE VACANCY RATE FOR
DATA CENTERS IS DOWN TO A MERE
1.6. AN AYE VOTE TODAY WOULD
ENSURE THAT WE'RE MAINTAINING
THE STATE'S ECONOMIC VITALITY
AND BUILDING OUT CAPACITY FOR
FUTURE GROWTH. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
SKINNER? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS, I LAID OFF
OF THIS, AND WHILE I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE NECESSITY OF DATA
CENTERS, THEY ARE ONE OF THEY
ARE, AS THE AUTHOR DESCRIBED,
EXTRAORDINARY CONSUMERS OF
ELECTRICITY. AND AS WE ARE
ENGAGED IN TRYING TO MOVE
CALIFORNIA TO MORE ELECTRICITY
TO ELECTRIFY OUR TRANSPORTATION,
FOR EXAMPLE, AND MANY OTHER, THE
DEMAND ON ELECTRICITY IS GOING
TO BE GREATER AND GREATER. AND
WHILE THIS IS JUST A FACT, WE
NEED TO BE CREATIVE ABOUT HOW TO
MEET IT AND USING, POLLUTING
GENERATORS TO DO SO OR, OR
FURTHER POLLUTING POWER PLANTS
TO DO SO IS NOT GOING TO BE IN
ANY OF OUR INTERESTS. SO WE
REALLY NEED THE INDUSTRY, THE
DATA CENTER, THE ENTITIES THAT
ARE DEPENDENT ON THEM TO ENGAGE
WITH US AND TO REALLY FIGURE OUT
HOW BEST TO MEET THESE NEEDS
WITHOUT NECESSARILY CREATING
MORE RELIANCE ON, POWER SOURCES
THAT CREATE EMISSIONS, WHICH IS
WHY THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. SO I'M STAYING OFF THE
BILL BECAUSE WHILE I COMPLETELY
APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR THIS
ELECTRICITY SOURCE, THIS POWER I
ALSO WANT TO SEE MORE CREATIVITY
IN HOW IT IS MET. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SENATOR DALLI, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I,
STAN, I'D IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND I WANT TO I WE HAD THIS BILL
IN COMMITTEE AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE. DATA CENTERS
ARE THE BACKUP FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY. THEY'RE THE BACKUP FOR
OUR LAPTOPS, OUR CELL PHONES.
ALL THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE
DEVELOPED IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
WORLD TO USE AND THESE THESE ARE
GENERATORS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
USED. YES. AND THEY ARE OPERATED
OFF OF DIESEL. THE SENATOR FROM
SANTA CLARITA, I BELIEVE, ASKED
THE QUESTION OF HOW LONG DO THEY
RUN? SEVEN HOURS A YEAR. THEY
RUN FOR TESTING JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE AVAILABLE. SO
WHEN THE WHEN THE POWER GOES
OUT, THEY RUN AN AVERAGE OF 40
HOURS THROUGH THE YEAR. THEY RUN
IN AN AIR DISTRICT. THAT IS
GREAT CLEAN AIR, THE COAST WHERE
ALL THE WEALTHY PEOPLE LIVE,
THAT DRIVE TESLAS, THAT POLLUTE
THE PEOPLE IN THE VALLEY, THAT'S
FOR ANOTHER DAY, THOUGH.
CALIFORNIA IS LOSING BUSINESS
BECAUSE OF THIS KIND OF BECAUSE
OF STOPPING GOOD PROJECTS LIKE
THIS RIGHT HERE. MEMBERS. LET'S
NOT LET THE PERFECT GET IN THE
WAY OF THE GOOD. THE GOOD HERE
IS THAT WE CAN DEVELOP THESE
DATA CENTERS. WE CAN KEEP THOSE
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA, AND WE CAN
HAVE OUR PUBLIC SAFETY WORK WHEN
THE POWER GOES OUT, BECAUSE THE
POWER WILL GO OUT. WE'LL HAVE A
FIRE, WE'LL HAVE A DROUGHT,
WE'LL HAVE A CLOUD COVER COME
IN. OUR SOLAR DOESN'T WORK, AND
WE'LL NEED TO TURN THESE
GENERATORS ON SO WE CAN BE SAFE.
SO FOR THAT AND MANY OTHER
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THIS IS A GREAT
BILL. IT MEETS THE TARGET THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO MEET. AND IT
REALLY DOESN'T HARM THE
ENVIRONMENT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THIS IS JUST GOOD POLICY.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL A ROLL.
WHAT? OH I'M SORRY, SENATOR
CORTEZ, PLEASE CLOSE. YOU KNOW,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF. MR. PRESIDENT, I
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
DIESEL THAT'S REFERENCED IN SOME
OF THE COMMENTS HERE IS THE
BACKUP GENERATORS FOR THE POWER
PLANTS. IT'S NOT THE PRIMARY
ENERGY FOR THE POWER PLANTS,
WHICH IS WHY IN SOME OF THE
OTHER COMMENTS, YOU HEARD THAT
THESE BACKUP GENERATORS ARE ONLY
COMING ON 0.07% OF THE TIME, AND
THAT'S BY THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY DISTRICT'S OWN FIGURES,
PUBLISHED FIGURES, WHICH WE
INCORPORATED INTO THE TALKING
POINTS FOR THE BILL. AND THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT DIESEL, AS WE
ALL ARE. WE'RE TRYING TO PHASE
IT OUT BY 33. EVERYONE IS TRYING
TO COME UP AS WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR THE LAST FEW DAYS HERE WITH
ALTERNATIVES, AND THOSE WILL
COME IN THE MEANWHILE, WE HAVE A
BIT OF A CRISIS IN THAT THE DATA
CENTERS THEMSELVES CAN'T OPERATE
, SEAMLESSLY WITHOUT HAVING A
BACKUP SYSTEM FUELED BY
SOMETHING. LANGUAGE HAS BEEN
IMPOSED BY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THAT I THINK ADDRESSES
THE ISSUE, LANGUAGE AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN IN THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE TO REDUCE THE
THRESHOLD FROM 200MW TO 150MW,
AND THEN IN APPROPRIATIONS,
THERE WAS FURTHER LANGUAGE,
WHICH SAYS THAT THE LOWEST
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE
EMISSIONS OF CRITERIA, AIR
POLLUTANTS, TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS AND GREENHOUSE
GASES WILL MUST RESULT FROM THE
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION OF
THE FACILITY. THAT'S PRETTY
STRONG LANGUAGE, AND WE THINK
IT'S GOOD ENOUGH TO ADDRESS, THE
ISSUES. AND HOPEFULLY THE POWER
PLANTS CAN STILL BE BUILT UNDER
THAT CRITERIA. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY NOW CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 51. ALAN ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY I
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN GLASER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR MEN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
NILO I OCHOA BOG I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SECRETO I SKINNER. SMALLWOOD,
CUEVAS I STERN UMBERG I WAHAB I
WIENER WILK I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN, ARCHULETA,
BLAKE SPEER I EGGMAN MCGUIRE,
MENGIBAR NGUYEN I SKINNER. STERN
WIENER. RESTROOM. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE. ALL RIGHT.
AYES 32, NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 63 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 897 BY SENATOR NEWMAN. AN
ACT RELATING TO PUPIL ATTENDANCE
. SEN. NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
897, WHICH WOULD STRENGTHEN THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT OF CHOICE
PROGRAM BY REMOVING THE EXISTING
SUNSET FOR MORE THAN 30 YEARS,
THE DISTRICT OF CHOICE PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA HAS ALLOWED
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES FROM
ACROSS THE STATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRANSFER TO ANY PARTICIPATING
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR PLACE OF
RESIDENCE AND IRRESPECTIVE OF
THEIR ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE,
ATHLETIC ABILITY, RACE, OR ANY
OTHER PROTECTED CLASS. ACCORDING
TO AN EVALUATION BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE,
THE PROGRAM HAS SUCCEEDED IN
PROVIDING STUDENTS ACCESS TO AN
AVERAGE OF 5 TO 7 NEW COURSES.
MOREOVER, THE LAW ALSO FOUND
THAT THIS PROGRAM CREATES A
COMPETITIVE LOCAL DYNAMIC WHICH
IMPROVES COURSE OFFERINGS EVEN
FOR STUDENTS THAT DO NOT
PARTICIPATE IN A NEIGHBORING
DISTRICT OF CHOICE PROGRAM. SB
897 897 WOULD SEEK TO MAKE THIS
PROVEN PUBLIC EDUCATION PROGRAM
PERMANENT BY ELIMINATING THE
SUNSET, AS WELL AS IMPLEMENTING
SEVERAL OF THE LAWS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROMOTE
EQUITY AND REDUCE BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE TODAY ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS, THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
AYES 37. NOES ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
JONES. FILE ITEM 70. HE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1074 BY SENATOR
JONES AND EQUALITY TO SEXUAL
VIOLENT PREDATORS, AND DECLARE
THE URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
JONES FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND SENATORS, I
RISE TO PRESENT SB 1074, WHICH
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT TO
THE PROCESS BY WHICH A SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATOR, OR SVP, IS
RELEASED BACK TO THE COMMUNITY.
AN SVP IS AN INDIVIDUAL
CONVICTED OF A SEXUALLY VIOLENT
OFFENSE AND DIAGNOSED WITH A
MENTAL DISORDER THAT CAUSES THEM
TO BE A DANGER TO OTHERS WITH A
HIGH LIKELIHOOD TO REOFFEND.
CURRENTLY, THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS DODGES ITS
RESPONSIBLE DUTIES TO PLACE AND
MONITOR SVP BY CONTRACTING OUT
WITH PRIVATE VENDORS WHO PLACE
PROFIT OVER PUBLIC SAFETY. SB
1074 WILL HOLD THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING VENDORS CONSIDER PUBLIC
SAFETY IN ALL PLACEMENTS OF SVP.
THIS BILL ALSO MANDATES THE
DEPARTMENT APPROVE ANY LEASE
BEFORE IT IS SIGNED BY THE
VENDOR. SB 1074 ENSURES THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
MAINTAINS INVOLVEMENT IN THE
PLACEMENT OF SVP AND PREVENTS
THE DEPARTMENT FROM ENTIRELY
OFFLOADING ITS DUTY ONTO PRIVATE
COMPANIES. I WANT TO THANK MY
OUR THE MULTIPLE COAUTHORS, BUT
ESPECIALLY OUR MY COAUTHOR FROM
JACKSON AND WHO'S BEEN VERY
HELPFUL IN GETTING THIS
ADDRESSED. AND ALL THE MEMBERS
THAT VOTED FOR THIS BILL IN
PUBLIC SAFETY AND APPROPS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE
ITEM 70? HEARING AND SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 37. NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY. AYES 37. NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. MEASURE. PASSES
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 71 BY
SENATOR BLACKSHEAR. SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE BILL 1092 BY SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR. AN ACT RELATING TO
COASTAL RESOURCES. SENATOR
BLACKSHEAR. YES. THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB 1092, WHICH
WILL REQUIRE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO STUDY, STUDY THE
SYSTEMIC DELAYS IN THE PERMIT
APPEALS PROCESS FOR HOUSING
PROJECTS IN THE COASTAL ZONE AND
REQUIRE FOR A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON ACTIONS THEY
RECOMMEND TAKING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. MEMBERS. I'M MOVING THIS
BILL FORWARD BECAUSE IN THE
MIDST OF OUR HOUSING CRISIS,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
ARE COMING FORWARD AND TELLING
US THAT THEY NOT ONLY STRUGGLE
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEAR
THE COAST, BUT SOME OF THEIR
BOARDS WON'T EVEN CONSIDER IT
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITY,
LENGTHY DELAYS AND UNCERTAINTIES
THAT MAKE IT FINANCIALLY
UNFAVORABLE TO EVEN TRY. SB 1092
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN VOTES
AND POLICY COMMITTEES, AND HAS
SUPPORT FROM COASTAL CITIES AND
HOUSING ADVOCACY GROUPS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING
AND SEEING. NONE. MEMBERS. THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLLCALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
? SEEING NO OBJECTION. AYES 37.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
73 BY SENATOR GLAZER. HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1256 BY
SENATOR GLAZER IN AQUITANIA
CRIMES. SENATOR GLAZER, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SENATE BILL
1256 ADDS A DNA COLLECTION TO A
NARROW CLASS OF CRIMES
PROSTITUTION WITH A MINOR. WHEN
THE PERSON HAS A PRIOR
CONVICTION, IT DOESN'T CHANGE
ANY PENALTIES. SO THE QUESTION
IS WHY? AND LET ME GIVE YOU AN
INTERESTING STUDY DONE BY THE
OAKLAND POLICE DEPARTMENT
HOMICIDE DIVISION, WHICH FOUND
THAT OF THE 200 UNSOLVED
HOMICIDES IN OAKLAND, 85% OF
THEM INVOLVED A VICTIM WHO WAS A
PROSTITUTE. SO WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE A NEW TOOL FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THIS CLASS OF CRIME
COLLECTION OF DNA FOR SOMEONE
WHO HAS PROSTITUTION, WITH
PROSTITUTION, WITH A MINOR, WITH
PRIOR CONVICTION. SO IT'S MODEST
AND NARROW, BUT HOPEFULLY
HELPFUL. WITH THAT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
FILE ON 73? SEEING NO OBJECTION.
HEARING NO OBJECTION. AYES 37.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW ON TO FILE ITEM 74. SENATOR
STERN, ARE YOU PREPARED?
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1277 BY SENATOR STERN. AN
EQUALITY TO PUPIL INSTRUCTION.
SENATOR STERN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS ABOUT EMPOWERING
TEACHERS TO TEACH ABOUT GENOCIDE
AND HOLOCAUST IN OUR CLASSROOMS.
IT'S SUPPORTED BY A WIDE GROUP
OF GROUPS. THE ARMENIANS,
BOSNIAN GENOCIDE SURVIVORS,
INDIGENOUS AMERICAN SURVIVORS,
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE SURVIVORS,
UYGHUR SURVIVORS, GUATEMALAN,
RWANDAN AS WELL AS NUMEROUS
JEWISH GROUPS WHO ARE
REPRESENTING HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
AND THE NEED FOR EDUCATION.
WE'RE TRYING TO TRAIN 8500
TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA THROUGH
INSTITUTES. WE'VE ALREADY FUNDED
THIS. THIS WOULD SIMPLY CODIFY
THE LAST THREE YEARS OF WORK
WE'VE DONE HERE INTO LAW, AND
HOPEFULLY EMPOWER OUR TEACHERS
TO TEACH RIGHT THROUGH THIS VERY
DIFFICULT MOMENT IN OUR HISTORY.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE MEMBERS. THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL?
SEEING NO OBJECTION. HEARING NO
OBJECTION AYES 7037. NO. ZERO ON
MY 74 MEASURE. PASSES FOLLOWING
74, I SHOULD SAY. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 76.
SENATOR WILK, HE'S READY TO GO.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1359 BY SENATOR WILK ENACT
RELATED TO ILLEGAL DUMPING.
SENATOR WILK, THE FLOOR IS YOURS
. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
PRESENT TO YOU SB 1359, WHICH
PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED RELIEF FOR
RURAL AREAS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE BEEN DECIMATED FROM
TRUCK OWNER OPERATORS DUMPING
WASTE MATERIALS THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES. UNREGULATED DUMPING
HAS WREAKED HAVOC ON THESE
COMMUNITIES, RESULTING IN SEVERE
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION AND
UNSAFE LIVING CONDITIONS. IT HAS
BEEN SUCH A PERSISTENT PROBLEM
BECAUSE PROPERTY OWNERS AND
TRUCK OPERATORS HAVE BEEN
EXPLOITING A LEGAL LOOPHOLE.
CURRENTLY, PERMITS ARE REQUIRED
TO DUMP OR RECEIVE WASTE
MATERIAL, MATERIALS ANYWHERE
OTHER THAN A LICENSED FACILITY,
UNLESS IT OCCURS ON PRIVATE
PROPERTY WITH THE OWNER'S
PERMISSION. CONSEQUENTLY,
BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE BEEN PAYING
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS A FEE TO
USE THEIR PROPERTY AS A DUMP
SITE TO AVOID THE HIGH COST OF
LIFE OF LICENSED FACILITIES.
WHILE PROPERTY OWNERS POCKET THE
MONEY. SB 1359 CLOSES THIS LOOP
HOLE BY REQUIRING A PERMIT FOR
DUMPING ON PRIVATE PROPERTY,
WITH OR WITHOUT THE OWNER'S
PERMISSION. THE BILL WAS AMENDED
IN APPROPRIATIONS TO REMOVE
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS AND
INCREASE FINES, SO THERE'S NO
PENALTY ENHANCEMENTS IN THIS
BILL. CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE WILL
PROTECT MY COMMUNITIES AND OTHER
RURAL AREAS FROM BAD ACTORS WHO
HAVE PROFITED FROM DESTROYING
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS WITHOUT ANY
FAIR CONSEQUENCES. RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING NONE. THIS
WAS ELIGIBLE, BUT WE HAVE AN
OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DEL. AYE DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
I. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA.
AYE. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
ARCHULETA. BLAKE. SPEER. DURAZZO
LIMON. MCGUIRE AYES 34. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 77.
SENATOR DALLI, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1423 BY SENATOR DALLI. AN
ACT RELATING TO MEDICAL. SENATOR
DALLI, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SB 1423 CRITICAL
ACCESS HOSPITALS. CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS ARE FACING A CRISIS.
HOSPITALS ARE FACED WITH
INCREASED LABOR EXPENSES, THE
EXPANSION OF MEDI-CAL, STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND EXPENSIVE BUILDING
REGULATIONS. RIGHT NOW, MANY
RURAL HOSPITALS ARE LOSING MONEY
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL CARE TO
PATIENTS ON AN AVERAGE, AND
THEY'RE ON THE VERGE OF CLOSING.
SINCE 2019, THE PERCENTAGE OF
RURAL HOSPITALS LOSING MONEY HAS
INCREASED FROM 40 TO 50. THE 37
CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA SERVE RURAL AREAS AND
SUPPORT THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN OUR STATE. TO
KEEP THESE ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES OPEN. SB 1423
REQUIRES THAT EACH PARTICIPATED
CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITAL SHALL
BE REIMBURSED THE FULL 100% OF
THEIR PROJECTED COST FOR
MEDI-CAL INPATIENT, OUTPATIENT,
AND SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
TO BE GIVEN THE CRITICAL ACCESS
DESIGNATION, HOSPITALS MUST BE
HAVE OVER 25 FEWER ACUTE CARE
INPATIENT BEDS BE LOCATED MORE
THAN 35 MILES FROM ANOTHER
HOSPITAL, OR MORE THAN 15 MILES
FROM ANOTHER HOSPITAL IN AN AREA
WITH MOUNTAINOUS TERRAIN OR ONLY
SECONDARY ROADS MAINTAIN AN
AVERAGE LENGTH OF STAY OF 96
HOURS OR LESS FOR ACUTE CARE
PATIENTS, AND PROVIDE 24 OVER
SEVEN EMERGENCY CARE SERVICES.
MEMBERS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON SENATE BILL 1423.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
MEASURE? HEARING AND SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 37. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEKAI FIRST
UP IS FILE ITEM 78. DONE. AND
WE'VE ALREADY DONE 78. THEN
WE'RE DOING AYZENBERG. SENATOR
UMBERG FILE ITEM 84. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 919 BY
SENATOR UMBERG. AN ACT RELATING
TO FRANCHISES. SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SB 919
WILL INCREASE TRANSPARENCY IN
THE FRANCHISE SALES PROCESS FOR
PROSPECTIVE FRANCHISEES AND URGE
AND I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? I'M HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 84 ADDED
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO AYE. OCHOA
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN. ARCHULETA.
CABALLERO AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. 36
NOES ONE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR MENGIBAR, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE? UNDER MOTIONS OR
RESOLUTIONS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS, I'D LIKE TO, REMOVE
. I WOULD LIKE TO PLACE FILE
ITEM 31, SB 1497 ON THE INACTIVE
FILE. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS. THERE'S ONLY FIVE MORE
BILLS LEFT FOR THIS EVENING, SO
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THAT YOU
REMAIN ON THE FLOOR. SO WE CAN
GET THROUGH THIS. AND THEN,
DINNER WILL BE SERVED AND I
THINK WE'LL BE DONE FOR THE
EVENING.
SENATORS, WE ARE ENTERING THE
SENATOR BRADFORD. SHOW THE NEXT
FIVE ITEMS ARE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. WE'RE GOING TO START
OFF WITH FIVE. ITEM 24.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1059 BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
AN ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. 1059 WILL
ASSIST LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRIES
WITH, ALLEVIATING SOME OF THE
TREMENDOUS TAX BURDENS THAT
PLACED ON THIS INDUSTRY.
CURRENTLY, IT'S ABOUT 40% HIGHER
AT A LEGAL, DISPENSARY. THIS
BILL WOULD ELIMINATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COLLECTION OF TAX ON
A TAX. PROBABLY THE ONLY
INDUSTRY THAT DOES SUCH SB 1059
ADDRESSES THE ISSUES AND ENSURES
TAXES ARE BASED ON THE ACTUAL
GOODS BEING SOLD. IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE, ANY DISCUSSION.
ITEM 24. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MINH. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BORG AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SATO AYE.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ARCHULETA. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. MCGUIRE. NGUYEN RUBIO.
SKINNER AYE. AYES 34. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
FOUR WILL BE VOTED ON. MEMBERS
IS FIVE. ITEM 26, 29, 34, 45.
SENATOR BRADFORD IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1292 BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
AN ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
SEN THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
1292 WOULD REQUIRE THE PUC TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE INCOME
BASED FIXED CHARGE AND ITS
IMPACTS ON CUSTOMERS BEFORE
MAKING ANY FUTURE ADJUSTMENTS. A
FIXED CHARGE HAS THE POTENTIAL
OF NOT ONLY INCENTIVIZING
INVESTMENTS IN ELECTRIFICATION
AND REDUCE SEASONAL BILL
VOLATILITY. IT IS STATUTORY AND
STATUTORILY REQUIRED TO REDUCE
UTILITY BILLS FOR LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUC MOVES IN A REASONABLE
DIRECTION, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON ITEM 26. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI I. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MEN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE. OCHOA
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO ACIERTO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. GROVE
AYE. MCGUIRE OCHOA. BORG. AYES
36. NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR BRADFORD IS PREPARED FOR
FILE ITEM 29. PLEASE READ
SECRETARY, SENATE BILL 1328 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD. AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
BRADFORD, THANK YOU. 1328
UPDATES AND MAKES CLEAR EXISTING
LAWS, PROCEDURES AND
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO ELECTION
TECHNOLOGY. CALIFORNIA HAS SOME
OF THE MOST STRINGENT VOTING
SYSTEM. TESTING AND
CLARIFICATIONS AND USE USE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE COUNTRY.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE SOME LAW
EXISTING LAWS ON STORAGE AND
MAINTENANCE THAT NEED FURTHER
CLARIFICATION. THIS BILL ENSURES
THE PRESERVATION OF ELECTION
MATERIALS, COVER THE LIFECYCLE
OF THE VOTING TECHNOLOGY, AND
THIS BILL CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
RELATED TO CRIME OF INTERFERING
WITH VOTING TO CONFIRM, CONFORM
PERM WITH CURRENT TECHNOLOGY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ DALLI. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR AYE. MIN.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO.
AYE. OCHOA PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
DALLI. EGGMAN AYE. GROVE. AYE
MCGUIRE. MIN AYE. OKUBO. UMMER
AYE. AYE AYES 35. NØ ZERO. ON
THE URGENCY. EYES 35. NO. ZERO
IN THE MEASURE. PASSES FOR ITEM
34. SENATOR IS READY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1383 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD. AN ACT
RELATING TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU,
THIS IS A CLEAN UP TO A BILL I
AUTHORED, IN THE ASSEMBLY, THE
BROADBAND HOUSING ACCOUNT.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE BROADBAND
PUBLIC HOUSING ACCOUNT CONTINUES
TO BE WOEFULLY UNDERUTILIZED AND
TO SOLVE THIS, SB 1383 MAKES
THREE CHANGES. IT WIDENS THE
ELIGIBILITY APPLICANT POOL OF
CALIFORNIA'S BROADBAND PUBLIC
HOUSING ACCOUNT. IT CLARIFIES
THAT NEW INTERNET SUBSCRIPTION
PLANS CAN BE PROVIDED FOR FREE
OR AT LOW COST TO THE COMMUNITY.
IT ENABLES THE BROADBAND PUBLIC
HOUSING ACCOUNT TO AWARD GRANTS
TO DEPLOY DEVICES THAT CAN
IMPROVE EXISTING BROADBAND
SERVICES. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEE, THE SECRET IS TO
TAKE UP YOUR BILLS. AT THE END
OF THE DAY, NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. ANY
OBJECTION? NØ, WE HAVE AN
OBJECTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE.
MINH. AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA AYE.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN. ARCHULETA.
GONZALEZ GROVE. AYE. MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE. AYE AYES 37. NØ ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES LAST, BUT
DEFINITELY NOT LEAST, FIVE. ITEM
45. SENATOR IS STILL READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1109 BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
AN ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. 1109 IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE THAT
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL TO COLLECT AND
REPORT DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
OF CANNABIS LICENSEES. THIS IS
VOLUNTARILY VERY MUCH SO FOR ALL
THE LICENSEES. IN RECENT YEARS,
THE LEGISLATURE HAS FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CANNABIS MARKET IS INCLUSIVE AND
SUPPORTIVE OF INDIVIDUALS
IMPACTED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS, AS
INTENDED BY THE PASSAGE OF PROP
64. MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE EXPERIENCED DIFFICULTY
ENTERING THE MARKET AND CONTEND
THAT THE MARKET CONTINUES TO
LACK DIVERSITY, WHICH IT DOES.
85% OF THIS MARKET RIGHT NOW IS
WHITE MALE DOMINATED, AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR WOMEN
ARE DISABLED VETERANS AND OUR
DIVERSE COMMUNITY ARE PART OF
THIS. SB 1109 WILL HELP PROVIDE
NECESSARY TRANSPARENCY ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS INDUSTRY,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE, ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. BORG.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO SUGIARTO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN ARCHULETA. DALY.
GROVE JONES. NGUYEN NILO.
OCAMPO. RUBIO AYE. AYES 31. NOES
ONE. THE MEASURE PASSES. IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS, MR.
PRO TEM, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS, WE HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS
TO END WITH HERE THIS EVENING.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DISPENSE WITH
JUST UNDER 60 BILLS OVER THE
LAST TWO DAYS. THANKS TO YOUR
HARD WORK, WE HAVE BEEN
TRUCKING. WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
APPROXIMATELY 260, 270 BILLS AND
IT IS WHY WE ARE ABOUT TO
ADJOURN AT 5 P.M. AND WHY WE ARE
NOT GOING TO COME INTO SESSION
TOMORROW UNTIL 2 P.M. SO HERE'S
THE GOOD NEWS FOR TOMORROW. NOT
ONLY ARE WE NOT GOING TO COME IN
UNTIL 2 P.M, THE ENTIRE UNIVERSE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH ON THE FLOOR
IN ADDITION TO OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR IS APPROXIMATELY 20 TO
30 BILLS TOMORROW. SO YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE A CONSENT CALENDAR
TOMORROW. PLUS APPROXIMATELY 20
TO 30 BILLS. AND THEN ON FRIDAY
YOU'LL SEE ANOTHER CONSENT
CALENDAR AND POTENTIALLY A
COUPLE OF BILLS. LET'S HOPE NOT.
SO AMAZING WORK BY THIS BODY. WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND UNTIL TOMORROW, MAY 23RD
WE'LL SEE YOU AT 2 P.M. AND I
THINK WE ALSO NEED TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE STAFF, BOTH THE DESK
STAFF, THE REPUBLICAN STAFF, THE
DEMOCRATIC STAFF. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IF WE CAN GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR ALL THE
WORK THEY'VE BEEN PUTTING IN, AS
WELL. MADAM PRESIDENT, WE'LL SEE
YOU TOMORROW AT 2 P.M. THE
SENATE IS ADJOURNED. WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY, MAY 23RD,
2004, AT 2 P.M. DINNER IS
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW.